before you watch this exclusive
interview with Andrew Tate there are a
few things you need to know Andrew is
taking a massive risk agreeing to do
this 5 hour and 20 minute interview
because he is still under house arrest
and under investigation which means
anything he says can and will be held
against him now what did we talk about
in this interview we talked about his
experience in jail with Tristan untold
stories religion how this impacted his
life how emotional was it was he scared
you're going to see a side of him you've
never seen before we definitely talked
about BBC BBC is not going to like this
interview for many reasons you'll see
why it's a total of 15 hours that we
spend with Andrew and Tristan at his
compound so a lot was covered having
said that there's about 45 minutes of
this interview that will be censored due
to the topic of discussion being around
his investigation and Romania so if you
want to see that 45 minute portion you
will need to text the word Tate to 3 one
zero three four zero one one three two
or click on a link below to subscribe to
an email for that to be sent to you
after his investigation or indictment is
public having said that brace for impact
you're about to be valuetained by the
one and only Andrew Tate
I'm winning too well I'm scared by the
incompetence of these clowns
[Music]
this guy's so innocent how can they get
you to go to the dungeon for 92 days how
can they put you on house arrests how
can they do all this stuff
[Music]
they could do this to you
they can do this to anyone later to you
or you or me or any man watching this
any man watching this I wake up
instinctually at 5am because that's when
they read your house I wake up at like 4
59 I just [__] shoot up
fallen so many times because they
thought they can get away with murder
and then eventually people said listen
stop you're not gonna do this to me
anymore we're not we're not going to
take a sense when I destroyed the BBC my
brother was celebrating I knew it was
interesting enough you don't beat the
British Broadcasting Corporation to make
fools of them like this without some new
[__] this is where their argument
has leaks in it
I'm genuinely looking for guidance here
am I supposed to roll over and [__]
lose
[Music]
I sincerely have decided that the best
thing I can do is stay true to my faith
and say true to God and tell the truth
and fight
foreign
since the last time we sat down with
Andrew Tate last time we sat down with
him you were the most uh Google man on
Earth today effective last two days you
are now the most Googled woman on earth
correct according to your Twitter
profile correct and uh we wanted to make
sure after the BBC interview you made
certain requests you said you want
moving forward there to be a fifty
thousand dollar fee when people sit down
to do an interview so we wanted to make
sure the ESG score for this interview
would be very high we got you 50 000
Target gift card I appreciate it very
much more people in America will
appreciate that and then you also said
cookies so Adam got you something
amazing to make sure we match that and
then
bring a Bud Light but unfortunately
Vinnie finished it on the way here
Vinnie
yeah so we respect that so but anyways
look A lot's obviously changed from last
time to this time last time we sat down
was around nine months ago
you had at the time been de-platformed
from every social media platform we came
out here we sat down we spoke The Matrix
was attacking you you were saying Matrix
attacking me Matrix attacking me from
then on uh uh musk buys Twitter in
October he then reinstates you in one
day I believe you get a million
followers on Twitter you're upwards of a
seven million today every other
account's taken down I think even
Tristan was taken down off of Instagram
uh and then you know the arrest comes
the lover boy all these articles and
vice releases the hit piece uh on you
guys you know they're saying what
they're saying and I'm sure we're gonna
get some comments on that the initial
30-day lockup was extended twice 92 days
in the dungeon uh we had a chance to
speak with one of your lawyers Tina uh
glandian on February 24th was a great
conversation we had with her then
eventually you're released you and your
brother come out and you specifically
make it clear that you did 7417 push-ups
correct very impressive you receive
letter from thousands of fans you read
the Quran on a daily basis at no point
was any charges uh anything official
charge it was all allegedly allegedly
allegedly yeah and while you were away a
new star was born Dylan Mulvaney which
I'm sure you're familiar with from there
on a lot of comments were made uh
comments of people that supported your
comments of people that didn't support
you Logan Paul said by 2023 he will not
have a sliver of relevance is what he
said KSI said Andrew Tate snitched on
himself after getting racial by Greta
thonberg Destiny said Andrew Tate has
been arrested for rape charges in a
country he specifically lives in to
avoid rape charges because he was
beefing with a autistic child on the
internet I think he's referencing the
great Greta Matt Bernstein advocated to
get you kicked off of Instagram for sure
and he's part of the blue pill Community
a big famous makeup artist Ethan Klein
said and that's why I call him Andrew
the human trafficker he sent me a season
this is threatened to sue me for
defamation for saying he's a human
trafficker what else am I supposed to
call someone that buys and sells human
beings after their will take the human
trafficker NBC in January 2023 said
Andrew Tate said he broke a woman's jaw
and that his business was a scam ahead
of Romania charges Rolling Stone said
meet Andrew Tate ex-kickboxer red
killing the angry young men of America
these are people that didn't support you
now these are the people that supported
you talk across and he comes out and he
says on full send podcast first of all
he's really smart the spirit that
animates Andrew Tate is very clear and
very obvious and it's not a malicious
Spirit at all Andrew Tate's core
messages respect for yourself act like
you're worth something achieve something
do something get the [__] off the couch
put down the porn go do something with
your life that's the greatest message
that anyone could give it tells you
everything about the people in charge
who say who say that's threatening what
is that threatening the same people who
live on the pedo island with Epstein and
the same people that were friends with
Harvey Weinstein were claiming to
protect women by rebuking Tate that's
Taco Carlson Pierce Morgan who
originally when he went on it was very
combative correct it was a very good
interview entertaining but I was it was
also interesting to see him trying to
push you and then he flips and he says
this is getting ridiculous Romanian
authorities must either charge him and
his brother if they have actual evidence
of crimes or release them musk obviously
supported by releasing restoring your
account like this Jake Shields said
people are freaking out about young boys
looking up to Andrew Tate but totally
fine with young girls looking up to
cardi B and the Kardashians and
obviously Aiden Ross red pill Community
Joe Rogan I can go on and on and on
about a lot of things that's being said
we watched the BBC interview
and we'll talk about BBC here in a
minute because I have some questions on
that as well but the first thing I want
to ask you is you know nine months where
we were at then September to where we
are today A lot's changed how do you
feel whatever everything that's going on
and tell us a little bit about your
current state today yeah there's a very
strange sense of Terror that comes from
knowing exactly what's going to happen
to you there's a strange sense of calm
that comes from it also but in the
middle of the night when you can't sleep
sometimes you feel happy knowing what
they're trying to do to you and
sometimes you feel terrified knowing
what they're trying to do to you I think
I'm very happy every single podcast I
did previous to this I hammered the
point home and I made it very clear that
they had the intention of trying to put
me in jail I said there's three lives
they try and cancel you and slander you
and destroy your name they don't just
want you to disappear from the internet
they want to disappear from the internet
in a cloud of Shame they have to shame
you which is why they chose the crimes
they did for me and it's why they
usually choose the crimes they choose
because it's heinous they want to shame
you and they want you to Disappear With
Your Head facing the ground and never
pop up again obviously they attempted to
cancel me I became more famous than ever
before I even said to you on your
podcast and I said on other podcasts I
said I think they made a mistake I think
when you have power and you overuse it
you what happens is a rebellion that's
how a revolution starts when you have
power you have to be very very careful
with how you use that power the second
you overuse it there's a revolution
right and we're in Romania so they know
all about that that's exactly what
happens and I I said at the time I think
I was a mistake I think they made a big
mistake canceling me the way they did
and then the second time the second life
which I described as they try and put
you in jail for no reason here we are in
the current scenario I knew it was going
to happen and the third one is they put
a bullet in your head so we're gonna
have to see
how the second life plays out and yeah I
mean when this is all over and I win the
court case I get the not guilty I won't
be smiling I'll be walking out the
courtroom with my head on this level
that's the kind of life I'm living now
I'm gonna be thinking oh okay so their
second attempt failed now what like do I
want to fly private anymore do I want to
go to that place anymore you start to
think about these things like do I want
to do these things law billionaires
dying in plane crashes is strange so
it's scary regardless of how it plays
out and I guess you just have to go with
the punches and and see where it lands
and God has a plan for for me and for
all of us and we're just going to see
how it ends up full disclosure you don't
have any Suicidal Thoughts I want to
make it very clear and I make it clear
on absolutely every single podcast I
would never kill myself I don't care
what they say I don't care what video
they show you never under any
circumstance would I kill myself it's
Haram never I don't care if they put me
in back in the dungeon solitary
confinement by myself for the rest of my
human years I would never kill myself
ever ever so if that ever happens God
forbid do not believe whatever garbage
they tell you the chances of me killing
myself is precisely zero and you have
this complete level of certainty that
this is exactly how it would play out
you've said this on um Team podcast that
this is what how this is their this is
their agenda they have to damage my
influence they have to damage my
influence they can't sit there and let
me be influential because I'm saying
things that they don't like me saying
and there are people sitting around
going he's saying things counter to our
message and counter to our narrative get
rid of it and they have a pretty
standardized Playbook and this is
probably one of the first times in
history with our Playbook just isn't
working cancel it well you're still
around oh we'll lie about him in the
news to say he touches chicks well No
One Believes it all the comments are on
his side everyone's calling us Liars
okay then do it again then do it again
make up a new girl then do it again find
someone else yeah and they keep
attacking me with the same weapons but
the bullets are bouncing off and that
doesn't give me a sense of calm that
doesn't make me think hahaha I'm
Invincible it makes me think uh-oh it
makes me think oh because human life is
cheap at the top it's very cheap does it
make you want to sit on the sidelines
and be quiet and just kind of live a
life with your family your kids does it
make you want to do that maybe maybe all
these attention is actually not a good
thing it's interesting because sometimes
I analyze myself and think why don't I
just do that why don't I just disappear
you know I don't need money I don't need
vain why don't I just disappear and then
you have to I was saying this to my
brother
and he was like well Genghis Khan didn't
need Vienna some people are just wired
that way like Vienna's a long way from
Kathmandu
sometimes it's just uh the way it is I
apologize to capital of Mongolia that's
just the way some people are if I see
Injustice and if I see things which I
believe to be false I feel like I am
obligated to say the truth I can't
explain why even if at my own detriment
what am I doing this for like it's it's
to the detriment of my life and I've had
these conversations at length of the
people close to me and and we're all
saying the same thing it's always been
the same way Humanity has always been
the same way there's been a select fault
small Few Good Men up against evil and
evil always outnumbers you evil always
has more money than you they always have
more power and more influence than you
if you look at if you play any video
game when you get to the end boss he
always has more life than you he always
has more hit points but you're the good
guy and it's kind of like it's it's
never been any different at any point in
human history there's been the good guys
up against the forces of evil whatever
they were of the time and you've always
been outnumbered and you've always been
supposed to lose so you consider
yourself the good guy in this situation
I think that truth is instilled by God
in all of us and I think if you tell the
truth you're a good person so who do you
think is the bad guy you know everyone
uses they them them they're after me
who's they who's the bad guy well
instead of saying who I will say what I
will start by saying is what they do and
what they do is they control information
and we now live in an Information
Society and by controlling information
they control how people think and act
and react to things that's all they have
to do they have to control information
and they have to be very selective with
what they allow you to talk about what
they allow you to discuss and what they
don't and once they can do that they can
keep you bickering about garbage and
they can control the sensitive
information and then they run the world
so
having all the information controlled
and having this hard barrier on what can
be discussed
that's how they can purport absolute
fallacies I think now it's been a couple
years we can probably talk about it they
sign up the world into believing they
should be afraid of the common cold they
sign up the world into this
and if you think about how difficult
that would be to do how difficult would
it be to sign off the entire population
of Earth well what you do is you just
lie on repeat and you don't allow anyone
to say anything counter to it without
hurting them the same way I've been hurt
and you just sign off them it's actually
amazing because now I use that exact
same Psy up on people I love it I love
it so when I sit with someone who's not
matrix-minded when I sit with someone
who is matrix-minded like when the BBC
walked in here I'm like do you all have
your vaccinations
social
distance 100 social distancing please
and they look at me like I'm crazy well
how am I crazy two years ago you were
telling me to do this now when I repeat
your own worldview to you I'm crazy well
if I'm crazy guess what you're a [__]
liar because you lied the whole time so
either you're a liar or I'm not you know
how could I be nuts put your [__]
mask on if I ever talk to any of these
clowns again they're going to be fully
masked up and I will and I refuse I
don't care if you've had two booster
Jabs no I want all six all six
injections I want paperwork or gifts
I'm scared of covet it's dangerous I
believe the mainstream media I'm scared
this word you keep using psyop I've
never heard that's what it's short for
psychological operations correct break
that down what what exactly is a sign up
yeah a psyop is is
The Matrix as a whole it's like
psychological psychological operations
are constant they constantly decide how
they want you to think and what they can
do to make you believe that right
there's a whole bunch of them they do
but it starts with tolerance that's what
I don't like about this whole guise of
Tolerance it's not that I'm an
intolerant person it's not that I'm a
bad person it's not that I want to hurt
other people but when they keep pushing
tolerance what they're trying to say is
have no standards or barriers or
parameters or anything that's what they
want you have to be tolerant tolerant of
what tolerant of having your shop set on
fire tolerant of your kids being taught
things you don't want tolerant of crime
tolerant of your house being broken the
tolerant of what you're not allowed any
hard barrier any hard parameters is a
man anymore that's why they push
tolerance that's the beginning of it
that's the first
once you accept absolute tolerance well
then it's the end isn't it I'm tolerant
of everything I'll eat the bugs you'll
tolerate everything I'll tolerate
everything I'm tolerant sure so when I
say things like I'm intolerant certain
things and people think that's bad no
you need to have standards and
parameters
and that's one of the reasons they also
attacked me I say that men should be
allowed to have standards and parameters
in a relationship and in their lives we
should be allowed to decide who we just
want to marry and we should have
standards for her they have standards
for us we should allow ourselves to have
standards for her we should have
standards in what we'll accept from a
government and standards and what we'll
accept from a police force we should
have standards as men but they're trying
to erode all of that because once that's
gone then your brain is completely empty
and then once your brain's empty they
can just plug in the slave program and
then then it's over right you're tall
you're a tolerant person you're a
tolerant person good you're a good slave
slaves are exceptionally tolerant so the
shirt you wear is what escaped the slave
mind resist the slave resist the slave
of mind it's a better word resist resist
but I want to do this before we get into
because we got we got five hours ago we
got plenty of time to get into a lot of
different topics so one I do want to
talk about BBC uh the handling of the
interview I want to get your thoughts on
it I know there's no reactions but I
want to go a little bit deeper into it
because I want to compare how your start
with the interview with BBC starter
versus Phillip Schofield which is versus
musk I got all the first questions we'll
cover that I want to talk about media I
want to talk about your evolution of
your faith atheist Christian Muslim and
then some of the things that's going on
with politics right now you know maybe a
little bit of Romania you know Trump
will cover what you're talking about
with different things it's funny you're
saying uh Monopoly on power Monopoly on
power if you abuse it now YouTube's
turning around and saying hey you can
talk about the election we're no longer
going to give the strike so that doesn't
work forever first thing I want to talk
about I think the audience would like to
know for you and Tristan 92 days in the
dungeon you know you're in jail your
your experience in there we keep hearing
about it we read about it but what was
it like for you guys being in there so
I'll start by saying and I have to make
this clear that the staff in the jail
were except really nice to me
um
they were very apologetic the vibe was
apologetic nobody was really treating me
like a criminal there were a few guys
who were icy cold I guess you could call
them they'd like to think of themselves
as professional but they were just
inhuman
but over time they warmed up and I was
exceptionally nice also to all the staff
jail was terrible I'm going to start by
saying jail was terrible and I was
miserable inside of the jail cell it's a
good thing depression isn't real because
I would have been depressed but
I think in life that you get what you
give and I want to feel happier so I
tried my very best to make people happy
so when the old lady would bring me my
food I would sit and say oh this is the
best food I've ever had I've never had
food disco did you cook this I thought
yesterday
but you managed to surpass it again
how'd you do it what's the magic
ingredient and I ended up making friends
with them like I had grandmas in there
the old ladies cooking the food and by
trying to make people happy and smile
all the time I start to feel a lot
happier
but it's kind of scary and I think the
scariest thing about jail was the
uncertainty of it all they would have
said to me you're in jail for 92 days or
even five years you've got five years
cool I do my time but when you're nabbed
and thrown in a Cell without charge
you're like well how long is this my
life is this it now is this the end of
the story I'm just in this cell and I
was picked up on 29th of December
I went through this quick court case
like I said I'm inside of the the
jurisdiction of Romania so to be very
careful with what I say because the case
is ongoing and we're in Romania and I
can't leave Romania but obviously
Romanian court is in Romanian by law so
you're marched into this room everyone
speaks a language you don't understand
for 15 minutes and then you're marched
off to jail look what even happened what
what even happened to me and they said
oh here's the paper that explains this
like that's in Romanian
and they said oh don't worry you'll get
a translation to English by law I was
like okay that's fine but because I was
picked up on the 29th of December and
there was New Year's Eve and holidays
that it was two weeks before I even knew
why I was in jail two solid weeks I'm in
jail I no one told me in English why I'm
in jail I had no idea can they do that
by law you get it on the piece of paper
in English but it's translation it's
holiday we need to find a translator
that is a delay and you speak zero
Romania zero so they said oh yeah human
trafficking what do you mean human
trafficking who when what what is this
took two weeks before I finally got a
piece of paper and then I realized what
garbage truly was I mean it was garbage
I was like this is complete garbage yeah
so um
yeah I have endless stories from jail it
was it was certainly
I think I don't think jail teaches you
much new
what it does is confirm everything you
already know it confirms everything you
know about the reality of the outside
world that you need to be physically
strong so that you're not attacked by
others and mentally strong so you're not
attacked by yourself you need to you
learn who's on your side and who isn't
you learn who's a coward and who's not
you learn who's an opportunist and who
isn't your circle you certainly learn a
lot about the people around you when you
go to a jail cell that's for sure but I
remember
it was New Year's Eve
when I was first picked up on the 29th
of December I was very sure I'd be out
in 24 hours so there's no way they're
going to keep me for for what like this
there's not this doesn't make sense
so finally New Year's Eve rolls around
and uh I'm sitting in the in the jail
cell by myself and in Romanian jail you
don't leave the room it's not like an
American jail where there's a yard or
anything you're stuck in the room it's
three by four and that's your existence
you just stay there are you by yourself
at the beginning I was by myself
um and you're stuck in this room and I'm
sitting there
it's New Year's Eve and there's a very
faint speaker
maybe way down the hallway the guards
must have been having a little party for
New Year's Eve and there's this awful
song it's called it's called the ketchup
song I don't know if you know what it is
I don't want to sing it but it goes but
hey hey
super annoying song and I'm sitting
there and I I know it's New Year's Eve
because the fireworks start going off
I'm looking out my tiny window and I can
just hear in the very long distance on
the end of the hallway hey uh-huh
this can't be it this can't be the end
of my life even the Cockroaches all over
the walls didn't celebrate there was
there's maybe 15 cockroaches on the
walls right and when when it struck 12
when the fireworks went off I kind of
like well who's my friends in here the
Cockroaches I looked at them even they
didn't move I was like well that's New
Year's it's funny because before that a
couple days before that me and Tristan
were discussing do we want to do New
Year's in Dubai do we want to go cour
Cheval shall we go Miami we're all
arguing oh that would be boring now
that's too far we had all these Grandeur
plans oh finally we decided to go to
Dubai
we were in Czech Republic at the time
and we decided to go to Dubai and I said
let's stop in Romania so I can repack a
suitcase that's it that's the only
reason that's the only reason so jet
left Prague landed in Romania my jet was
still on the runway
came here overnight to pack a suitcase
spent the night spoke to Greta with the
pizza box and it's 5 a.m they go before
I flew back to Dubai so that was mine
the infamous Greta pizza box situation
read a pizza box how much you think
there's anything linked to Greta is
there anything uh because the timing of
it yeah I don't think she specifically
said of course but
there are certainly people within the
Matrix machine that you can't attack
without catching flak4 there are certain
they're certainly protected people it's
absolutely not really a club and you're
either in the club or you're outside of
the club she's certainly in the club
right so if you're if you are if you say
certain things about certain people or
you get a beef with x amount of people
or you discredit a certain person
they're going to try very hard to teach
you a lesson for doing that and you can
see very clearly who's in the club and
who isn't by the the Phillip Schofield
situation
this is a man who has groomed boys and
had sex with them but he's in the club
all of the media headlines after two
days are let's have compassion feel
sorry for him his mother's upset they've
attacked me for 14 months day after day
after day and they relentlessly attacked
me nobody talks about my mental health
nobody gives a [__] how I feel I did I
didn't do any of the things he did he's
actually done things I haven't done
anything but when you're in the club
you're protected by the media when
you're not in the club you're attacked
by the media and that's how it simply
Works you're either on our side or
you're not but to join their side you
have to sell your soul your sanity has a
price you have to your sanity is for
sale you have to sell it you have to
come along and understand it you take
out your mind and say here you go take
my sanity I'll take 35 million yes that
is a woman yes protect me it's insane
and the reason these people join these
clubs is because they know they're doing
bad things and they feel they need
protection the reason I stand up and
argue against all this [__] is because I
know I have I don't have skeletons in my
closet you think I'd be on the internet
talking like I talk and fighting The
Matrix if I had skeletons in my closet
because I was actually a bad person I've
been investigated as deeply as a person
can be investigated by multiple federal
agencies for 14 months I was locked into
jail cell and 2 000 people I know was
called my barber my old housekeeper from
when I lived in England nine years ago
my my Gardener I used to have in another
country I lived in everybody was called
and people were offered bribes
effectively the media are calling girls
saying if you have a bad story to tell
about Andrew we can pay you thirty
thousand dollars if you have a bad story
that's a pride there's a bribe and they
still couldn't find anyone still I've
been investigated to a deeper level than
99.9 of people you cross on the street
and they're saying I'm guilty I'm a bad
person you put you go get 20 men off the
street and put them through what I've
been through you'll find more crimes
than you've ever found with me absolute
clown world it's insane and if I was
part of the club none of this would be
happening the media would be on my side
they would hit me this hard they
wouldn't be lying about me all I had to
do was sell my soul and sell my sanity
and I refused and they're trying to
punish me for it that's what's happening
it's funny you say this
um when uh we watched the BBC interview
with uh musk right and he goes up and
the guy opens up the question with why
did you agree to do this interview he
says well I don't know what's the name
of the BBC and he's trying to mock them
and all this stuff and there's a part of
it where you know he calls them out for
the mistakes they made and if you go to
the bottom of the interview on BBC
you'll see comment sections saying why'd
you cut that out because musk puts it on
Twitter but they didn't put it in the
interview then you watch the interview
with the uh uh uh with you the first
question they asked you was uh uh what's
the first question hey you've been
accused of serious crime rape or
something like that uh you know right
off the bat they asked that question of
you and then you see the interview Lucy
Williamson I believe her first question
was you're facing some very serious
allegations have you raped anybody
that's the open question that they ask
you and the video they put up the first
one they take it down the second video
they put up that's 12 minutes like the
Highlight one they turned the comment
section is open there's 80 000 plus
comments there then you look at Philip
Schofield you just brought a Phillip
Schofield for people that don't know who
Phyllis Schofield do you mind explaining
to people who he is yeah he was a TV
presenter in England he was very famous
he ran the morning show and he was
grooming children for a very long time
and all the staff knew about it and the
people who worked on the show with them
were being groomed by him and everybody
knew and it was all a big ha ha joke and
now he's come out saying oh please don't
pick on me I feel sad and the media is
saying I'll leave the guy alone he he is
when you go look up his Wikipedia it
says he wrote closed captioning not
available
gets fired then he has to take a break
then he comes out after 27 years telling
his wife you know and I'm gay I'm coming
out of the closet he's got two daughters
but there's a part of it where Matt to
you calls his wife and says hey your
husband and I had to referred together
when I was 19 the first time in 20 and
all nobody knows if it was before or not
the interesting thing about him is his
brother Timothy Schofield I don't know
if you know about his brother oh what
the one who's in jail for being a
pedophile what's convicted of 11 sexual
offenses involving a child between
October 2016 and 2019 including two
sexual activity with a child here's how
the interview started first question the
guy asked him he says you've had quite a
week how are you opening question first
is the question to ask you on the
opening right and then he turns around
and says the media's interest in the
affair was motivated partly because of
my homo because of homo homophobia
alleging that an affair with a much
younger woman would have not generated
such a scandal so he gets protected and
he says all those people who write those
all right write those stuff today
everything that there's actually a
person on the other end right this is
proven by the way this is the part where
even when somebody's watching you and
saying why are they taking them to court
maybe he did something why they're
taking Trump to court maybe he did
something why are they taking this gun
he must have done something there must
have been something there right it's
stuff like this BBC does it BBC are
watching this right I want to kind of
remind you of your mission statement
that show up on your website we're going
to put the link below to your mission
statement you can go find it here's what
your mission statement is BBC this is
why you've lost some credibility the
last couple years to act in public
interest serving all audiences through
the provision of impartial keyword
impartial high quality and distinctive
output and services which inform educate
and entertain you say you inform educate
you entertain yet you conceal misinform
and your content is quite frankly boring
you're cherry picking on people that
you're talking to so a message like that
gets the average person to say
everything with you is allegedly
everything he did is proven his brother
is proven yet let's leave him alone poor
guy let's target him this is where their
argument has leaks in it well somebody
like you can tear it up absolutely
Philip is part of the club and I'm not
and and this is the thing I'm a mentally
resilient person right 14 months they've
attacked me I'm not going to sit and
complain about that because that's not
how I operate as a man 14 months they've
complained about me if you'd look in if
you type Romania human trafficking you
type in any of these things my name
comes up my face I'm a bad person I've
lost all my bank accounts I've lost all
my social media accounts I've been
vilified all across the Matrix in every
single possible way they print my face
every single day with something negative
next to a date nobody gives a [__] about
my mental health right because I'm the
enemy and what's scary about this is
Lucy Williamson herself she was begging
me for an interview the BBC were begging
me for an interview I don't need any of
the
the only reason I even sat down with the
BBC is because they were begging me I
can go and just say my own words and get
plenty of views right but the whole time
I was in jail they're begging me for an
interview can we speak to him on the
phone maybe you can give an interview
from jail can we have an interview
please please please please please and I
was saying why do I want to talk to the
BBC and the BBC was saying no we don't
want to do a hit piece we want to come
across we want to be this is what
they're telling this is what they're
telling me we want to be impartial we
believe there's a side of the story that
hasn't been told we're really
interesting and we're really interested
in some of the
or let's say
what's the word I don't want to get this
wrong inconsistencies in the Romanian
justice system we're very interested in
his side of the story there's been
enough hit pieces we want to tell the
other side we want to hear Andrew take
story and I said no on repeat then they
sent me a list of questions I didn't
even ask for a list of questions that's
not who I am I don't have to script I
never ask those two questions they sent
me a list of questions here's what we're
going to ask it's about his mental
health it's about the Romanian justice
system it's about the fact he hasn't
been charged his Liberty's been deprived
all this stuff and I thought well that's
kind of interesting maybe it's a bit
interesting and the Matrix is obviously
printing lies about me and these are
some interesting questions from the
Matrix for the first time ever okay they
walk in here all smiles and happy all
smiley faces try to take me off guard I
already had my list of questions right
it's all going to be nice and easy I sit
down and they instantly attack me they
put the cameras on First and they attack
me expecting me to stutter and make a
fool of myself
it's it's kind of like they tried to
Sucker Punch me I'm in the club and
they're my friend shaking my hand and
they tried to hit me and knock me out
and this is the thing that's so amazing
about it yes I destroyed the BBC but of
course I did because I'm smarter than
all of them but why should I have to
rely on my wit and intellect to destroy
BBC with their research team and their
plan their deliberate plan to try and
annihilate my not only my credibility
but my life they are trying to put me
back in jail these people they're not
they're not dishonest they're genuinely
evil and they don't give a [__] and so
why should I even sit there and
entertain them I believe I could slip
every single Sucker Punch they throw at
me for the rest of human time like I
said with any of these clowns no matter
who they sit with with their research
team whatever garbage they come up with
I'll make a fool of all of them but why
am I even entertaining them anymore
what's the point that was the last
chance I gave mainstream media they lied
for months to get that interview with me
completely dishonest head to toe and
like you said they sit with Philip are
you okay are you okay we heard your
mum's upset that poor old lady maybe
they want you to stop talking about it
because his mom's upset let's not talk
about it anymore because his mother's
old you're either part of the club or
you're not you have to sell your sanity
nowadays if you sell your sanity your
afforded protections that's the reality
of it because if you're a sane thinking
person you don't buy their [__] and
that's what upsets them they don't want
anybody who thinks for themselves they
need you to not they want you to believe
exactly what's on the television screen
believe in covid it's covet now it's
covered now oh Putin's invaded Ukraine
Putin's cured covet now now it's
till the next thing comes it's
absolutely asinine did any of the
questions that they sent you ahead of
time Zero by the way we didn't there was
no no that's not how we operate
whatsoever did they ask you any of the
questions that you said they were going
to ask zero they start with an attack
and it became a battle instantly did
they ask you at any point what jail was
like your mental health was like zero
how like you completely missed the mark
when everyone wants to know what was
jail like but they don't even ask you
that question this is what's so interest
from reality because they are genuinely
detached in reality they think that
finding a video I made eight years ago a
four-hour speech I made eight years ago
and finding one line of it without
context that can be misconstrued they
think that sitting down with me and and
saying that to me is an aha moment
nobody cares because you're taken out of
context one and I said you're taking
things out of context because I'm not
taking out a context I said if you're
presenting it without context that's
taking it out of context that's what it
is you're lying by Omission I said that
to her after the camera's off and she
looked at me because she didn't
understand when you omit details when
you refuse to put in all of the
then lie by including one detail which
may happen to be true you can tell the
truth and miss all the details around
the truth and you are lying by Omission
you're lying by omission and you're
sitting here you're saying oh you said
this eight years ago nobody cares
because they know me and they know I
didn't mean it in that way and they know
it's taken out of context and they know
that it's an old video on the internet
and it's not even an aha moment they
think it is but they just want to sit
with you for an hour attack you and
attack you and attack you wait for you
to make one mistake if I would have
stuttered or made a single mistake
that's the only three minutes they would
have shot that's all they want they want
that one hour then they take the little
bit with me they cut it down to 12
minutes they look terrible in all of it
but I would have made a single mistake
would have been the only bit they've
shown that's all they care about fake
news did you tell them did you say I'm
only doing this if I'm able to record as
well I said I know that's what happened
with Trump as well a couple years ago I
didn't even tell him I just recorded it
okay so they didn't know you were
recording they didn't know I was
recording until afterwards and then I
said that was dishonest I'm going to
release the whole video you told them
before you released I told them there is
no contract or agreement with BBC no
nothing was signed it was just simply a
an interview okay because I think that
was very important when you released it
for people to see what fully was said
versus and by the way you know the
Phillip Schofield the interview that
they put up the 12-minute one that just
came out you know the comments are
turned off of course they are the
comments are turned off yours are turned
on this is turned off uh and and who
knows many reasons why they would do
that but go back to BBC so okay they
come they want to ask the questions of
you for some of the people that maybe
aren't following the story closely but
they know who you are we're in the car
we're driving and a lot of people are
asking questions there's like we asked
the drivers like hey are you going to
Tate's Place how do you know we're going
to takes place and he says well whose
State oh Andrew Tate oh tell us what I
undertake well listen okay what kind of
a guy is he actually really like him I
said why do things going through what
he's going through right now oh it's
because it's always because of money
okay so we're at a different restaurant
so tell us why are you going through
this why is it going everybody's saying
a similar thing about this right but for
those who don't know there's three
different camps yeah the camp that that
already sees you guilty it doesn't
matter what they read so for example
this story here you know from BBC came
out just last night 10 30. Andrew Tate
choked me until I passed that UK woman
claims right this is Alice another
anonymous name just like Sophie right
but there's three camps there's those
that say well look I'm already thinking
he's guilty I don't like him anyways I
need anything to get me to think he's
guilty whatever it takes I don't have to
I don't have to do my own due diligence
I just have to hear anything then
there's a camp that's a die-hard fan
there's nothing you can do that they did
wrong you can you know in their eyes
gonna be wrong then you have the people
in the middle that are the reasonable
ones yeah that are saying you know what
let me look at this what about this what
about that the people in the middle may
say the following question they may say
and I may have asked this question from
you last time as well they may say
Andrew okay if this guy is so innocent
how can they get you to go to the
dungeon for 92 days how can they put you
on house arrest how can they do all this
stuff if you're somebody that was born
in U.S you lived in UK how come somebody
else isn't coming to bail you out you
got different lawyers how is it that
they can keep doing this to you if
you're not guilty what do you say to
those people yeah and once again I have
to be careful what I say because of the
court case but Romania has a law or the
law in Romania is basically if you can
prove to a judge that it might have
happened they're allowed to hold you up
to six months during the investigation
stage if I was guilty of anything I
would have been charged long ago and
we're going to talk about charges soon
because I I still believe they're going
to attempt to charge me but we're now
approaching the end of the six months
they can keep me under a form of arrest
for without charge typically in Romania
when I was first arrested
the guard said ah within two weeks
you'll have your indictment it was like
two weeks he goes yeah everyone gets
charged quickly nobody Waits six months
for a charge if they arrest you they
charge you like like every other country
right the fact they've waited six months
and gone into my entire life and
attempted to to find something shows
they don't have a case why I believe it
happened is because they didn't have a
case when they were trying to hit me
with this garbage and they thought you
know what if we put him all over the
news if we slander his name completely
if we there was a hotline
if you're a girl who's gonna hurt my
undertake call this number in the UK a
hotline so they were attempting to use
the media to find what they wanted
five months go by months go by case laws
are
and our lawyers saying when we're going
to close this case File like yeah we're
just waiting for some papers we're going
to close it we're going to close we're
going to close it around the time I was
canceled
things start appearing in the case File
again they start spying on me again
very interesting that it happened around
that time
I don't know if they understood that I
didn't have I wasn't protected by the
political class of the USA I don't know
what happened
they started to build this case and they
spied on me for all of these months
spending millions of Euros spying on me
everywhere I went trying to find
evidence of a crime
eventually they get to the end of their
legal limit spy on me and they don't
have any crime they don't have anything
so in my current court case we have two
Americans who lied the ones who we have
the conversations between them saying
they're gonna Oscar for lying to the
police we have the CCTV of even coming
and going we have their Uber records
showing they can travel the country
freely we have their phone calls with
their mother where they're saying yeah
he didn't hurt me and my boyfriend
called me that we have all of it we have
all the evidence we have those two
and then there's nobody else who could
possibly even take the stand I don't
believe as as as high level as this
Matrix attack is I still don't believe a
Romanian judge is going to put me in
jail with the dossiers I've seen it it's
garbage I don't think I'm going to end
up in jail but it's just taking years of
my life damaging my influence having bad
things to say about me keeping me under
control keeping me locked in a house
that's all they want to do they have no
interest in the truth there's no victims
there's no one to take the stand do you
know who Sophie is or Alice is or no
yeah so the BBC that's really
interesting so then the BBC says well we
found victims because the BBC have done
enough investigative journalism to
understand that the case is garbage and
they have this no victims so they said
well we found victims
they found one called Sophie first that
was a few months ago I think I was still
in jail when Sophie appeared is that her
real name no that's her thing so they
have a girl with a fake name called
Sophie
they don't show her face
they they ask me what do you think about
Sophie how can I comment on Sophie when
Sophie isn't real first firstly you've
made her up secondly I don't know who
you're talking about you're saying that
nine years ago I was emotionally
controlling that is the most subjective
garbage accusation what does that mean
nine years ago I said you shouldn't
party with those guys in the club is
that what I said I don't know what I
said I don't know who she is if she
exists at all and they're saying nine
years ago you're emotionally controlling
Sophie said so who's Sophie we're not
telling you what's emotionally
controlling mean we're not telling
if this person even exists which they
don't then I destroy the BBC make it
very clear to them that Sophie doesn't
exist on repeat because she doesn't
and two days later Alice appears what's
interesting about this is that
decal the federal agency inside of
Romania along with help from
International Partners have tried so
hard spending millions of Euros with
Federal level tools to find a victim so
they can put me in jail and they can't
find anyone but the BBC just pulls them
out whatever they want the BBC does
where do these people come from and I
say this every single time if anybody
believes they've been wronged male or
female by me go to the police go to the
police I encourage you to go to the
police all these people say we don't
want to go to the police
we just want to say on the news what is
that because you're not real is that why
that's pretty convenient I mean I
thought it was a bad person why don't
you go to the calls oh because you have
no evidence and it doesn't exist that's
why are all these accusers in the UK not
even in Romania not even Romania so
Sophie and Alice are supposedly both
from the UK and Alice's story to correct
that's not Al I said Alice it's Evie
Evie or Evie or something like that
e-v-i-e it's all made up names it's all
made up yes
Evie is saying 13 years ago I choked her
or something yeah by the way when is the
six-month time limit and did this come
okay and can we reference the Tweet you
just posted a couple days ago I want to
stay on the show's commenting on Evie
and you were going to say something
about Evie uh what she said 10 so she's
claiming 10 years ago or 13 years ago
you guys had the consensual sex the
first time she comes back for the second
time around according to the story she
says she was being uh uh your hand was
on her throat strangled me she was
passed out for a minute and then she
came back and she said I did not approve
of the second time time having sex after
she was passed out so these stories
they're making you know and then she
says the guy asked the question saying
how come you didn't do any police report
back then he says well because it's not
fully rape and it's not bad because it
was consensual I kind of wanted to be
there and I didn't tell anybody about it
six years later there's way too many
things that doesn't give it credibility
for somebody to say I didn't do anything
about it then but six years later I told
my friends three or six years later yeah
and this is the thing that's scary if
you say to any red-blooded male 13 years
ago you had sex with a woman
consensually and she's now unhappy about
how that sex happened you can get any
man on Earth can get screwed with that
if this person exists at all and like
you said she refused to go to the police
if she exists and she's saying it was
consensual I think last night they aired
on news night and she literally they
said why are you coming forward now and
I think this actor the person literally
said because now he's rich and famous
they literally said those words that's
that's what they said oh because now
he's rich and famous I think it's unfair
that it's it's it's it's asinine I don't
understand
genuinely how a man can protect himself
in the western world anymore how can you
even exist anymore if this is what
they're gonna hit you with as soon as
you get to a certain level of influence
there's no man on Earth who's safe from
this I said this to my judges the I had
a few male judges I said they could do
this to you
they could do this to anyone they can do
it to you or you or me or any man
watching this any man watching this they
can put in the BBC nine years ago you
did something they won't tell you her
name they won't give you any chance to
defend yourself do you have no idea what
they're [__] talking about and they
will print it on repeat until you lose
your job and lose your bank and lose
your social media and then you're gonna
sit there bankrupt and depressed and
then they're just gonna move on from you
and if you don't die if you're like me a
cockroach refuses to die if you sit
around and refuse to go away they're
gonna make up a new one
it's crazy and it's genuinely scary and
you're not safe from it anywhere anymore
I will say right now on this podcast I
encourage absolutely anybody who
believes I've harmed them male or female
to go to the police with evidence and
we'll go to court let's do it I don't
harm people if I was harming people I
wouldn't be out here as open as I was
the biggest criminals and the biggest
gangsters the most heinous people on
Earth don't have social media
you know this do I see a guy with an
Instagram pretending he's a gangster
he's got a gangster the real gangster
hasn't got Instagram but that's the
reality of you think I become the most
Google man in the world if I've been
running around hurting people
it's absolutely insane and I think there
has been a shift in the Consciousness I
think especially because of covid and a
few other things people are starting to
understand that all these people do as
well I think people are starting to
understand that and the harder they try
and hurt me with these lies the less
people believe it which is scary for me
like I said earlier it's scary they keep
coming up with more garbage the bullets
keep bouncing off so now they're sitting
around going we can't convince the world
this person is a bad person
how do we get rid of him
that's the scary part
you were going to say something yeah
six months you know it's six months
coming up right now June 29th I believe
correct okay you put out a tweet
recently you said the six month time
limit is running out right there's zero
evidence against me unless they invent
something against me right and then you
ask a poll you said if they charge me
with an empty bullet and it still takes
a year to beat it and allows them to
save face they're hoping that the world
will basically forget about all this
what do you think they will do and you
gave people three options option one let
me go option two charge me with no
evidence option three invent and frame
attempt the results were 38 let me go
right 35 invent and frame attempt and
option two in third place charged me
with no evidence 27 38 35 27 so
basically it's it's pretty it's pretty
even so what do you think is gonna
happen the people the 38 of people who
think they're going to let me go I think
are extremely naive I go to sleep every
night every morning I wake up
instinctually at 5am because that's when
they raid your house I wake up at like 4
59 I just [__] shoot up because they
bust in my house three times now it's
not nice to have a bunch of men with
guns bust in your house it's not a nice
experience
so every single morning I wake up
expecting them to just turn up again
with something else and drag me back to
a prison cell who knows what they'll
just make it up but the fact they made
up this particular crime is because it's
a hit piece and it's a slander on my
reputation if they would have done the
same thing let's say for tax evasion
would anyone care no a rich guy didn't
pay a police favor no no one cares we
have to hurt his name human trafficking
think about think about that
I said this to to the judge
how does it make sense a man with no
criminal record
who is financially successful decides to
begin to human traffic at 35 years of
age I have no Financial motivation it's
clearly not my personality profile I
don't need money
why have I begun to human traffic from
nowhere
it doesn't even make any sense from a
pure logical perspective there's no
motive to the crime who will buy human
traffic
who was the victim there's no victims
and there's no motive and here I am a
Housewives it's insane so yeah I'm it's
genuinely intimidating I don't I don't
know what's going to happen next I
believe they're going to try they're
gonna try and charge me with the garbage
they have and I think what they're
trying to do is just hang it over my
head and keep me afraid
do you think of the the idea of trying
to either silence you or make you
irrelevant is working meaning do you
think you're more relevant today than
you were on September 1st is that
strategy they're implementing uh working
no they're failing and the reason
they're failing is because God's put me
in a position where I have to LEAP from
the front
I I think that in the days of old when
politics used to mean something politics
I believe in politics as long as the
leader of the country charges on his
horse of the Enemy at the front then
you're allowed to be king then I'll
listen to your laws that's politics when
you send other people's kids to die in a
war and you sit on your ass that's not
politics to me but now I'm in a position
where I'm spearheading by God's plan the
rights of basically every man on Earth
they could do this to anybody so I think
any man with a brain who's thinking is
looking at my position and going it
could hit me or my friends or my son or
my dad the same way they're hitting this
guy and that that builds a degree of
affinity among smaller audience so no
they failed they failed they made a hero
out of me which is what I'm actually
scared of I'm I am scared by the
incompetence of my enemy I'm scared by
the fact that they are failing so
monumentally if they had been half
successful with the cancellation none of
this would have happened if the
cancellation made me an obscure internet
personality it'd be over if I would have
just allowed them to beat me
none of this would happen but I beat
them
and that's the problem now I'm sitting
here going okay well after I beat you to
BBC after I destroyed the BBC Tristan
gave me a high five he's like oh you rep
they're gonna look so stupid I said bro
we've sunk the HMS Hood HMS Hood in
World War II HMS Hood was the British
battleship is it the the flagship of the
royal Navy and the Royal Navy was
obviously renowned it has been for
hundreds of years it was the best
Battleship and it was up against German
battle Crews of the Bismarck and the
hood should have outgunned the Bismarck
and it was the best German ship against
the best British ship by absolute fluke
the Bismarck on its first volley or
second volley landed a shell perfectly
through the top of the hood and blew up
the ammo magazine and like in the first
shot within minutes destroyed the entire
HMS Hood chilled like I think it was
like 3 000 people two survivors you can
find the video on YouTube the hood blow
into pieces when Churchill found out the
hook was sung he said sing to Bismarck
don't care what it causes
he sent every ship every plane every sub
diverted from every other Mission
doesn't care if we lose every plane we
have don't care if we lose the RAF we
cannot lose the hood without him losing
the Bismarck Sink the Bismarck when the
Bismarck sunk the hood all of the crew
were celebrating except the captain the
captain updated his will he updated his
will and telegraphed home to his wife
and said goodbye because he knew when I
destroyed the BBC my brother was
celebrating I knew I said Tristan no you
don't beat the British Broadcasting
Corporation to make fools of them like
this without some new [__] we sent
the hood and he's like oh we'll see oh
who's this Evie Evie I [__] knew it
I'm winning too well I'm scared by the
incompetence of these clowns but I don't
know what else I'm supposed to do am I
supposed to lose
I I I'm genuinely looking for guidance
here am I supposed to roll over and
[__] lose
when they're lying about me and
slandering my name and trying to put me
back in a [__] dungeon back with the
Cockroaches all I could do is protest my
innocence but there's such idiots I make
them look so stupid and then there's
egos involved you think the you think
the you think Lucy Williamson hasn't
been called into a meeting room with
some BBC producer saying you made a fool
of us yes she has there's egos involved
big big businessman with business
interests of ego investment and hurting
me now and I keep winning so I don't
know I'm in a very precarious scenario
do I continue to win do I do I let them
win a bit do I just roll over and shut
up what am I supposed to do I don't know
what the right move is it's difficult
so you sincerely don't know what the
right move is I sincerely have decided
that the best thing I can do is stay
true to my faith and stay true to God
and tell the truth and fight
the right move for me I believe is to
fight and and fight to the end because I
think that suicide is always the wrong
option I believe you're put in a bad
position the best thing you should
possibly do is fight to the best of your
ability which is what I'm going to do
however
if I was looking at it purely logically
without any kind of ideological
motivations perhaps if I would have shut
up when they wanted me to I wouldn't be
in this scenario but that's just not who
I am
you know Alexander the Great didn't have
to keep conquering Genghis Khan didn't
need to take Vienna he could have just
chilled he kept going so I feel like
when I'm in a position where I don't
know what I'm supposed to do the best
thing I can do is just look to God and
tell the truth and just and that's what
I'm doing I'm going to ask you one more
question regarding human trafficking
because this is a heinous charge
allegedly I mean this is not any this is
not lightweight stuff
you famously ran a webcam business right
perfectly legal nothing wrong with that
I mean I can't tell you how many women
are doing only fans these days webcam
business how much of a reason was that a
correlation for the human trafficking
the sex trafficking the webcam business
how much did they correlate yeah well he
must be human trafficking him he's
running a webcam business there's no
correlation zero correlation so they
haven't even charged any of the webcam
business or any of this zero and what's
crazy it's crazy because people assume
that right it's crazy because one it's
not illegal and two you can go drive
down the High Street of Romania there's
webcam Studios on it's one of the most
popular businesses in in the country
it's not even illegal and and that was a
past life you're talking about something
that happened 10 years ago it was that
long ago it was about 10 years ago yeah
it was at the very beginning of it the
very beginning of the whole idea of this
that industry my neck is an application
which allows you to take a minute to
connect with influencers from all around
the world my name is Andrew Tate and I'm
available to speak directly to you on
minute I think it's just perception I
understand I have this perception
and I think a lot people who are also
dislike me a lot of the reason they
dislike me so much is my perception I've
had people who say I hate what you say
say what do I say and after talking to
him a while they say it's not what you
say it's how you say it of course it's
the perception of aggression it's the
perception of masculinity that they're
afraid of it's not even the words they
might like the words it's my delivery so
I understand perception can be reality
to a degree I accepted that maybe the
first month I was in jail I understand
when you have a message which is
complicated and masculinity as a whole
is a very complicated tapestry that the
best way to instill it and teach it is
to break it down to its three chord we
break it down to its core beliefs so
I've evolved Way Beyond Lamborghinis and
chicks right but masculinity is a whole
is a very complicated tapestry you need
to have the emotionality you need to
have the times you feel like crying and
you don't you need to have the times you
can be aggressive you have the times
that you can be violent to protect your
family it's very complicated and you
can't teach that especially to the Young
Generation in in in spite of constant
propaganda they have coming in their
ears very easily so I break it down to a
very core message and the core message
is that I have Financial Freedom so it's
hard to tell me what to do and I have
sexual access because I'm respected by
women and I have a good Network because
I'm respected by men I break it down to
those core things and those core things
are why I build my that's how you build
the tapestry of masculinity because if
you don't have those three core things
you can never build the rest of it
that's the beginning of it if you don't
have those three things it's hard to
build the rest so anybody who doesn't
look into my message properly I mean I'm
sure these people who are after me have
never listened to me speak at length
ever ever they just look at a picture
he's on a boat there's three girls on
the boat there's no way those girls are
happy with that because my wife hates me
and there's three of them so so he has
to go to jail and that's what's
happening this is that Baseline I truly
believe it's that Baseline Baseline but
my message as complicated as it is
without first breaking down and proving
you have success in the most core levels
of it right before you learn to box you
jab and you cross before you do all the
complicated stuff you do the basic stuff
so a lot of it is people looking at my
message not understanding how detailed
it is not understanding how positive it
is looking at the Baseline instincts
which I teach in which I use to
advertise my success as a whole to
people to show and say look I clearly
know what I'm talking about to a degree
because I have things that you want and
you're a man so you can't tell me you
don't want them every man wants this
every man wants one of these
and they take all this and they try to
weaponize it and use it against me and
you're right it's it's feminism as a
whole that has this idea that if a man
is a man unapologetically and he doesn't
apologize for being a man that he's a
bad person
which we've discussed at length and I've
discussed a bunch of times but it's
truly the most crazy thing about all of
this is when [__] hits the fan it's
exactly the kind of men they hate that
they want
every single time
a Time
part America and you can stand there and
argue with a feminist and argue with her
to the end of time and if someone ran in
there with a gun she would say hey you
you go you're the misogynist you go
protect me the feminist guy who's on my
team I don't want him to go I want you
to go please we don't want Dylan
Mulvaney on the front line of course not
and and it's hypocritical and it's
hypocritical and it's done on purpose
it's purported by the Matrix it is done
to attack the Baseline masculinity of
men because they don't want men to be
masculine because when you're masculine
you say no to things I saw a really
interesting study once that was tested
it had testosterone level and it was
linked to your capability to disagree
with people the higher your testosterone
level the more likely you are to
disagree because at a baseline level
back before we were more civilized than
we are today if you disagreed with
someone you had to fight him
you have to fight that now but you
understand and say you are wrong there
had to be a possibility of violence if
you didn't have the capability for
violence you you didn't say they're not
really you didn't say they were wrong
you just agreed with stuff right so they
don't want men who are standing up and
saying I don't believe in X they want to
reduce reduce our testosterone levels
toward units so that we sit and say well
I may not agree with it but what can I
really do about it is what it is and
then they have absolute control do you
think history favors that ideology or
history eventually a group of men stand
up and say yeah listen we've had enough
this is not going to be happening I I do
believe that in history it's always been
the same I believe it's always been a
select group of good men who are up
against evil and I think they've always
been outnumbered and it's always been
difficult and they've always suffered
all of them
when I was in jail the amount of letters
I got from people and it was just names
of and I'm not comparing myself to these
people this is the letters I got of
Nelson Mandela Martin Luther King
Malcolm X Muhammad Ali everyone who is
unjustly imprisoned everyone's going to
jail because when you stand up for
something they end up trying to put you
in jail when you're a good person trying
to do good the evil The Matrix as a
whole is going to try and throw you in
jail that's what they do that's the
punishment for it and history has always
been the same it's always been a small
group of outgunned people who stand up
who are to the detriment of themselves
to principle to allow Injustice and evil
to thrive and they stand up and they're
outgunned and they're outnumbered but
they're like no I have to tell the truth
if you play a video game and you're the
good guy when you get to the boss at the
end he has more life than you he has
more hit points and he moves faster and
he's a cheater He Cheats He Cheats the
Bad Guy cheats but you still win because
you're good and that's how that's how
the battle's always been I would love
for the world to be another way but I
don't think it's ever been that way I
think if you find any time in history
it's always been the same story
and now I'm in the position where like I
said earlier what am I supposed to do am
I have I do I have a life path in which
I can genuinely help people and do I
have a life path in which I can
genuinely do some damage to the evils of
the world or am I just going to
disappear like a coward and let them lie
about me and do my time and shut up and
delete my Twitter account and just go
away you know you know how sometimes
like uh uh uh I've been in sales for
quite a while if a guy who doesn't have
any responsibilities any single he has a
30 000 a month boom he's going to Vegas
having a good time and then he doesn't
work as hard until he runs out of his
thirty thousand three months today I
gotta go make the 30 000 again oh my God
panic I got to pay my bills I'm beyond
on the phone let me buy this watch and
make 40 Grand I'm going out again so
it's very inconsistent right and then as
you're in sales longer you're like okay
the profile of somebody that's going to
be more consistent is not a single guy
it's a guy that's married kids homeowner
and all those three are signs of what
married commitment home homeowner
commitment responsibility kids
commitment responsibility last time we
didn't talk about your kids at this
point I think it's public video your
daughter running to me give Daddy your
kiss all this stuff everybody knows at
this point do you when you're in in jail
sometimes I I sit there and I got books
on my desk I'm like I'm like 50 books
behind and I like to read I know you
don't talk about reading a lot but I
like to I'm like I'm 50 books behind but
I bet if you're in a place where you're
in jail you're forced to think
you're forced to Andrew you don't have
the phone you don't have a computer
there is no emergency podcast go away
and think you're sitting there like okay
family kids
you know what it's really all about
those decisions decisions when you think
about your kids
does it influence you to say what are
you doing this you know why are you why
are you going through all this stuff
maybe you got to make some changes in in
your lifestyle and if yes in what areas
or does it say no double down even more
because I'm fighting for them and that's
a really interesting question I'll start
by saying how thoughts in jail are
different than thoughts in the outside
world because this is actually an
observation I had
in the outside world I don't think you
carry a thought for very long that you
don't want to carry you can sit and
think about something if you want to but
if you don't want to think about
something you just get your phone out
some Pops in your head oh I don't okay
fine distract yourself or you get in
your laptop or you call someone or you
do something right it's not very often
in the real world in the real world you
have a thought you don't want in your
head and you have nothing to take it
away you have no phone you have no
outside interaction you have nowhere to
go what a perspective you're just stuck
yeah you're stuck with yourself
so there were times in jail where for
the first time like I have a lot of
mental control but there was the first
time ever I'm battling with my own mind
saying I don't want to think about this
and I I put another thought in the way
it kept it was on the door it was
knocking on the door all the time and
this is for weeks because there's no it
never every day is the same you never
get the inter-outside interaction and
you also what made it worse is you never
get the answer that you know like the
open loop if you ever say to somebody
I'm gonna tell you something I'll tell
you later and it bothers them that's
what Jail's like because you might think
of something
doesn't matter what it is I won't say
what my thought was but I'll give you an
example let's say I thought when did
Constantinople fall what year
I can't just Google it I don't know so
it's stuck in your head right so you
have this negative fault you don't know
the answer normally in life when you
want to know something you find out
but in jail you die so you're like I
don't know you got this in your head and
you're like I can't get this out of my
head so when you have a negative thought
yeah especially if there's an open loop
to it you need to know something or you
want to know something you can't get it
out of your mind I would sit there for
hours just meditate and trying to just
keep the door closed on negative
thoughts it's really difficult it's a
really strange experience and maybe in
normal jail in Western countries where
you get to go and interact with people
you can distract yourself but I was
stuck in a room for 93 days in one room
I did not leave that was where I was I
was allowed to go to the fridge once a
day which is a three meter walk and back
that is it in my room you and Tristan
are in the same room or no at the
beginning we weren't but then we ended
up in the same room yeah
so yeah the thoughts in jail are very
pervasive and it's also a long time
maybe never maybe never in the outside
world where I had a thought in my head
for weeks and weeks and weeks and you
just satisfy the problem you fix the
issue in the real world in jail you
can't do that
so yeah family and kids and those are
the positive things that you do think
about
but
because I think of children I think of
legacy
and then if you're gonna think of your
legacy why are your children you think
of your legacy via your actions
and then you have to sit and by
extension go well truly truly on my
deathbed truly will I be happier if I
gave up or if I continue to tell the
truth
I'm scared of the regret of thinking you
know what I was the most famous man in
the world and every man on Earth was
listening to me and I was really making
a difference but I got scared I don't
think I can live for that I don't think
I can live as a coward I don't I feel
I'd feel like a [__] I just feel like a
whim and sometimes inside of men that's
all it takes for us to do the most
stupid things there is the idea of
feeling like a coward a man will run
into a burning building
to not be a coward if the if the
firefighter they go there's children in
there and the whole building's on fire
is like well I can't be Howard I'll [__]
it and you'll risk your life it's
something that's built inside of us
honor and pride it's something that
should be it's what they're trying to
take away from us but it's what used to
be built inside of men and I just feel
like
I can't give up I know what I'm doing is
good I know what I'm teaching is good I
know that people don't like it but I
know I'm not teaching anything that's
bad
and yeah I want my children to be happy
but I have daughters too and how do you
make sure that your daughters are secure
and have a good future well I think you
do that by building good men
how else do you do it my daughter is
mine now but she won't be mine forever
she's going to marry somebody I like the
idea of her marrying a good man with
honor and principle a man like me I
don't want to marry some idiot so they
call me a misogynist and I'm anti-woman
I'm pro-woman the best way you can
improve the lives of women is make men
better men better at being men because
when a man is a good man he's good for
all of society including women he's good
for everyone around him when he's good
at being a man
so I feel like I'm helping them as well
by extension
and it's difficult and yeah I I I I
can't say with honesty that I strongly
considered giving up it never crossed my
mind it was there for a second do I need
to do this and after like half a second
it was again I do I don't know why I
can't it doesn't make logical sense so
kids didn't influence it one way or
another kids made me want to do it kids
made you want to do it kids made me want
to do it we've got it I I I look up to
my father as a hero and I would hate for
my sons to look up at me and not see me
as a hero because that's how I believe
you should see your dad as a hero and I
feel like and you're not a hero without
an enemy you're not here over that fight
did they ever try to and by the way I
don't see this working effectively at
all but did they at all try to come in
between you and Tristan or you and the
two girls or the two of you and them was
there any manipulation and divisive
divisiveness going on there what about
these stories that came out that you've
got cancer and lung cancer and then you
were poisoned and these Matrix attacks
yeah so they keep planting these stories
are they making these things up so the
cancer thing is interesting because by
Romanian law every 30 days to extend the
arrest there has to be new information
they can't extend the arrest based on
the previous information so they put
together all this garbage case and
arrested me for 30 days to keep me
another 30 days they have to find
something during that 30-day arrest
period to keep me for the second month
but of course there's nothing to find so
when I was having uh medical scans in
Dubai a scar a dark spot was identified
on my lung and I had follow-up tests
booked for February
so when after the first 30 days I called
up my PA and she said are you coming to
Dubai I said Well yeah if they let me go
at the end of these 30 days I'll come to
Dubai for my medical tests they took
that conversation and shown it and used
it in court saying I'm trying to flee
the country and trying to escape the
judicial system as motivation for the
second month's arrest and the judge
agreed and locked me in jail because I
said I would go to a medical appointment
if I was free
and they use that as proof I'm trying to
run
because they had nothing else and the
judge agreed it for some reason kept me
in jail
then everything would remained Elites so
it leaked that I had this medical thing
in Dubai I had a problem with my lungs
and then
there's a hospital here and I decided to
go to the hospital here and have it
looked at because although I was not
concerned I thought you know what
although it's difficult to do procedures
in jail I have time
for once in my life
so I decided to go to the hospital here
in Romania and Romania does have some
Private health care which is actually
very high quality it's not as poor as
people think it is and I went to a
private Hospital
and I knew it wasn't cancer I knew it
wasn't I sat down the doctor and said
we're really concerned about this dark
spot in your lung I said it's not cancer
he said how do you know I said that's
just not my life path
it's not my story you told him that yeah
the doctor was like okay but we have to
investigate and we can investigate but
it's just not my story it's not cancer
had zero percent when BBC came did you
have guys like watching every move they
were making you had to almost put like
one-on-one right somebody's watching
everything they're doing everything you
have to do it like you can't be you have
to be overly paranoid and skeptical if
they want to hear about you know Ricky
Tang's crime Lord do they want to hear
more about the crime syndicate in Hong
Kong I could tell them all about it
because Carl
gonna get under control but
um yeah I I mean this is the things this
is actually really interesting point
which I'll go into before I finish the
long story so I went to the doctors here
in Romania everything leaks it leaked
out to the Press I had this Monk on my
lungs I was supposed to go Dubai they
did not even going to Dubai they said
that's enough reason to hold me and keep
me in jail which is absolutely insane
all because I also had a phone call
about a medical procedure it's crazy but
they were always going to keep me anyway
and find some reason
I went there I had a bronchiocopy have
you ever had one of them
bro
I wouldn't call it painful but it's
certainly horrible so they put a camera
in your lung so it's not it's down your
throat but it's in your lung it's not
not down the throat it's into the airway
so you're trying to vomit and you're
trying to cough and you can barely do
either and they're moving this camera
around inside it's extremely unpleasant
even if it sucks I had three years ago
in Dallas for the whole allergy thing do
you have a bronchiosity yeah they have
to knock you out it's terrible yeah
you've had this yeah were you awake or
asleep no they gave me anesthesia so I
was I was asleep I was awake wide awake
yeah wide awake I was excited yeah it
was they gave me this uh uh they tried
to numb your throat a bit and then they
gave it to me and the doctor was all
around me it's kind of interesting
because when something is in your mouth
and you're choking you want to grab it
right so you're on a chair and you're
chained like you're like tied to the
chair so you can't move your hands so
you're like tied to the chair and you're
like this and they put this thing down
your throat this camera and you're
trying to vomit and you're trying to
cough but they can't move the camera
when you're coughing so even the guard
the armed guard who took me the police
officer the guy he was in the corner of
the room and he was like I could see on
his face he was like [__] hell and
I've I don't even want to reenact it
because it's probably so horrible to
look at but you're you're just like like
you're trying to vomit you're trying to
cough you're like your face is bright
red you can't breathe and they're like
stop golfing stop coughing stop coughing
and you have to try and stop coughing
for like two seconds so they can adjust
the camera a bit it's the worst 20
minutes of my life it's horrible they
finish that and they go okay well the
good news is there's precisely zero
smoking damage on your lungs and your
lungs are perfect
but the lesion whatever it is is on the
outside of your lungs it's not on the
inside of your lungs we couldn't see
anything
so I completed that procedure went back
to jail that was a nice evening
um horrible anyone has a bronchoscopy
yeah go to sleep don't stay awake
horrible
um then they said we have to find it we
have to put we have to get a biopsy from
the outside of your lungs so we have to
put a needle through your back a needle
like this long through your back through
your rib cage
to your lung a CT guided biopsy is
called and take a piece of it and then
pull the needle back out and then do a
biopsy on the piece now they're like
this is an operation do you want to have
it while you're in jail because the
bronchoscopy wasn't much to recover from
I had a really sore throat whatever but
this is an operation do you want to have
it while you're in jail and I was like
well why not I'm in jail I have time I
can't recover but I have time
so I went for my CT guided biopsy they
put you on your front they get they show
you the needle it's like this long
and then they they stick it in you and
then they scan you with the biopsy and
they try and see where the Mark is and
they adjust the needle and they scan it
it's like 30 minutes of them shoving
this needle and you're trying to get to
the right point
and eventually they uh did it did the
biopsy and they said uh yeah it's it's
benign some lesion on my pad from when I
had I had pneumonia when I was a kid or
something that's benign I said I told
you I knew that cancer wasn't my life
path I knew it wasn't but obviously
rumors spread like wildfire wildfire wow
everybody in the states
especially because I smoke all the time
right but it was actually very
refreshing to hear I have zero smoking
damage on my lung zero I was like
there's zero
I mean I'll accept a little bit I'll
take a little bit but I think it's
because I train every single day I work
out every single day I train hard every
single day and I think you know you burn
it off a couple cigars here and there
are not big deal it's not cigarettes I
think cigars are better than cigarettes
I also believe nicotine is a super drug
so I'm not gonna stop I think nicotine
is super drug 100 what does that mean
nicotine and caffeine are what I run on
this all I run on coffees for closers
bro
tell me I'm the only one that drinks
coffee the two of us oh really by the
way you know who uh who talked about
nicotine Tucker Carlson talk about
nicotine right have you seen that when
he talks about nicotine where he starts
his days off his day off with nicotino
100 fire blood I I have about 10 to 15
cups of coffee a day and two or three
cigars a day and I only eat once a day
and it's funny because people that come
back to 15 cups of coffee day minimum
wow but you don't do drugs zero drugs
you'll do you'll have a sip of alcohol
every once in a while I used to I
haven't had alcohol nine months I've
quit but you're running on caffeine and
nicotine it's funny because people look
at my physique when I put pictures up
and they're like What's your meal plan
I'm like bro cigars and coffee coffee
cigars I eat once a day I eat once a day
one time I eat dinner that's it only
dinner and eat so you do intermittent
fasting for every 18 hours what yeah and
80 to 90 of my calories are meat that's
it I'll just have like three steaks for
dinner
now how much of that is genetics how
much is that like I'm not sure if it's
genetics but that's just how I feel best
I feel best when if I if I smoke and
drink coffee all the time I feel hungry
which motivates me and I feel energetic
it's energetic hungry that's how I like
to feel when I'm working I want to be
hungry if I eat I'm tired life's too
good if I eat I'm in my Mansion I've
just eaten she's beautiful a little bit
no but but yeah but if I don't eat I'm
like maybe I wouldn't say angry but I
like to have that tinge of
irritableness does that make sense I
don't know maybe I sound crazy it's how
I get things done it's how I get life
done it's just how I pop some coffee
again three cigars and you eat once a
day that's right yeah and you train
every day every day and it's working
working for you it's how I feel best I
don't know if I if you wrote a book on
Tate's diet if that books well I had I
had well this is interesting because I
had a blood test when I was in hospital
for all these things and my testosterone
level I'm not going to pretend to be an
expert on male hormones because I'm not
I don't understand them I don't know
what measurement it's in but it's
between 9 and 27 is the testerone the
testosterone level the mark can be
between 9 and 27 the normal range I've
never taken a steroid in my life I don't
inject anything I don't take any pills
nothing and I was 32. I was above the
normal scale and I'm 36 years old
supposed to be going down so whatever
I'm doing I'm sticking to what was your
diet and your regimen while in jail oh I
had coffee and cigarettes don't worry
bro I had those really I spent my
commissary money on coffee and
cigarettes like coffee and cigarettes I
want meal a day same so there was
commissary money yeah so we had to give
you that yeah so uh a friend of mine put
money on my account
so I was a rich guy in jail because in
Romanian jail most people haven't got
money right okay I was rich there's a
limit to how much you can buy but I was
spending the maximum so I had plenty of
cigarettes
coffee I actually quit coffee but now
we're talking about coffee and then I
want to go back to the appointment
earlier but
I quit coffee for the first 30 days in
jail because I've never I've never not
been caffeinated my experience of life
is Catholic
right I'm awake it's Kathy so I was like
I don't need energy now I'm in jail so I
quit caffeine and all coffee for 30 days
to see if there's any tangible benefits
and I can confirm to the world that
there are none
syrup I did not sleep any better I did
not go to sleep any easier I did not
dream anymore nothing absolutely nothing
good happened except that was terrible
day it was garbage like give me my
coffee
cups of coffee a day to have that much
coffee the last time I drank coffee was
25. we have good friends literally we
have one friend that drinks almost as
much
everybody around me loves coffee yeah
including my 11 year old son Tico him
and his mom got into an argument the
other day because she didn't want to
take him to Starbucks
he said what do you mean it's like I
want some coffee he's like you're not
having coffee yeah at 11 years old
anyways but it's working for you it's
working for your body sometimes when you
when you find a diet or a combination
that that hits your body well you'll
know it you'll feel it and you have to
know your body the best correct I think
there's no perfect diet for everybody I
agree slightly different I agree and
that's just and and I think you are what
you eat to a degree and also depends the
mental model you want to operate under
some if I want to operate under Comfort
I certainly wouldn't eat the way I eat I
do it because I particularly want to
operate under a degree of irritability
and high energy and hunger I like
feeling hungry I don't like feeling full
I like being hungry all the time I I
love that I mean that's that's the
quality of people where you know you can
you can tell a lot from somebody how big
they think after they make money and
they have some success when they make
money that's when they slow down that's
when they get casual the hunger goes
away you'll really know if somebody is
hungry when they made money and they're
still going what is this guy doing still
going yeah you've already made the money
you've already had the success but
transition to a couple other stories
here so all of a sudden you put in your
profile obviously I joked about it
you're the most Googled woman on Earth
you know that was based on your Twitter
profile you know Nina Turner comes out
and says if somebody says they're a
woman they're a woman not a tough
concept your response is I'm a women
right you do that and you've left it on
Twitter
tell us why because I am
you don't believe me you're a woman are
you misgendering me I have to choose
that you choose to agree with you right
my pronouns are she her
no but the level of it's all a joke
right
but there's actually a very Sinister
undertone to all of this garbage and the
Sinister undertone is that your Baseline
instincts and your Baseline senses are
how you've always perceived the world
right they have to attack them at some
level and they did I mean it's fantastic
with covet covid I know we can talk
about it now it was amazing I used to
say to people all the time who have you
seen die
do you see a pandemic yeah on the news
no no no
do you see ambulances rushing back and
forth everywhere do you see bodies on
the street do you see lines outside of
hospitals do you see a pandemic how a
pandemic would look do you see a
pandemic oh but my grandma my friend's
grandma your friend's grandma was 96.
Okay so I'm not saying it's not sad I'm
but they have just lied to you so many
times that you're ignoring your own eyes
that's the final stage of the slave mind
it's the final stage the final stage of
the slave mind is when your eyes tell
you this is green but the news told you
it was blue
so it has to be booked so when they're
doing these things there's nothing to do
with caring about the mental health of
gender ideology none of this garbage
they're deliberately attacking you and
saying what your eyes tell you is wrong
because if they can make you start to
admit that your own eyes are wrong then
what what other defense do you have
against propaganda
if they're going to give you a lie but
your own eyes can't protect you well
then it's over isn't it so all of these
things they're doing all of these things
are a deliberate assault on the senses
and they do it by controlling the
language if you control what someone
says over time you'll control what they
think you don't think what you don't say
it's very hard to live a life for eight
years if you're lucky and think things
and never say them ever if you think it
you're going to say it sometimes you're
going to give the idea get some feedback
on the idea build on the idea change the
idea whatever it is through discussion
if you never ever ever discuss it you're
not going to think it so they say this
is the truth ignore your eyes and you
have to say it's the truth you can't say
it's not the truth and the people are in
charge of the world they think
generationally they have time right now
it's a joke 200 years from now won't be
a joke to introduce and that will all be
[__] standard operating protocol the
grandchildren the people who are in
charge now that that's what they want
they'll pull it off in the end slow
incremental damage they'll take they do
it with nearly everything they'll take
all your rights away take 100 of your
rights away they'll upset you they'll
give you 99 back
we're good again
don't worry and they're the
grandchildren the people in charge of
the world get what they want in the end
they think generationally so now we're
at the beginning of it it's all a big
joke right but especially before Elon
had Twitter when you couldn't say the
truth online when you couldn't say my I
see X on the internet without going to
jail or losing your account or getting a
hate speech charge in the UK or some
garbage they're controlling what you
think
and on a long enough time frame what you
think becomes true if two we all believe
two plus two is four
but with a hard enough Scion if you
can't say that if you have to say it's
five on a long enough time frame math
breaks down and everyone's just gonna
believe that two plus two equals five
that's what happens you think we're
gonna get there have you ever seen the
experiment there's a really interesting
experiment with monkeys and a banana and
a water spout have you ever seen this
they put five monkeys in a in a room and
at the top of the room there was a
banana and when one monkey tried to
climb up to get the banana they turn on
the hose and splash all the monkey's ice
cold water
so the monkey will come back down and
wouldn't get the banana and when another
monkey would go to climb up they'd
Splash all the monkeys with ice cold
water and what would happen over time is
when a monkey went to climb the Rope to
get the banana the other monkeys would
jump and pull them down and hit and
teach them a lesson don't go for that
banana if you go for that banana we get
splash of Lord
then they'd swap one of the monkeys out
now there's a new monkey in the room who
doesn't know the gang the new monkey
would attempt to climb and all four
monkeys would attack the monkey pull him
back down and kick his ass
he knows if he climbs the road to get
the banana he gets attacked he doesn't
know he gets splashed through water if
he doesn't if he gets down he doesn't
know the game but he knows if I try and
climb they're gonna attack me
after a certain amount of weeks they
change another monkey and another monkey
Another Monkey over time you have five
brand new monkeys who have never been
splashed with water ever but nobody goes
to climb the Rope because if they do
they're attacked by all the other
monkeys and nobody even knows why damn
that's just how it works if you climb
that rope we beat you up that's just how
it works
that's what they're doing on a long
enough time scale to humanity there are
already x amount of people on the planet
there's already a population X percent
who knows what it is who ignore their
own eyes and repeat what they are told
you can't say that that's not what
they're doing because they're already
successful with x amount of the
population they've begun the seed is
there
two percent three percent seven percent
who knows they've already proven they
can do it now it's just a matter of not
showing up and hammering the hammering
at home make sure they repeat in schools
children are young they believe things
are impressionable hammer it to the kids
especially put it in every Disney movie
give it to the kids all day long they
grow up sooner or later long enough time
frame that's it it's generational attack
do you think that's gonna work though
because uh let me maybe unpack a
question so uh uh I'm from Glendale I
went to Glendale High School and stalloy
right so yesterday a big fight broke out
in Glendale mass that it's all over the
news so the fight was over these parents
Armenian parents who are for four years
are like listen we don't mind if you're
gay but don't teach our four-year-olds
about transgender don't put these books
in finally yesterday Bagel brawl it's
all over the news they're fighting
Armenian parents are like we're not
gonna tolerate this this is just not
gonna happen to us right then you go to
YouTube YouTube comes back and says hey
uh starting such and such all the videos
that were put up about you know the
election and you know whether it was
fake collection or not we're no longer
going to give a strike or take those
videos down they can stay up there right
this is totally fine then you see a the
Surgeon General comes out the attorney I
don't know if you saw this one here he
comes out with an article saying new
Surgeon General advisory raises alarm
about the devastating impact of the
epidemic of loneliness and isolation in
the United States this is the same guy
that was part of the camp is now saying
hey our epidemic of loneliness and
isolation has been an underappreciated
Public Health crisis that has harmed
individuals and social health our
relationship our source of healing Etc
this is the same guy that said wait a
minute lockdown you know do this do that
so the more and more arguments are
coming out against even ESG I don't know
how close you follow ESG where why are
we doing this did you see how much
Target lost 10 billion dollars did you
see how much Bud Light Lost 25 12 this
is no longer working well if you want to
like even one of the insurance companies
I work with closely it's one of our
biggest one we work with yesterday I see
their post on Instagram well because of
pride month we're doing this I I know
the people in that company but they just
raised a few hundred million dollars one
of the companies they gave the money to
was one of these bigger guys the
Vanguard BlackRock and you know State
Street so when you take money from those
guys you have to you have to have a
certain ESG score but a lot of people
are now saying this is not a proven
formula that it works stop doing it so
do you think guys like you who are maybe
in business who are maybe in church
they're saying Pope what are you doing
what are you talking about who are maybe
in the Christian church who are maybe in
different denominations they're in the
military sitting back saying I didn't
sign up for this so meaning successfully
do you think these guys will be able to
manipulate their agendas down
everybody's throat or there's going to
be certain people standing up well
certainly I'd like to believe that the
tide is Shifting and we're starting to
get some degree of Victory against the
Matrix as a whole I do believe that the
public sentiment is shifting however
the fight is long and it's very very
difficult because I agree with what
you're saying only a year ago I would
argue it completely and say it's
basically over I'm actually very
impressed with the back with the with
the ground we've taken back with common
sense
but these people operate so slowly it's
generational these attacks the attacks
we're suffering now were started in the
70s and 80s they take it over time and
yes it's fantastic that those parents
fought back against that school that's
fantastic but there's a whole bunch of
schools where they didn't and who knows
okay that particular book might be
removed a softer version will be
implemented next year maybe that book
will come back they have all the time in
the world all the money in the world and
they're they're insulated from these
things that's what's most scary you talk
about Vanguard and BlackRock and all
these companies what's actually scary
about it is the people who are making
these decisions are completely insulated
from the consequences of their decisions
they're in Switzerland they fly private
they don't care you think they care
about any of this crap they'll say I'll
do this oh it's caused a riot
they don't live there they're nowhere
near it they have nothing to do with it
when is the last time you've even seen a
politician did people even exist they're
not even there's nothing to do with
where they they operate it's actually
amazing when I was in Dubai once I think
it was about three years ago I saw the
leaders Dubai walking through them all
I was like he's a person he just walks
in
I was so impressed imagine a western
leader walking through the mall never
never in a million years it's just
pieces of paper private jet vanish all
these people are in charge of everything
don't even live in these communities I
do believe that yes we can win because I
don't think you can fight to the best of
your ability if all hope is lost I do
believe we're winning and taking ground
back absolutely and I believe that we're
doing that by purely telling the truth
what our eyes see or is what's real and
we're doing it in the name of God
because you're saying Armenians are
strictly religious I think God and
religion is one of the best ways you can
combat these things
however the fight is never ending
because they're never ending gonna try
and Implement you talk about ESG scores
it's garbage they put together that's
not going to end it's going to get worse
and worse and worse over time
and it's kind of unfortunate and it's
kind of upsetting that we still have
this system where the people can be
unhappy with something The Peasants can
Revolt to a degree
but does it even really matter at some
point you get to a point of power where
you don't care about money
and then things are really difficult
right when you control everything you
don't care about money I mean I'd like
to actually argue we talk about Bud
Light this mullaney whatever it is
whatever yeah yeah Dylan Mulvane
sweetheart yeah
and yeah I know we've damaged their
share price etc etc I would believe
people who own that company or beyond
that company I don't think they truly
give a [__] in both I don't think they
care maybe they care a bit I don't think
they're losing that much sleep over it
maybe they are a little bit but I'm
saying you get to degrees of power and
levels of power where you don't care
about money I'll give you a perfect
example of it I know we keep going back
to this but it was actually a massive
pivotal event in Awakening so many
people was the covid scam
I said this multiple times in many
different countries I visited I said if
they cared about you they would have
left everything open maybe put a tax on
everything
extra tax percent whatever and Bill
hospitals why didn't they do that why'd
they why did they lock you all up
because it's a mass compliance exercise
they want you to comply they don't give
a [__] about your health they just want
you to comply they want to test how many
people comply
and people were saying yeah it's all
about money it's all about profit and I
said that's actually a very optimistic
way to look at it I think that if you
destroy the economy and lock up one of
their houses and Destroy everyone's
businesses you don't care about money
you're you're beyond money you're above
money you want power and you want
control
because once you become actually rich
you learn that the world is all just
about people
right the best things in your life are
people best things in your life for
family things make you happiest are your
friends your life experience is the best
if you have good team around you good
assistance good helpers good staff
whatever it is it's all about people and
controlling people what do you want
money for
to get other people to do what you want
that's all money is I want Lamborghini I
can't build one he can I will pay him to
build me a Lamborghini it's all about
people so once you get Beyond a certain
level of money
and there's a certain level of control
you want that money perhaps can't buy
buy then you think well I don't care
about the money I want the power
I don't want money I want them to stay
in their houses why because I said so I
don't do they have to haha it's funny
and I've said and sat with people and
said do you really think people in
charge of the world are so petty that
they would lock everyone in their houses
so they can laugh and say yeah I
actually do I think if you were born
into a wealthy family where money has
precisely zero value and you are
arrogant to the Moon because you're this
whoever and you believe you're God's
gift and you don't a Ferrari ain't gonna
make you happy you could throw a Ferrari
Ferrari's freeze pennies you don't care
about any of this [__] what makes you
happy is everyone respecting you and
being afraid of you
to a degree you're going to try and
influence some power and fear I think
that's what it is so I think a lot of
these companies when they're doing these
things and they're upsetting people Etc
yeah it's good that we're fighting back
but I also think part of them enjoy the
show
I think part of them genuinely enjoy the
show I think part of them go you know
what
let's do this is this is insane let's do
this oh they're fighting uh I really
believe it I I know it's a pessimistic
way to look at it but I think they enjoy
the show apart I don't disagree with you
in in regards to that I can see that how
you know you see it in movies or scenes
where you know condescending arrogant
you know and they kind of want to they
enjoy bullying the guy that can't help
himself right hey do this say clean up
pick this up I look at this he'll do
anything that I need him to do right I
fully believe those types of things
exist but and empires have fallen so
many times because they thought they can
get away with murder and then eventually
people said listen stop you're not gonna
do this to me anymore we're not we're
not going to take a stand and typically
when that happens you said it earlier uh
you know what is really why what's going
on in Glendale or some of these other
cities that people are protesting why is
there an organization called gays
against groomers gays against groomers
what what do you what are you doing and
I just wanted to be giving leave me
alone I'm not trying to be you know
grooming kids that's not my job I just
want to be gay leave me alone we've made
so much progress these guys I'm not that
guy I'm not this person right so I think
the part that
they fear the most if you read Communist
Manifesto there's a book written by uh
Cleon skousen I think he was like a
former CIA agent for like 15 years he
wrote a book called The Naked communist
one of the things he talks about how
getting rid of God well they're
succeeding in that area but not fully
yet you know getting rid of the family
nucleus well we already know what is the
purpose of this lgbtq movement what is
the purpose of this transgender what is
the purpose of let me get this straight
this person cannot buy a gun at their
team this person cannot go in the
military at 13. this person cannot vote
at 18. this person cannot own a car at
their team but they can transition the
most the most important decision of
their lives you're okay with yes now
that doesn't make sense to me that
doesn't make sense to me I think you
said something at the beginning the the
concept of being tolerant you know what
yeah it's okay we can't have gays oh
it's okay we can have this so uh listen
man uh-uh you've crossed the line I
think Faith Family Kids values
principles they fear the hell out of
absolutely and I think that Community is
rising up no you're totally right but
you made a really interesting point
there where Empire is falling and this
is where I kind of feel like we're
entering a new stage of the world
because it's never really done before
because typically when Empires fell the
world was far more polarized if the
empire fell there was nowhere for the
corrupt dictators of set Empire to go
the Empire's Fallen where I say let's
say England fell you can't it's very
hard to get Exile in France you could do
it a little bit but let's say America
fell today let's say it completely
collapsed and it fell the people who
archetyped that downfall do you think
they beat America
do you think they'd be sitting there
waiting to get scooped up do you know
who they are can you recognize them
what's their name even if you could do
you think they're in America or do you
think they're skiing is so sad
this globalism the whole point of
globalism is that they don't care when
Empires fall when you globalize the
world then you have a chess board I lost
the Knight doesn't matter what Bishop
sack the queen who cares there's so many
things I want to say but I don't want to
die but there's truth this can be proven
and shown even with this current proxy
war
Europe and all the gas prices and the
inflation rate in Europe has gone to the
Moon to fund this proxy war in Ukraine
why is this happen because America's in
charge of everything and America has
decided that Europe has to Bear the
brunt of the [__] for its proxy war
you're going to have higher gas prices
you're going to have inflation you're
going to have massive unrest you're
going to deal with it all and we're
going to sit over here and insulate
ourselves because we have the global
Reserve currency and the war is going to
happen over there and everyone's going
to die and we're in charge
so now we have this globalism how can an
Empire fall when you have basically two
camps there's two teams now there's two
sides left so it's it's a it's I agree
with you completely the Empire's falling
but I'm saying if the empires fell in
days of old the Kings would be strung up
but now when the Empire Falls nobody
notices it doesn't matter we don't know
who the king's song we don't know who's
in charge we don't know where they are
they're not going to be anywhere near
the trouble that's for [__] sure
there's gonna be somewhere else oops oh
well and do they really care
do the people in charge of the world
care if America's crime rate goes up one
thousand percent would they lose sleep I
actually think they do partially
because think about it so I'm with
Andrew Schultz and I'm taking your
position with him yeah okay you know
what Andrew Schultz is good guy and he
says you know part of me that gives me
Comfort is no one these guys are so
obsessed with their money he may be
wrong so we can debate this they're so
obsessed with their money that there's
no way they're going to let America fall
because if America Falls everything else
Falls so they're going to go just as
much as they can to control but not
enough to get the machine to break
because they're so in love with money
and power they don't want to give that
up well I hope that's true I would love
for that to be true but my argument is
that these people are already so deeply
entrenched they print the money
go print the new money I don't care they
cared about money covered wouldn't have
happened
they closed the entire economy I don't
think they care about money I think they
can I think they control the world to a
level where you want to eat
do you want war
like I don't think they give a [__]
about money they'll print the new money
they'll change the name of it and print
the new one a certain level of power I
think they're so above and beyond all of
our concepts of how the world works and
they don't have any interest in any of
it I don't think they give a [__] I
think if you were to go to these people
whoever they are and say we're going to
take your money away they would just
laugh at you you think you can take my
money you think you understand money you
think you're going to damage the stock
market you think I give a [__] about the
share price
I think there's a level beyond all of
this and they're the ones who truly are
running things and they truly have no
influence and in fact the harder they
damage the economy and the more damage
they do to money the more people are
dependent on governments to eat that's
where communism comes from right the
more poor we get the more you need the
government just so you have food in your
mouth how can you resist the government
if they feed you
you can't
so yeah like and I sound pessimistic and
I'm not pessimistic and I do believe the
answer to all of these things is free
thinking and truth and God and Community
standing up for themselves and changing
the general consensus I do believe that
because to a degree
although we talk about people who run
the world to a degree We Run the World
because
our tolerance level is what runs the
world there's more of us than them so
two degree you say who's in charge of
the world well I like to say where we
are because it's all about we're the Abu
we're the abused wife in this
relationship how much crap are we gonna
put up with reset the limit
they're going to come at us with
everything they can right we set the
limit but the problem is they try very
very hard to one increase our limit to
the max which is tolerance and two to
divide us to the point where we don't
ever unite long enough I love what
happened in Glendale what you just told
me about that should be happening in
every single School Across America all
of them oh they would love it if you
retweet the video for them and give more
exposure you know it's when you're
saying this I'm reading a book right now
Robert Moses I don't know if you know
who he is or not power broker that's a
guy it would be very interesting guy for
you to study this is the guy that built
New York okay and he came up and uh uh
hate it
a complicated person misunderstood uh
the more they would
push him back the more he stood up the
more they would say no this is not fair
what you're doing the more he would even
say I'm gonna go more even more extreme
and so if in New York you mentioned the
name Robert Moses there's going to be a
camp that's going to say scumbag racist
white supremacists all this stuff and
there's a side that's going to say this
guy built a bridge this guy did this
this guy did that he he would make it so
hard for a certain Community go to the
nicer Community he would put the car you
know the bridge so low that trucks
couldn't go through because he didn't
want the bad people to go into this like
he was that sharp and one time in the
book they talk about how Robert Moses he
says look the one thing about Robert
Moses he could give a [__] about money
he could give a [__] it was all about
his influence over so I agree there are
certain people that don't care about
money they're more driven by control
influence all of that the part that uh
you know we're talking about the movie
Fury Vinnie and you give me this whole
thing about Fury the scene where Shia
LaBeouf is reading out of the Bible and
he's crying while he's reading this and
then right if you want to text me what's
with the and then afterwards you see
Brad Pitt quotes exactly what scripture
it was but they never showed how much
Faith he had and the whole point was I'm
ready to die we know we're here this is
going to be happening we're in the tech
there's no I think the people
there's a part about Trump uh I had a
girl on Whitney Webb I don't know if you
know who Whitney Webb is we had to run
okay yeah and we start talking about
different things and I've been having a
lot of weird guests on lately
and making a comparison between the
Kennedy family and Trump
pisses a lot of people off but those two
families forget the fact that once a
Democrat one's a republican they were
both anti-establishments they were both
anti-military industrial complex they
were both anti-cia anti-fbi anti-all of
this stuff right we saw what happened
with Kennedy we saw what happened with
Reagan we saw what happened with Lincoln
all these guys were anti-establishment
guys we saw what happened with Trump the
part about Trump that
you know
made the other side uncomfortable is
okay we can kill the guy
that's been the strategy for a long time
you can't really do it today
as much because they fear one thing that
they're the most jealous and envy you
know what that is they don't want they
do not want to build a martyr they fear
building a martyr because that's the
ultimate height that they want to get
they do not want to build a martyr right
so okay we're going to humiliate the
crap out of you we can embarrass the
crap out of you we're going to publicly
try to do this we're going to come in
between you and your kids you know we're
going to go get your daughter to be more
LGBT we're going to get her to be on
this side and we're going to pin this
that's the strategy and we're going to
put the break into our family apart
right
and he still stands up there yeah
and and to them it's like what the hell
do we need to do for you to you know
just sit down and be quiet not willing
to do it that's right do you think again
going back to it
more of those types of men and women who
are misunderstood and complicated
stories they they're not perfect far
from it more of those guys are the ones
that are saying yeah it's just not going
to happen on my watch man and that's
what we need and the the by the very
nature of being the kind of person who's
principled enough to risk his own
personal
situation in life if you have principles
that strong you're going to be disliked
by some people you're never going to
have a person who is principled enough
to take risk to his public detriment for
the good of what he believes in who's
liked by everybody that that's a logic
failure right because he has principles
which are hard lines and people exist
across the entire Spectrum so there's
many people exist outside of those lines
that's what I liked about Trump he's not
perfect of course not but he says what
he means it means what he said I
actually disagree with him
he says what he means
and that's what they're afraid of
they're afraid of a man who says what he
means and means what he says because he
can't be bald because he's principled he
can't be bought even now me if they're a
company with 100 million dollars and say
We'll sponsor you with this company's
100 million dollars you just have to
shut up I'd say no I don't want your
money I don't want the money I don't
need money there's nothing else to buy I
bought everything I don't need it I buy
principal's worth more so and that's
what they're afraid of they're afraid of
principles and it goes back to the
original point they're trying to remove
all of our morality all of our Baseline
understanding of things my neck is an
application which allows you to take a
minute to connect with influencers from
all around the world my name is Andrew
Tate and I'm available to speak directly
to you on minute that
that's how they in
and you're right
and now it's under conscious assault
I've never said this before I've never
even thought this before this is a brand
new thought for me but I would like to
think in times of old in history perhaps
everybody was the same everybody was
principal everybody had parameters but
they were different parameters perhaps
there were competing ideas but I think
in the modern world it's not so much
competing parameters it's just people
who believe in things people don't
believe in anything besides what they're
[__] told and it changes every day do
you have the empty brains
the the slave minds and the people who
actually stand up for something
but the slave Minds you can't say well
they believe in a different ideology
because they don't they believe in what
they're told to believe in on that
particular day it changes they don't
have any true core belief they just
repeat
I talk about the Matrix all the time and
people say why did you choose that
terminology and I chose that terminology
because it is perfectly accurate in
describing exactly what is happening The
Matrix is a computer program which is
designed to control your mind so that
your body can be used to power the
machines that's exactly what happens
when they make you watch the news to
control your minds you continue to use
your body to work some garbage job and
suffer from inflation and power the
machines machines being soulless people
who are in charge of the world but
there's also a million other different
ways you can compare the Matrix to the
real world and the Matrix they say
anybody can become an agent at any time
if their mind is not unplugged they
become an agent if their mind is not
free they turn into an agent you can see
that in real life mention covet to an
NPC mention Trump to an NPC you can sit
and have a perfectly cordial normal
conversation with somebody for an hour
and be fine and you can mention one of
the particular subjects which they are
programmed to Hate by The Matrix itself
and they will turn into an agent in real
time and you will see them now start to
genuinely emotionally dislike you as a
person they were your friend for an hour
yeah now they hate you they will turn
into an agent Kobe was perfect I would
sit with people we'd all be friends
until I mentioned that covet's garbage
oh
now they're an agent what do you mean
Kobe's garbage my friend's grandma was
99. she got sick
okay sorry
it doesn't change my view and they
change and and the Matrix is actually a
perfect absolute explanation of what's
happening and and Morpheus says it if
your mind's not free you can be one of
them and that's what's happening and
this is why we have we don't have
competing sets of parameters which we're
trying to argue about which is the best
way to run the world we have people with
parameters who believe in family and
love and God and tradition and taking
care of yourself and taking care of
others there's people with moral
standard and there's people with none
zero empty vessels agents who are
programmed on any given day of whether
what they're supposed to care about
these people can't tell me they care
about things that's what's most annoying
about my position because it's
absolutely an hourly weaponized virtue
they use against me the people who hate
me hate me because one I I truly believe
and I know this is arrogant to say but I
feel like I have to say it there's huge
there's definitely a massive jealousy
implement
if I wasn't so tall and rich and good
looking wouldn't be happening they don't
[__] like me they don't like me
because I remind them of the chocolate
school that took their girl that's part
of right they don't like me personally
so they can't they try it it's true so
they try and find an attack vector and
what happens when you have somebody
who's monumentally successful across all
Realms of human endeavor the only way
you can attack them is by calling them a
bad person they can't call me stupid
they can't call me ugly can't call me
bro can't call me weak they can't go any
of these things so how do you attack
this guy well he's a bad person how do
you call someone a bad person you
weaponize virtue none of the people not
who are pretending to give a [__] about
women
and that I'm bad to protect women have
any interest in protecting women none of
these people think I better become
physically strong so protect women none
of them even believe in protecting a
woman in a physical scenario I don't
even believe in protecting their family
none of them have any none of them
donate to any Charities that involve
women nothing they're just taking the
virtue and weaponizing it and attacking
me with it me as a person who donates 25
million a year to charity to feed both
male and female children me as a person
who believes I have a responsibility to
be physically capable so that any woman
I'm walking down the street with is safe
I do more for women than any of these
clowns would ever do but they're just
weaponizing virtue and attacking me with
it it's not even genuine virtue that's
what's so upsetting about it these
people the matrix-minded people have so
few parameters and so few virtue
whenever there's virtue inside of them
it's only so they can take it weaponize
it and fire at you they don't give a
[__] about any of the issues they talk
about they don't care about race They
Don't Care About Women they don't care
about gays none of it they take it they
put it in a bullet and they shoot at the
people they don't like it's all fake all
of it when you were when you were
talking about this
um I wrote all these things down that
we're talking about principled virtues
God Parents True Believers Fighters
Traditions these people they fear right
all these people they fear and these
guys are slowly but surely starting to
stand out the scene we're talking about
with Shia LaBeouf he says what we're
doing here is a righteous act here's a
Bible verse I think about sometimes many
times this is his words it goes and I
heard the voice of the Lord saying whom
shall I send and who will go for us and
he began crying and said here I am send
me Brad Pitt turns around and says book
of Isaiah chapter 6.
for me
business I asked this question I'm so
curious to get your thoughts on this for
the longest time when I got into
business I was you know younger guy 21
on my cooking very coachable tell me
what I got a I'm a coachable guy what do
I got to do I'm a coachable guy super
coach won't want to make money I'm
second time being broke my dad's at the
99 cent store too many heart attacks I
want to get out of this yeah so I'm like
hey Patrick basic stuff when you're
doing business and you're talking to
rich people like Morgan Stanley Dean
Witter never talk religion never talk
politics never talk sex just don't talk
about those three things I said okay
guess what never talk politics never
talk religion never talk sex no problem
we're going to business so what do you
think about the political climate today
Patrick David oh what do you think yeah
you know well I think this is but what
do you think Patrick I don't know you
know quite frankly I think I'm trying to
figure it out for myself right now but
we'll see what's going to happen like
you know the whatever way you're
deflecting and you kind of go on your
phone hey what do you think about God
what is your opinion on Islam or Muslim
well you know for me you know there's
you deflect that eventually you're
sitting there you're like
the people that I know at that level
want to talk about those three topics
now sex is maybe off camera and they're
kind of having fun with it yeah but they
want to talk about politics and religion
so we for the longest time have been
silenced and now the ESG community
all this time they've told us to stay
quiet and they're saying what they're
talking politics yeah they're talking
religion and they're talking sex the way
through lgbtq what's wrong with that
what's wrong with it it's normal it's
normal it's normal no it's not normal
well listen you guys shouldn't talk
about politics and sex and religion you
shouldn't be doing that yeah and then
you see this one you know during covet
One Pastor Australia Syrian man I don't
know what his name is Vinnie what's his
name the Syrian Pastor priest from
Australia and he was fighting all the
anti-covet guidelines and he's his stuff
is going viral he's doing this and he's
seen these messages some of the people
that stood up they stood up because they
feared God okay and for you with your
life it's been interesting watching you
go through your evolution of your faith
pre-2022 former atheist couple of the
things you've said in the past God isn't
real because you can't prove it okay
kind of like that was more the Malcolm X
argument right bad things happen to good
people and good things happen to bad
people far too often for God to exist
I'm the Center of My Universe that's
pre-2020. then gradually you start
talking about Christianity and you know
in 2020 made a video announcing that you
were wrong about what you had said
previously about God right
now you start saying people are who are
atheists are angry bad energy people and
I don't want to be on that team anymore
and even if God is not real the world is
a better place if people do believe in
God I know God is real because there's
so much evil in the world that there has
to be an equal and opposite Force the
devil can't exist if God does not and if
you look at the world today it is very
obvious that the devil does not exist
and I'll go to the last one here with
Muslim
quotes from you Christians don't have a
religion anymore because they tolerate
everything and stand for nothing and by
the way I actually agree with you the
fact that they're they're tolerating way
too much Islam is the last religion on
the planet God is something to be feared
respected and to prove yourself too
which means you got to earn his right
it's a hey I want to earn your right
your respect right
how did you go if you don't mind talking
about your own Evolution because us as
men
if you know me at 25 years old you
probably would have liked that party
with me I was a selfish guy I was a guy
you would have thought I was right and
we go through this phase of
where the selfishness kind of comes down
a little bit you still need to be
selfish because you need to be driven
but to the point where you're like
listen man I gotta really do something
and then somehow somebody God enters
what's been your evolution of your faith
and where where are you at today yeah I
think Newton's I think it's Third Law
equal and opposite Force what you just
said there is absolutely true there has
to be equal and opposite Force to all
the evil in the world and that the equal
and opposite Force to all that evil has
to be God and I've talked about this at
length even with atheists and I try and
say that regardless of whether you're an
atheist or not you're thinking of God as
a man in the sky but you need to think
of God as a concept as a whole and once
you do that it's impossible to accept
that he doesn't exist right I said to
The Atheist I said let's say there was
two islands you're Shipwrecked right and
there's two islands both of them are
full of savages on wine one Island
you're ruin your friendship right on one
Island your friend goes and he crashes
and they they kill him and they eat him
and you go to another Island and they
want to kill you and eat you but they
don't because it's against their
religion
did God save your life
who cares who doesn't know the name of
their God but their God said don't kill
shipwreck survivors and now you're alive
so their God saved your life the concept
of God in and of itself saved your life
you own God so for the concept of it the
idea of it so even the idea of opposing
evil as a whole is a belief in God so
you're either an evil person or you
believe in God in some regard
and then
I became once I understood that there
had to be an equal and opposite Force I
was raised Christian I live in a
Christian Nation the Romania is actually
I think the second or third most
Christian country on Earth it's very
Christian country here it's churches
everywhere they strongly believe and
that's where I began my journey but I
always had a very healthy respect for
Islam because I understand that to a
degree to have a religion at all you
have to have an intolerance to a degree
because without an intolerance you don't
have rules you don't have laws you don't
have any like you said you have to earn
God's respect if you're a religion which
is tolerant of everything then you don't
have to earn God's respect you can be a
bad person and do bad things God loves
me so it's fine well no it's not because
that's not the point of the religion so
then you extrapolate that out and I'll
sit and thinking what's the primary
function of a religion
and the primary function of a religion I
don't believe is the religion exists so
I can live forever I mean that's a
that's a nice thought but I think on a
macro level the primary objective of a
religion is to restore and contain some
degree of traditional value within the
society how do you judge let me change
the way I worded that how do you judge
the success of a religion I don't think
you can judge it by the number of people
who join it because there's lots of
people who are Catholic who don't act
Catholic they don't act in any way
particularly Christian anyone can say
there's something you can walk into a
strip club and everyone says Christian
doesn't mean anything right so how do
you judge the success of a religion well
I like to think the best way to judge
the successful religion is how
successful is it at fighting evil how
successful is it at preserving the
morality
of a population in X parameter in an ex
geographical area so when you look at it
from that way you can't say that Islam
isn't the most successful religion on
Earth it's the most successful in
regards to opposing evil it's the most
successful in regards to opposing its
differing viewpoints it's the most
successful in regards to having people
act within the limits and the confines
of what it finds to be moral and good to
God it's the most adhered to it's the
most feared it's the most respected in
most forms and then also I'd like to
think I would say it's the most fear
yeah it's the most fear but what is
respect without fear
do we respect Men We Don't Fear
but there's a man who could do
absolutely nothing to you on any level
at all you might be nice to him sure
because we're not bad people but would
you really respect it if you could take
his chick in front of his face set his
car on fire he wouldn't do a thing you
wouldn't expect him you might be nice to
him because they're not bullies we
wouldn't respect him respect and fear
are linked they're not always the same
thing and you can you can maybe have
fear without respect but it's very hard
to have respect without fear but also I
I heard someone say once that we see the
world as we see ourselves if you're if
you think everyone's a thief if you're a
liar you think everyone's a liar and I I
kind of agree with that I understood
that
I also like to think we see religion as
we see ourselves I like to see myself as
a person whose respect you have to earn
I like to see myself as a person who has
strong rigid boundaries I like to see
myself as the person who'll stand up and
say no that's wrong I like to see myself
as a person who's not afraid of being
shamed by whatever Community for saying
I don't agree with that particular ideal
I liked seeing myself that way so if I'm
going to see myself that way then I'm
going to naturally align with a religion
that operates within that form so when I
say Islam is the last religion on Earth
I say it because it seems to be the only
one who will stand up and say no
we don't care no that's not what the
book says no
I was raised Christian and and Muslims
as a whole we have no problems with
Christians none at all I don't want
anyone to think I'm anti-christian like
I dislike Christians we don't have a
problem with Christians we believe in a
lot of the same things we believe in
Jesus we put more respect on the name of
Jesus than most Christians do
I just don't like the idea of people
saying they're a Christian and saying
but because I'm a Christian I can do
whatever I want and throw all the rules
away none of it matters because once you
have that level of Tolerance you no
longer have a religion Islam seems to be
the last religion left with parameters
if you don't parameters you're not
religion at all
so the closer I found myself to God the
closer I saw I found myself this long
that's just how it ended and Andrew
speaking of fear one could argue that
Islam these days certainly in the last
20 years with the war on terror they've
also been the most vilified absolutely
right so you know everything that we've
seen happen with
extremism and everything that's going on
all over the world how are you grappling
with that you've been a Christian for
for years now Islam and you know what's
you know what that's such an interesting
question because when I was younger
especially when I was an atheist I would
I would sit and I'd sit and think
people are really doing Terror taxing
and doing all this crazy stuff because
you know they're upset over a cartoon
that's so stupid and nobody should kill
me nobody should kill Charlie hebdo
everything nobody should kill anybody
nobody should kill anybody I'll make
that very clear but also part of me is
now saying
why would you want to insult the profit
for billions of people why would you
want to do that I'm not saying you I'm
not even I don't want to make the
argument against Free Speech I'm saying
you couldn't be allowed to this is a
sensitive subject I'm just saying what
kind of person wakes up and thinks I
want to do that I don't know I just
don't think that's a healthy mindset
like when I see these satanists and
they're especially in America and
they're doing let's keep it on
Christianity these satanists and they're
dressing up Jesus is gay and all this
stuff like that's not done in any kind
of good faith there's no good reason to
do that that's done with genuinely
malicious intention
and what kind of people want to do that
and then the answer by extension is
I thought America was a Christian
country so how can you have a Christian
country where the the profits of the
religion are mocked to the highest
possible levels within the confines of
the country and and it's promoted
is that Christian country
doesn't seem a Christian country to me I
don't think the same thing would happen
with Islam and Saudi Arabia I can't
imagine that happening so how can you
say we're a Christian country but
everyone's mocking Our God on the
streets
it's it's on Netflix ha ha ha
that's not a Christian country to me so
if you're not a Christian country then
where's the religion where the religion
is supposed to enforce certain
boundaries you're supposed to at least
show it respect you know and it's also
kind of interesting because
in Christian countries there's more
respect for Islam than there is for
Christianity
in a Christian country name one they
still don't do it with the Islamic
Prophet why do you think that is it's
too much smoke
it's just not worth the Heat
because because people believe and I'm
not advocating for violence on any level
I'm saying that even these degenerates
who are trying to destroy people's
belief in God like we've discussed
earlier because they don't want you to
have any Baseline morality if you
believe in god there are Commandments
yes and no that Baseline morality
prevents you being an absolute slave so
they're trying to destroy it but even
those degenerates who are trying to Mock
and disgrace God understand there's a
point where it just backfires and move
this is smoke
and they don't want the smoke and
shouldn't God be feared I'm scared of
God
it's the only thing I fear I Fear God
they can put me in jail I know I'm
telling the truth God's on my side I
Fear God
so God should be feared so once again
does anybody fear the Christian God I
haven't seen anybody scared of him in a
long time
and it's kind of crazy because it's very
interesting
the max the like the mass migration all
these things are leftist policies but
then also Islam is the most right-wing
religion on Earth it's kind of very
interesting I grew up in England and I
grew up in Luton which is a town which
is mainly Muslims like this it's a huge
Islamic community and there was a bunch
of English people who were complaining
about this too much immigration we're
losing our culture and I understood
their point absolutely but it is the
same people complaining about all the
left-wing LGBT and schools all these
issues I don't think the only allies you
have against this are the Muslims
they're the only allies you have in any
of this the Christians don't protest
against any of this stuff the Christians
don't the Christian there's very few
Christians will get up off their ass and
complain in fact I saw on Twitter
yesterday one of the churches was lit up
in rainbow
I have nothing against gay people
that's actually another point I want to
make into about this thing I think most
people don't care and I think that
bothers them have you ever had a have
you ever had an argument with a girl
and she's like strapping around the
house she's huffing and puffing and you
just don't give a [__] so she has to
keep up in the ante to eventually go
what's the problem because she tried the
low level stuff and you didn't care
I kind of feel like this has a remnants
of that I'm gay cool
I want to get married
I want to wave my dick in your kid's
face
it's like whoa whoa whoa
I feel like they're like they tried to
annoy us and we're like we don't give a
[__] do whatever you want be a person we
don't care and now we're like okay well
we have to get to a limit where they
have to react we want attention now we
want them to care about what's the right
move on that well that's and that's the
point you know it's it's difficult
because there comes a point where you
simply have to address it and now you
have to oppose it and this is sorry
sorry to disrupt you but this is why
they're so careful and so clever with
what they do they package it all
together
lgbtq I would argue I don't know what Q
is firstly sorry I don't know what
you're questioning all right LG I would
argue that G and T are very different
things Beyond a gay man and someone
who's chopped the dick off are very
different things so they package it all
together so now because the spectrum of
your enemy is so large you have people
who are complete fully this way you have
people who we accept and are normal in
society we have no problem with gay
people and they put it all together
you're an enemy of all these people and
they complicate the argument and they
mix it all together and now you're a
bigot and really you just want your kids
to be left alone really just want to
leave the children of course but all you
want to do is leave your kids alone and
then it's like okay I'm now raising
children I have more children than most
people would believe how do I protect my
children from this incentive God
which God can protect my children
Allah Islam I'll move them to Dubai or
Saudi Arabia and none of this will
happen
can I trust a Christian Nation some of
them remaining is a Christian Nation and
to a large degree they oppose quite a
lot of this stuff but they're also NATO
and they're also EU and they also rely
on bailouts and grants and money and on
a long enough time frame even in the
seven years I've lived here I have
watched certain attitudes change because
money buys influence and power so Andrew
not to cut you off
how much of you converting from
Christianity to Islam is actually the
belief in God versus
the societal pressures that are facing
because it seems like it's a little bit
of both for you to believe in God you
have to respect him
how can I believe and put the put my
life in the hands of someone I don't
respect
and I'm going to respect a god which is
feared
yeah but it's a vertical relationship
right it's not a horizontal if you base
if you base it horizontally they're
going to disappoint you if you think
about if you're going to believe let's
go believe Prophet Muhammad his teaching
and let's go believe the Bible NIV and
Jesus father you know for God so loved
the world that he gave us you know you
gave your son for me let's say that's
true and you're doing it based on faith
who would do such a thing for me what a
level of sacrifice for you to do that
who am I for you to be so worried about
me if you look at it from that angle
it's not necessarily coming from a place
of fear it's coming from a place of
Grace that's coming from a pla Grace a
place of love it's coming from a place
of absolutely you know or a different
feel because I do believe
uh the part that upsets me is the fear
aspect that they're allowing others to
mock your God to mock mock Jesus to mock
whatever religion it is you're a part of
you're kind of like they're just funny
man so no it's not funny you just cross
the line like JC has that one line where
he says don't tell me why the guy
what the guy said about me tell me why
he was so comfortable saying it to you
100 you tell me why say comfortable to
you so I think that's the part about
uh faith I understand when you're saying
to fear in the respect side so that's
the part where fear is needed I totally
agree but the part where you you were
making a point about lgbtq you're like I
don't know what Q stands for is
questioning and then you're like well
I'm gay okay cool
trans listen man spectrum and he said on
the if we were to say which religions
the far right it's going to be Muslim
totally get it they're on the far right
Christian today is kind of going Center
left today like they're kind of being
soft right now okay so if I'm gonna
raise my kids I'm going to take my kids
to you know Dubai and I'm going to take
my kids to Saudi Arabia why because I'm
defending against some of these immoral
philosophies that they have I don't want
to go there I actually understand that
argument yeah and and I truly and I want
to make one more point I do believe
there is one God and I believe there's
many different paths to God and I'm not
a religious scholar and I'm not an
expert on Islam I'm doing my best and
I'm reading the Quran as often as I can
and it does say that Christians on the
Day of Reckoning will see how close they
were to the truth and we are we are
allies we are not enemies in any regard
Christians and Muslims and I do believe
that the idea of Christians and Muslims
shaking hands and saying let's put an
end to a law this garbage would be
fantastic I'm not anti-christian in any
regard I just found myself as I became
more and more religious seeking and
looking for
a faith witch normally I could be proud
of but a faith which was guiding in
regards to I don't know what a Christian
would answer to certain questions
nowadays what does a Christian answer to
I'm a transsexual and I want to show
your kids my genitals what's the
Christian well Christian's supposed to
say no do they
I know what my I know what my Muslim
friends would say I don't know if you're
a Christian I don't know how you're
supposed to act I don't know what you're
supposed to adult I don't get it anymore
the True Believer says the True Believer
the True Believer but how many are True
Believers and I mean I don't know I see
all over Twitter all these churches are
losing their minds it's just seems very
complicated Islam seems very very simple
you know what's right you know what's
wrong I have a question regarding we
talked about tolerance and acceptance
and the other end of that is extremism
so I'm a Jew Christian
Newfound Muslim respect look at all
hanging out here yeah you know the
beginning of a joke somewhere you know
so I you know we're talking about
accepting the you know we have gay
friends we have lesbian friends bisexual
the T stuff is what it's kind of like
all right what's actually even happening
here you know I'm not a yeah this is not
my wheelhouse nor any of our wheel
houses but one could argue that you know
on the on the opposite end of the
acceptance and the tolerance is like
absolute extremism and I'm sure the
allies of the LGBT will point to Islam
and point to the Middle Eastern
countries important to the North African
countries that have Islam as their
religion and say they are the most
extreme when it comes to LGBT they say
that it should be illegal to be gay and
in some countries you should be killed
if you are super this is just I'm just
playing your right staff you're right
and this is super interesting arguments
because I will I will sit here and say
that I guarantee in most Islamic
countries there are gay people and I
guarantee that they have gay
relationships and nobody cares as long
as they're not trying to inflict on the
children it's illegal to walk down the
street and do indecent things in front
of children but I guarantee if you were
gay in a lot of these countries you know
privately nobody would care because
they're trying to preserve the family
unit and to a degree you have to always
protect innocence when you were to talk
about extremism I would be friends with
a gay person yes I'm a Muslim but I
would be friends with a gay person
because if a full-grown man decides to
make a decision it's his decision to
make but I must protect Innocents as a
man so I must protect children if two
men if two full-grown men decide to have
a fight Let them fight if a full-grown
man decides to pick on a kid that's
unacceptable so I must protect innocence
so I agree with the extremism point but
I have no problem with full grown men
doing what they want to do maybe some
Islamic scholar is going to watch this
and get mad at me I don't have a problem
being gay with gay people and being
friends with a gay person I don't care
my problem is when you take a person who
is unarmed who is innocent who is
programmable like a child and start
inflicting your worldview on them that
is disgusting and Immortal that is
unfair and it can't be accepted on any
level and that's the reason
homosexuality is genuinely outlawed in
these countries not because they fear
what two full-grown men are going to do
they fear what's happened in the west so
two full-grown men are going to purport
on the minds of children which aren't
theirs that's what they're afraid of
you know I don't know if you saw the
interview uh CNN uh is interviewing this
the in Africa and I have the video I
don't want to play the video obviously
the leader yes I'm talking about
democracy he says democracy look you can
do whatever you want to do though he
says what do you think about gays and
his reaction was like what do you mean
what they do I don't think I don't agree
with what they do you think that's okay
anyways he's given his argument right
and the lady's reaction is like how
could you says look you keep your
beliefs to you do not bring it to our
country here right uh the the challenge
goes back to remember how you're like
the girl that you're dating is like so
what happened I ask you to bring the
oranges from the store how come you
didn't bring it yeah I forgot hey so how
about this Amazon and you know that's
why you love your mom more than you love
me and you're like oh [__] are you
getting around them and now there's a
fight right okay
well
is the mistake being too tolerant from
the beginning
is the mistake being too accepting from
the beginning is the mistake of you know
you know like the the fear when I talk
to Second Amendment guys and the fear
about well you know what's wrong with
them doing background checks what's
wrong with them doing this he says look
that's that's how it starts you give
them the background checks then they're
going to come for everything well you're
over exaggerating no one's coming for
your guns well you also said 20 years
ago Hillary Clinton marriages between a
man and a woman and the sanctity of
marriage 20 years later so that is the
fear where one must watch this as a case
study say somebody start a new country
and saying look here's where we stand
these are the laws we're not touching
we're not going to be doing XYZ you've
been too tolerant and now you're paying
the price for it and now you're reacting
to it and that's exactly why you
completely nailed it if you give an inch
to take a mile and that's why I think in
a lot of these countries they have an
official it's officially illegal they're
actually quite tolerant of it more than
you'd believe I'm telling you you can go
to Jordan and your waiter will be a bit
free you can tell now cares nobody cares
nobody gives a [__] right but they have
it officially illegal to prevent it ever
bleeding out into actually affecting the
mindset of society you can do what you
want you're a full-grown man but Society
is based on family traditional Family
Values that's how our society is based
that's how we show ourselves to the
world and that is not going to be
affected or changed I was going to say
that's why you see the the you talk
about the collapse of Western Society
specifically America you see decline in
values Wall Street Journal came out with
that article that said Family Values
plummeting religion plummeting uh being
a social uh being Community organizer
plummeting everything's plummeting in
America other than money people are uh
focusing on money my neck is an
application which allows you to take a
minute to connect with influencers from
all around the world my name is Andrew
Tate and I'm available to speak directly
to you on minute so so it's interesting
while you're while you're talking about
this whole religion thing while you're
in who has reached out to want to
support we talked about this last time
briefly yeah uh uh being a Muslim
yourself have some of the most powerful
Muslims reached out trying to help out
figuring out a way to get you out yeah
absolutely they certainly have and also
the amount of mail I got from Muslims
around the world was completely
incredible when I was in the cell with
Tristan he even said he said well I'm
Christian nobody's written to me yes
yeah so it was kind of amazing to
support we that you have from the the
Brotherhood and you certainly feel part
of the family and I've had a lot of
support from them as a whole
um it was Ramadan at the time I was in
jail so my first Ramadan was in jail so
that was certainly interesting because
you eat when the Sun goes down
and my meal came when the sun was up so
I'd have to cover it up and try and hide
it from cockroaches and wait for the sun
to go down and then eat it cold by
myself but I felt like you know if
you're gonna do it the first time you
may as well jump in the deep end and do
it hard so I I did that and that was a
experience
and jail as a whole I mean there's so
many stories I can tell there's so many
different ways I remember it there were
times I laughed
I will sit and say some of the best days
of my life were in jail get out of here
yeah and some of the worst days of my
life were in jail but there were days
where me and Tristan when we were
finally in the same cell
there's times we laughed like we've
never laughed before I'll sit and admit
that's absolutely not really true I feel
like if you're going to be the kind of
person who strives for an exceptional
life which is what I am I think I'd be a
coward if I said I want an exceptional
life but I only want to be exceptional
in a good way I don't think that's
genuine I want an exceptional life thing
exceptional means away from the norm and
away from the norm means flying your
Bugatti on a jet to Dubai and taking
your own plane to meet it there and it
also means a Romanian dungeon quick
cockroaches on New Year's Eve they're
both exceptional experiences and the
times I was with my brother and it was
just him and I
we truly had some genuine days where we
laughed like we always laugh me and him
laugh and have fun on a private jet and
we laughed and had fun in a Romanian
prison cell because that's just who we
are and I also have to give my brother
some credit while we're here I would
like to state that I absolutely
genuinely believe I have the best
brother in the world and I'll tell you
why
I always knew I had the best brother in
the world but he proved it in jail and
I'll tell you why
my brother was put in jail for being my
brother
he hasn't said any videos he hasn't said
anything on the internet he even said
any other things I've supposedly said
he's not the Matrix isn't attacking him
the BBC doesn't forget about him nothing
why was Tristan Tate in jail because
it's Tate brothers so they just took him
and threw him in a cell now what's
interesting is when I got out of jail so
many people near me got Heat
all business partners got hate with
attacks they got hit with like a tax
paperwork and uh they were calling
everyone who's ever known me and
ex-girlfriend's got heat and all these
people got heat and some people
complained some people didn't but some
people were like oh since you've been in
jail it's been so stressful for me the
media's outside my house I'm stressful
for you I was in jail what do you want
me to do and people were complaining at
me and as these people start to complain
I sat there I said to Tristan
you got thrown in jail purely for being
my brother and never for a fraction of a
second did you even moan
didn't even not even for a fraction of a
second did he say oh they only put me
here because of you why am I here I'm
innocent this is nothing to do with me
nothing in fact he said the absolute
opposite he said I am so glad I went to
jail with you I would be furious if they
sent you here by yourself and they're
going to lock you up they better lock me
up and there was a time about two months
in because there's less media pressure
on Tristan they were talking about
releasing Tristan first and he was
saying no I won't leave without Andrew
going down with the ship I won't leave
unless my brother leaves I won't leave
and he was telling the guards I won't
leave keep me here I'm not leaving they
said the judge says you have to leave
you to leave because then I will stand
outside the gate I'll sleep outside
I ain't leaving this jail and our lawyer
said well we can make an appeal to just
release you because there's less media
scrutiny around you and just saying no
Andrew's in jail I'm in jail refused to
leave he was adamant he had to stay
that's a brother for me and it was the
same for me I said to Tristan if they
came in to me and said Andrew go home
I'll be like no no way Tristan's in jail
I'm in jail we're in jail together he
never for a second complained never
bitched never moaned and he was only in
jail for being my brother and then I
come out and there's other people oh
they sent me a piece of paper blah blah
blah you're moaning it's unbelievable
you truly learn like I said jail
confirms everything you already knew
about the world and you truly learn
who's on your side and who isn't and
that's good to learn but
it's it's actually crazy
the also the the larger psychological
analysis of it all everyone lives inside
their own minds right so it's kind of
crazy I came out of jail
and some of the first messages I got
from people was them complaining about
the problems me being in jail had given
like
you think that wouldn't happen right you
think oh you come out of jail people
will be like oh are you okay they're
like oh you're okay you're out now okay
yeah well listen
Mo you'd be amazed you'd be amazed and
I'm like
I was in jail what do you want me to do
yeah that sounds unfortunate I was in
your jail cell what do you want me to do
about it it's kind of crazy how much
everyone's kind of self-interested so
it's been a learning curve and you learn
a lot about a lot of different people
and your circle gets smaller
and I think that's probably one of the
reasons God put me in there to just
learn a lot and make my circle smaller
and you just have to listen to him and
pay attention to it and say okay right
you're off you're off you're off you're
on you're on your own but my brother I
have to give him credit because I tell
you
I also think me and Tristan are one of
the best teams in the world because we
have different roles inside of our
Brotherhood
my role is to be concerned and to panic
not panic that's the wrong word I never
Panic my role is to be concerned and try
and fix the problem I'm in jail pacing
up and down how do we get out
and Tristan's role is to not care and
together that helps us achieve the
objective best because when we really
need to get out I'm in charge
his role is to not care sometimes
when it was when it was at the height of
frustration I needed his superpower
Tristan's superpower and this is a super
powerful life is he is the master of not
giving a [__] we would go to court
we would go to court
imagine this you're in jail right
weekends were the worst because the TV
was worse on weekends for some reason
like you had to do like three channels
at the TV the weekends were the worst
and you could hear out the window
everyone having fun I hated weekends so
on a Friday would roll around I'd say
Okay Tristan we just have to Zen away
the weekend and on Monday There's Court
we just to Zen away the weekend
so for the weekend we just sit there
staring at the wall intrusive thoughts
can't sleep all those things you're
trying to get your brain just sitting in
silence because the room's tapped just
staring at the wall just staring at the
wall and you think Monday would never
come and Monday would eventually come
right or Sunday night comes and 8 A.M on
Monday they're going to take you to
court and they might let you go home
they might let you go home you've done
nothing this person in this room can
decide if you go home and it's Sunday
night and you can't sleep and you're
awake all night long there's no clock
but you just you just the seconds feel
like hours you're just sitting there
eventually a am comes put you in
handcuffs walk you to the court you walk
in there everyone speaks Romanian don't
have a clue what's going on everyone's
just talking at each other in Romanian
then they say you'll get the answer in
three hours go back to jail when I went
back to jail I was sitting in the room I
was like do I pack to go home no that's
too optimistic okay but you're nervous
you're like you're anxious am I gonna go
home is it over do I get to go home I
called the lawyer do you have an answer
yet no no answer yet okay sitting there
I can barely sit still Tristan finishes
Court walks straight into the room it's
a matrix attack it's [__] I'm going
to sleep and went to bed clean asleep I
was like how the [__] are you asleep you
didn't care at all he just went straight
to bed and then when he woke up like six
hours later mattress attack I'm like
yeah you thought so just rolled back
over didn't care but it's perfect for a
guy like you but that's what you need I
need that I agree because if I had
someone else next to me is hyped as me I
would have gone insane I agree I need
someone like him who's just like he had
the superpowers like bro I love jail
Jail's great look we got coffee I love
jail none of my women are messaging me I
love jail truth I may I I'm telling you
I had 45 minutes on the phone a day and
I used all of my minutes Tristan never
made a single phone call from jail get
out of it not one I was like Tristan do
you want to speak to anyone nah
they're watching Romanian news didn't
give a [__]
like bulletproof but the only reason
he's so bulletproof that way is because
he knows I'm doing the absolute best the
other way he couldn't be that way if I
wasn't trying to get us out because then
he would try to get out you need the yin
and yang so like when I when I when it
was chill time it was his mental frame
and when it was attacked how do we get
out here it was my mental frame but
Tristan's superpower genuinely is
genuinely genuinely not caring I can't
explain the level of how much he didn't
it didn't affect him he didn't bother
him at all I didn't see him sad
nothing you smiling he didn't care you
consider yourself a stoic how much more
stoic is he than you I just think we
have different roles and I think we've
evolved into them over the time because
it's not just jails and everything
that's what we are with everything if
there's a business problem I'm the one
who's like [__] we have to fix this now
[__] [__] and Tristan's the one like
Andrew you are so ridiculously Rich
chill
but we need that we need both right but
he couldn't be that chilled if I wasn't
the way I was because he wouldn't be
successful totally see you need the
opposite so everyone goes oh you and
your brother are so close we're so close
because we're actually very different
people but yeah he he was amazing in
jail and even afterwards
I I still struggle to sleep he sleeps
fine because I think my experience of
jail
was a far more stressful one because I
but I adopted that now I'm not saying I
couldn't have done what Tristan did I
could have done what Tristan did if I
were to go into jail and say your MO is
to not care I could not care but my ammo
was how do I get out of this Matrix
attack so I I was the most stressed I've
ever been in my life so that's carried
over so I don't sleep he sleeps fine but
he slept fine in jail so why wouldn't
you sleep fine now right
so yeah it was uh it was interesting but
I have to give him props because it's
it's amazing to
have that level of clarity and he said
things which were absolutely not really
true things I already knew but it was
nice to hear I want to ask you a
question on this so I have two boys
right and one that they're going to
watch this they're not going to watch it
right now they're 11 nine but they're
one they're going to watch this right uh
and in school you know I'll go and the
kids that are you know 11 12 13 they're
like you you Andrew how was that
interview oh my God so 11 year old kids
are watching these types of content but
yeah that's pretty wild where they're at
but here's a question about brothers
there's a lot of brothers out there as a
father there are certain principles I'm
teaching them okay one if you can speak
from the idea of how your bond was built
based on a man your father memory
injecting certain values and principles
into two of you yeah you guys better do
this I don't want to see this yeah and
then which part of the code did you guys
create because there's friendship but
there's Brotherhood there's a very
different story absolutely how was that
developed yeah so my father and I have
endless stories about my father a lot of
people who dislike me would call him an
extremist I don't think he was an
extremist I truly believe I had the best
father on the planet and from a very
young age he made it clear he said look
you're a tate and you're going to have
animation of people who are against you
your best bet is to be a team so
whenever me and Tristan would fight
which happened we got put in a room
together and we had to sit in that room
and my dad would say three hours or four
hours in silence
sit us down in the room here here
looking at each other and say if I hear
a noise I'm starting the time again and
we'd have to just imagine you know
you're a kid and you fight and you're
Furious and you're so mad and then you
end up sitting across from the person
you hate
silent because you make a noise dad gets
mad and Dad's outside right so just sit
there two hours don't make a noise
we had to stare at each other and over
time we thought every time dad was home
we just stopped fighting because it
wasn't worth it sitting in this
isolation weird silent stare thing
because that's what happened don't
repeat it happened like five times and
we just stopped fighting we'd literally
we'd fight all the time when Mom was
home and when Dad would come home we'd
literally just look at each other like
truce like we can't we don't want to sit
and do this thing we had to do so we
became a team and then I think it
evolved from there because there's
always been a hierarchy I am the older
brother I'm the bigger brother he does
respect me for that we both have
opinions but you know it can be it can
be vetoed by me in the end and we have
our specific roles my specific role is
I'm I'm the one who takes the most
action I'm the one who over worries I
believe especially in business and many
other things I say it to all my staff I
say react I said react fast react early
like Panic early like Panic now
I don't believe in waiting for things
it's just not who I am I can give you a
million different examples if if my
email processor just happened
before my cancellation said oh we'll put
your account under review you'll have an
answer in 72 hours as soon as I get that
email within three minutes I'm like get
a new one get a new one I've never
waited for anything in my life and it
worked I've never waited and it worked
out fine Ever every time that you're
canceled every time I should delete it
every time somebody gonna get a new one
now get just get a new one I need
today's email I'll get a new one we
can't get into it no no accept us build
one
like I'm the Panic fast and early guy
Tristan's the complete opposite and that
makes us a perfect Synergy and I I super
need him and I need his energy
especially in jail man he was fantastic
in jail he was like Andrew holy water he
goes if when you were 18 they told you
you could be one of the richest most
famous men on Earth
with street cred in every single City
that knows how to speak English all you
had to do was sit in jail for two months
would you have taken it it's like yeah
he goes what the [__] do you care for
so true now we're talking that he goes I
know he says that what kind of man
hasn't been to jail
what kind of man hasn't been to jail he
loved jail he was loving it all the time
he goes what kind of man is in the jail
of course I'm in the jail I'm just today
of course I go to jail but he didn't
care and his energy was amazing to tap
into but we both understand that we
neither of us could be us without the
other ones polar and that's why we live
together that's why we'll always live
together
I've had a lot of like women try and say
why do you still live with your brother
why do you want to live with me and I
try and explain to them that
one I don't think I can be my most
competitive without him
two I'm most emotionally stable with him
I like the idea I'm most competitive
with him I I'm my best version of me if
it doesn't matter I have to go into a
fight doesn't matter if I have to run a
business I'm better with Tristan by my
side than I would be by myself
and three
my ideal family life even my ideal
family the way I live my life now is
very much more like a clan than a
nuclear family I like me my girl my kids
Tristan his girl his kids my cousin his
girl his kids I like this idea of lots
of people I like that I like that
feeling
so girl says to me well you don't want a
family like no I want family bigger than
you want I just don't want to just sit
with you I want a lot of people around
me and I think it's better for that and
I think it's better for the children
especially also I think they enjoy it
more
but yeah I've got the best brother on
the planet I truly do and um this is why
I'm saying some of our Best Days of Our
Lives are in jail I was going to ask you
that you guys live here in this compound
it's amazing place I was going to ask
you you kind of just answered it but you
foresee yourself living with your
brother the rest of your life thousand
percent thousand percent I can't imagine
not wanting to live with Tristan if you
want privacy you have privacy right we
have a big house
it is what it is but I can't imagine
him not being around if there's a
problem I just shout his name or I just
can't imagine it and and I know on my
best self also there's the overall the
overall
male competition the masculine
competition that exists between us
between all men so we live currently
here we've got me my brother my
brother's personal trainers here we got
camera guys here we've got War Room guys
here we've got loads of guys here but I
can give you a million examples there
was a record set a next story of a gym
and there's a stair machine and there
was a record set of 188 floors within a
time frame I came along and smashed it
with 198. I only held the record for 45
minutes because someone beat it with
202. as soon as the records beat and
everyone gets pissed off and puts their
trainers on puts their shoes on as soon
as it's beaten every
who beat it and everyone goes and did it
and that's how you push yourself to the
level you never thought you'd be able to
push yourself 202 202 floors in 30
minutes good luck 200 no no no he that's
what that was beaten
22. the beating again I don't know
they'll ever get to that but I'm still
198 I gotta try again but the point is
when you have men around you there's
that natural masculine competition and
that's what drives you if you're going
to be the best version of yourself even
if you're a boxer training for a fight
you train with a team
you train with other boxers you train
with other boxers or other trainers
if you're a football if you're a
football team you're pushed by your team
I think life should be the same right if
imagine you took the normal average man
and you moved him into a house of five
people and you had a philosopher and uh
Fitness expert and uh hypnotist whatever
it was
these will be
that will make him a more competitive
person overall because he's trying to
compete with all the other people who
are on his level you don't want to take
[__] position
so I I don't like the idea of my life
without masculine competition that's why
I'll always listen to my brother and if
you met a girl one day who says Tay I
want to have have your babies live with
you but it's kind of weird that your
brother's here what would you say to her
yeah a few of them have said that I
offer some degree of compromise I'm like
look we can have our own house separate
if you really want but I'm going to be
spending a lot of time at that other
house including night's over I want to
stay with where my brother is so you
wouldn't compromise a little bit but
he's going to be living next door or
with you 100 and I don't think and that
may be unusual
world I don't think that's unusual in
many places I love that you talk about
this all the time you don't even know
how much I love that yeah I love that to
me that as a kid that was a dream like
if you could you know right next to each
other uh live there's a family in our
community
uh billionaire family they live right
next to each other the the oldest son
has the biggest house 12 000 square feet
then the youngest son has the second
biggest house eight thousand square feet
and their parents live in a six thousand
square foot house right next to me
absolutely okay the two boys have four
kids the eight kids are always together
absolutely what a great environment
absolutely it's a dream environment
absolutely I I can't see how a person
wouldn't buy into that the benefits of
it and and there's also benefits to the
relationship because I I think you have
a better relationship with your woman if
she can go and talk with other women and
be with women and I'm with guys and then
you're together sometimes and you can
split it out it's better for everybody
this whole idea of the of just man woman
boom childbang I understand where it's
come from I'm not saying it's all
typically bad but I do think that in
those scenarios there's a lot of men who
are particularly miserable particularly
men especially and the idea of a clan
and having that team around you I love
that I wouldn't live any other way I
love living that way being born and
raised in Miami there's a lot of Latin
culture there yeah and you know the
American friends
they just move out move on their own
that's what they do but in Latin culture
the abuela is living in the house the
family's living in there the the women
are all kind of congregated together we
could also a different world we can also
discuss it financially right if if
you're a man and a woman and you have
three boys and they're let's say
traditional Western whatever they all go
and pay three different rents and they
all move in with their girlfriends and
everyone's getting wrecked right if you
all stay together and combine your
income you also do much better
financially there's not a lot of
immigrants even survived especially
Muslim immigrants in England I've heard
you tell the story about it absolutely
yeah they all stay together in one big
house they all pool their incomes you
have a bunch of people with average jobs
and Ferraris on the drive and then they
buy the house they're in then they buy
another you pull the incomes if you all
split and separate and just spread out
you're just paying all different rents
all different electricity bills and you
just go broke you have to think of the
last name and the generation and the
clan as a whole
so yeah I love the idea I live with my
brother I'll never live without him and
yeah his woman can move in of course his
kids can be around me of course I'm
Uncle why not I have no problem with
that that's a dream let's let's
transition into a couple of the topics
so
um
I saw a video by the president of
Microsoft Brandon I think it was the
president of Microsoft who said
you're going to see one of the biggest
threats in the future being deep fakes
okay and then you saw a similar thing
being said by Google Sergey Brennan you
can see what's going to happen with deep
fakes and then the example of deep fakes
was given by the actress from Wonder
Woman what's her name a Gala
Gal Gadot right there was a deep fake
porn made of her then it was a deep fake
uh video made of trump then there's deep
fake of Joe Rogan there's one of Morgan
Freeman hi I am not Morgan Freeman kind
of goes like this wow so the direction
we're going with deep fake right
when it comes down to AI where do you
see the threat is that something you you
think about is that something you see as
an opportunity as a threat and if yes
which part of it yeah that's a really
interesting question deep fakes are
certainly going to change the world
because
what we're going to have is we're gonna
have a post-truth society and then the
only way they're going to be able to
tell you what's true or not is some
committee which decides what's true and
what to do fake and then they're going
to be in charge of the world and then
they're going to lie to you and then
you're really in trouble so that's going
to be very interesting once you get to
the point where what did I say earlier
about not being able to trust your own
eyes they're going to take that away
from us soon then what then you're
really in trouble
um in regards to AI I think it has to be
adopted inside of my school hostage
University we teach AI with absolutely
everything a lot of the images we
generate even on my Twitter accounts all
Ai and what's actually scary about the
modern world is
I don't consider myself old I'm 36. but
some of the children children I call
them children 17 18 year olds inside of
my Schoolhouse University they're AI
Wizards and they can do magic with this
stuff magic like they can literally
genuinely Andrew Tate on the moon and
the image is generated in seconds like
artists are going out of business I
thought AI would put truck drivers out
of business artists are going out of
business musicians are going out of
business it's kind of scary I do like to
think that with things like AI there's
always going to be some degree of
natural separation between the men who
are genuinely inventive and killers and
the men who are
more
let me change the way I say that I think
if you're an exceptional person a truly
exceptional person you don't have to be
afraid of nearly anything
but Matt you'll probably agree with this
in my experience in nearly every
business in the world you have 10
killers and and you have a bunch who
want the paycheck they do their job
but I wouldn't say they're Killers you
understand and we live in a society for
a long time where I can't even I didn't
even tell you now sometimes when I hire
I'll say to to my cousin or to my my CLL
say look either get one killer or three
normal people
reality that's the basic
free people to have after the job or you
need one killer to do the job and I
think that those three people who have
to their jobs enough to not get fired
they turn up most of it on time but
they're not really that motivated those
are ones who have to fear AI I think
businesses in the near in the medium
term are going to become killers and AI
I tell it now I have some some guys who
work for me on one particular company
and their sales staff I was reading
through the sales scripts The Killers
doing really well but the average guys
that said you're not doing much better
than chat GPT could do right now I want
to warn you that you're not doing much
better that I could replace you with a
machine today let alone them five years
from now for free you need to be careful
so I think it's just becoming more and
more competitive the idea that you can
just be Joe schmoe do your job turn up I
don't try that hard it's fine I think
that's all going to go out the window
because as the world becomes more
competitive as a company you have to
compete with your competitors and the
only way you're going to be able to do
that is just where do you cut the flat
fat when you cut the flat when I see AI
pop it up and getting more and more
intelligent in the way it's talking that
doesn't scare me Bible Way with words
involves Joe schmoe I'd be afraid this
chat GPT can probably text your girl
better than you can
probably probably get laid faster advice
for the guys out there yeah just plug it
in here it'll do better than you do so
that's scary you know that's hilarious I
I think that's what the the average man
really needs to struggle and I've been
saying this has been my message for a
very long time in all Realms I've said
for a very long time that life for the
average man is going to get harder and
harder is becoming more and more
competitive you need to find more and
more ways to stand out and be unique and
the only way to really do those things
unfortunately as a man is to suffer and
that's one of the reasons I'm kind of
glad that God put me in jail because if
you look at anything that builds a man
into a man there's a degree of suffering
it's very hard to become a man and have
a man who's a respected and has stories
and is capable when he only had a nice
life and nice experiences It's usually
the things that made you the best
version of you are usually the worst
things that happen to you so the demons
I carry from jail the fact that I can't
sleep
the fact I can't sleep I've had girls
say to me you can't sleep you need to
see a psychiatrist and I said absolutely
not I would be furious if a psychiatrist
walked in here and took my demons from
me I don't care if they could fix me
with a click they're mine and they were
bestowed to me by God and they are mine
to deal with and they are mine to fix
because that's how I become a better
version of me I would be furious if
someone took them away from me I'm glad
I can't sleep good I can train endlessly
that's why I'm bigger than I've ever
been I'll train every I'm not going to
waste a minute but all the demons have
been given to me by God and all the
problems I've been given to me my God
are mine to fix I would never ever allow
anybody else to take them from me I'd be
furious if a psychologist came in and
said I could cure you I'd say no thank
you I will cure myself I don't care if
it takes 10 years I'll cure myself
that's my job
and I know that when that's done I will
be more mentally resilient than I ever
would have been without you
that's the whole point of it right
so many men say I want to be the man but
they don't want to suffer they don't
want to fight and I don't understand why
because even if you look at a superhero
movie they tell you even in superhero
movies they make it very clear Batman's
parents died that's why he's Batman all
the bad things have to happen there's no
way to get there without the bad things
I get so many emails from people
complaining about their bad things and I
don't have time to reply to any of them
but if I could I'd say good
good luck congratulations off you go of
course you broke your heart of course
you're sad of course you miss her she's
with me now that's life that's part of
it that's the only way you're gonna get
to that level of resilience you can't
become the man any other way
so yeah I I thank God for everything bad
that's ever happened to me and all the
demons and I
I trust that he's not going to give me
anything I cannot in the end decipher
and deal with in the end I think it's a
puzzle
and you decipher it and you work out the
best way to deal with it and you
internalize the good parts and you
become a better and stronger and more
resilient person for it
so I have to thank God for every single
one of them well I mean you got to go
through [__] to be the ship that's
basically what it is and by so by the
way what you're saying is not a
hypothetical you talk about being the
average man you see this play out on
dating apps these days have you seen
what's happened especially on Instagram
and on all the dating apps hinge
bumbling out there the top guys out
there are getting 90 of the women
whereas the bottom guys I think the
stats are a third of men under 30 have
not been laid in a year if being average
is not acceptable anymore at all it's
not acceptable anymore and it's not it's
not acceptable in the sexual Marketplace
but it's also just not acceptable I
don't think even in life anymore period
you have to diversify now so much to
even protect yourself the idea that you
can just be a law-abiding citizen in a
country and just work your job and be
okay is gone it's gone if kova doesn't
prove that I don't know what will yeah
look at my situation you have to
diversify you have to be smart enough
that you have assets and friends and and
capability and lawyers and whatever all
over the world now that's the only way
to protect yourself you can't just sit
within one jurisdiction and go oh well
but I don't speed so it's going to be
okay I don't think it is I think it's
coming to a point where it's not going
to be okay
and AI is going to make it harder and
harder again for those average men it's
going to be harder and harder I don't
think the exceptional men are ever going
to suffer from AI I think we're going to
use AI you think this whole neural link
that Elon Musk just got the approval for
for the patent
so now the sale is going to be look no
matter what you do John you will never
be like Andrew Tate but if yep you take
it's normal GT500
slash Tate you're able to get upgraded
to his levels and think like him and
I'll think and do this and do that for
only 49 000 hours
my mother always says to me I'm glad I'm
not young and I'm starting to say that
now I'm glad I'm not young because I'm
telling you it's gonna be scary right
because the world is hyper competitive
every single thing in the world is
competition I don't think people realize
I'm a hyper competitive person because I
understand that every single thing I
want somebody else wants the girl I want
other people want the car I want other
people want the house I want other
people want the lifestyle the jet every
single thing you want somebody else
wants it's a massive competition as a
man you have two choices you either
accept that as a massive competition and
try and play the game or you just try
and pretend it's not a competition and
Live In Perpetual failure
and it's going to become hyper
competitive the world already is you're
not gonna be able to compete with a
person with a computer brain so you're
gonna you're gonna have to have it
because you can't compete then once you
have it then who knows can they turn it
off I don't know can they turn you off I
don't know can they inject the slave
mind programming directly through the
chip I don't know that's scary I would
never want to do that but it's going to
get to a point where you're not even a
person without it you can't function
without it you're a second class citizen
without it what happens to competition
then is it going to be Whoever has
access to the best uh technology Whoever
has the most recent upgraded version of
XYZ neural link chip absolutely it's
going to become scary I'm glad I'm not
young I hope it doesn't happen while I'm
alive I don't know it's going to be it's
going to be an interesting world does it
does it inspire you want to have more
kids or are you like that's indifferent
I'm gonna have the kids I'm not worried
about that I think yeah I think they I
think in the 1700s they're probably
saying the same thing the future's over
and the Future Ain't that bad so
there'll be a way it will work out I
just have to instill within them the
same values I have and they'll find a
way to work it out and and hopefully
they'll be okay DVD you always say the
future looks bright I mean you must be
concerned you've got four kids I would
have 20 more right now if I could but I
would have 20 more kids right I don't
know how you feel about it I don't have
20 more kids right now if I could
absolutely absolutely love children
there's nothing bad about having
children the only thing I wish I did a
store earlier only thing I wish I did
was yeah well listen right now I don't
know if you know if you need some
inspiration there's this guy named Al
Pacino
I saw that we had a kid at 82. I thought
I was 29 years old and the Nero had it
at 79. wow well so it's never too late
if you got the testosterone level of 32
I'm sure you can have 20 more kids I'll
be okay politics let's talk politics
with uh America you're seeing what's
going on with the election one of the uh
Vantage points you have is you're not
there it's kind of like it's your
problem you guys deal with it I'm over
here on this side
from your perspective YouTube comes out
hey all the election stuff you guys
talked about that we would ban it and
take you down you guys can talk about it
now because we want a balanced argument
from both sides okay no problem
um
who do you see what do you what are your
thoughts on the Trump today 2024
DeSantis Biden how do you see this thing
kind of go politics is is so interesting
it's it's so messy I mean obviously I'm
a trump supporter I believe in Trump I
like the scientists and the things he
did
I I'm not going to choose between Trump
or DeSantis I think if one of them won
if any of them won it would be fantastic
for the world
I think YouTube taking a back step is
actually extremely important
symbolically it'd be interesting to see
if they keep that up post this election
seeing what happens with this election
that'll be very interesting but I think
it's certainly a massive symbolic step
back I remember when I got canceled
nobody talked about Rumble nobody talked
about kick nobody talked about even you
got valuetainment no disrespect you were
a lot smaller than you are now of course
it's crazy how fast Alternatives have
popped up and I'm only saying this
because I do feel like I literally said
I remember my exact words I said there's
pressure behind the dam everyone's tired
of it all it takes is a crack and when
there's a crack there'll be a flood and
the crack in the dam will be a man who
is more famous once he's canceled than
he was before he was canceled that's
what I said now they're trying to put me
in jail which is making me more famous
again I'm not saying it's all because of
me but I'm saying there's definitely a
public Consciousness switch where the
the arbitrars of Truth are having to
backstep now they've overused their
power they overstep their power exactly
we said they would and now they're
allowing open discourse so I hope the
America has a free and fair election
that's what I'm praying for I think
every country should have a free and
fair election especially when we're
going to fly fighter jets and drop 500
000 bombs on Farmers who've never made
five dollars in their day and into the
guise of democracy we're going to bother
to do that that we should at least have
a democracy ourselves so I think a free
and fair election will be interesting
and I think the will of the people
should be done and that's how America
was built and founded and that's what I
would like to see and I do think that
America does lead the public
Consciousness overall as a whole I know
what you're saying about me being over
here but I do think that which which
side wins does have an overreaching
effect overall on the entire planet
America is still the most powerful
country on Earth it'd be very
interesting to see
what happens in 2024 we'll put it that
way crazy question for you he gets
approached all the time pbd when you're
running when you run a PVD he goes I'll
vote for you bro yeah he goes listen I
was born in Iran made in America I can't
run why when are you gonna
but you were born in America entertained
I was here you know you were raised in
Luton UK you've lived in Romania but you
are an American citizen I have no idea
with me first I have no idea you were
president of the United States Andrew
Tate what would that look like I have no
idea what it'd be like to be president
but I have a feeling what Putin said
about the presidents might be true did
you ever see what Putin said yes eight
years they come and go yeah I've been
I've seen three presidents I've seen a
lot of presidents come and go and they
all come with these Grand ideas but once
they get in office the people with the
briefcases and the dark Suits come in
and sit them down because of the strong
bureaucracy inside of the United States
and explain to them how things are done
they never seem to get their ideas done
they never seem to do the things they
said they were going to do you include
Trump in that I think Trump tried his
very best to resist that and that's why
he's in the situation that's why they're
taking him to court for no reason that's
why he was Matrix attacked I mean if
Trump's okay let's let's cut the
regardless I'm going back to jail anyway
probably with this Matrix is not going
to try and kill me anyway they probably
are if Trump's situation isn't a matrix
attack what is
what did they just hit with in New York
some deformation for defending himself
against a lie is that that's not a
matrix attack tell me what what is
possibly else anyone who's sitting out
here who actually truly believes that
the Matrix doesn't exist has no idea how
the world works the media machine and
the legal system work hand in hand to
try and slander people's name and
convince you enough convince the
populist enough that they're guilty so
there's no Revolt so they can hit him
with a guilty plea they've already
decided before all of it it's all it's
all it's all a plan this many months of
negative news then we'll hit him with
this we'll get him guilty for this and
with this many months of negative news
the populists will probably swallow it
it's garbage it's a matrix attack from
head to toe how much do you see yourself
in Trump and do you use your words first
they try to cancel you he was canceled
yeah then they try to throw you in jail
he's dealing with lawsuits lastly they
try to put a bull in there well Trump's
lucky because he's a bit older so Trump
will try and Outlast him oh wait my
problem is I'm a bit Young
and I also think the reason I feel
particularly at risk and I I say these
things on podcast to protect myself and
I don't want anyone to think I'm
paranoid or crazy because I I really
don't believe I am the reason I think
I'm particularly at risk is for the
thing you just said it's the masculine
youth who are my fans it's the 11 year
olds 12 year olds 15 year olds 16 year
olds they are the future of the world
they're the people you want to go and
die in a ditch they're the soldiers you
need those are the people you need Psy
Oak do you need them Psy opt you can't
have a bunch of men who aren't psyopt
that's when you lose control of
everything when the men don't listen
anymore
and they're all listening to me and I'm
teaching them things like God religion
personal responsibility accountability
discipline and everyone's saying well
why are they attacking Andrew for just
telling the truth making me go to the
gym because when you have these things
when you have accountability and
discipline and personal responsibility
you have a barrier you have a parameter
you have a no you have a limit they
don't want you to have a limit none of
the men are allowed limits we must
accept whatever we are given from our
relationship with our woman from the
government from our job we're just the
slaves we're we're the backbone of the
tax bracket we just have to shut up and
pay our taxes as soon as we have limits
that they have a problem that's why they
dislike the things I teach what do I
really say what do I really teach young
kids as genuine dangerous what do I say
go to the gym stick up for yourself
stick up for yourself go to the gym
you're allowed an opinion educate
yourself be smart work hard believe in
things believe in yourself have friends
have strong friends around you don't
listen to dishonest men or dishonest
women it's not misogynistic to say
dishonest people non-gendered should be
anywhere near you you should have
standards for who's your friend
standards for whoever relationships with
romantically with your gay or straight
but you should have standards telling
men to have standard is now wrong think
because as soon as men have standards
they lose control they don't want any
man to have any standard on anything
they want to come along and say no you
need the eighth injection take it
that's all they want I think that's the
saddest thing that's happened to you is
because anybody that listens to your
long-form content not 60 seconds on Tick
Tock fully understands that you're an
advocate for male self-improvement
absolutely get out of depression work
your ass off be coachable make money get
women enjoy the Finer Things in life but
they will take the little things you say
and label your misogynist label your
chauvinist and that's the tip of the
iceberg of minor things you say when you
really are a male Advocate it's
weaponized virtue but also you can't
have an opinion on any kind of
differences or differentiation without
them now calling you a misogynist if if
if I believe a woman is better at
raising young children than a man I
would never drop my child off to a
nursery run by men I think that would be
weird I would never take my two or
three-year-old girl and drop her off in
a nursery which was male run I would
only bring her to a nursery which is
female no would you hire a babysitter
that's a boy neither never am I do I
hate men
no like I just believe that in war a man
should go and raising children maybe
perhaps women should go I just believe
in the same things that everybody
believed in 10 years ago yeah the world
has gone nuts 10 years ago everything
I'm saying was standardized and accepted
and normal and they're taking this
misogynist garbage and weaponizing The
Virtue and trying to attack me with it
and they don't even believe in it it's
truly it's truly upsetting but
I just can't be quiet because I don't
know how
I couldn't live as anyone else other
than me I couldn't live as a per a man
who wasn't trying to be his best self
let's stay on this so you said uh
president then you brought in Putin yeah
so then that discourages for somebody
you think they can make a real change
okay so two question one if you are the
president today I'm sure you've thought
about it yeah what policies would you
attack right now in America I watched
RFK I don't know if you listen to the
recorder yesterday what he said about
the angle he would take with Pharma he
says all these things were talking about
guns he says how is it that we have the
same amount of guns as Switzerland does
per capita but Switzerland hasn't had a
school shooting in 21 years we had it 21
hours ago and we just had one last night
by the way big one I don't know in
Virginia I want to say right yeah seven
people shot just yesterday right every
day there's everything you're talking
about fentanyl you're talking about the
drugs you're talking about lgbtq you're
talking about military industrial
complex economy taxes what what would be
top three issues you would attack if you
were a president today and that's so
interesting because before I answer that
question that ties back into what we're
saying earlier about men's mental health
they pretend they give a [__] about
men's mental health but if you come
along and actually Advocate and tell men
how to be happier I've been a sad man
and a happy man I am a man I know
exactly how it feels on all ranges of
emotion I'll be honest with you right
now when a man is sad yeah there is an
inclination towards aggression that's
how we're born that's how we're evolved
we're evolved with that inclination
towards aggression we need that to
protect and provide that's who we are we
need that bravery but having a bunch of
depressed sad men who have no emotional
control is dangerous for society I say
this all the time they try and pretend
that I'm somehow dangerous for society
by telling men to stand up for
themselves and be masculine absolutely
not really not when you tell a man to
have no emotional control and be more
feminine that's a school shooter a
school shooter is not a man with
masculine accountability he's a man
who's told Act that's how you feel
you feed for long enough throw on some
drugs on top of psychiatrist gave him
throw in a lack of a girlfriend and he's
had enough that's where school shooting
comes from school shooting does not come
from men being masculine it comes from
the absolute opposite of these things
and they know this they know this very
very well
to fix Society we have to fix that in
the most base level the root level I
think America and most countries need
more transparency and understanding of
how things work but when they're
attacking the family unit they're
attacking all of these issues every
issue you've just labeled all starts
down back down to the beginning I really
think the reason I would like to argue
and I don't know any of the statistics
on this in the 1950s I'm sure there was
prevalence of guns all around America
but there just wasn't the school
shooting why what was different what was
different in the years before that there
is now I think it's just because
children obeyed their parents and their
parents were a family and there's a
degree of responsibility that was
instilled inside of people and there's a
degree of accountability and also there
was a degree of honor and pride great
question there's a degree of honor and
pride I'll tell you something now I bet
in the 60s 70s whatever in any country
in the world people didn't want to do
dumb [__] because the family would be
known as criminals the last name would
be tarnished their son did this you hear
what their son did there was a whole
there was a vested interest in all of it
now you have a school shooter is going
to go out there be a piece of [__] and
kill people and then their parents are
on TV while yeah he was failed by the
system they didn't feel any shame it's
unbelievable if one of my children or
someone close to me did something that
heinous I would be disgusted I would I
would apologize just for the sake just
for the name alone there's no honor left
there's no Pride left in the name and
this is what happens when you remove
honor and pride from people you have no
honor and no Pride nothing really
matters what matters anyway it doesn't
matter if you're out of shape it doesn't
matter if your kid's a piece of [__] and
a criminal nothing matters without honor
and pride and this is done on absolutely
every level I said this to Tristan the
other day I was actually saying we were
driving well the other day long long
time ago I haven't left the house in a
while
we were driving I said every even on the
most base level I said every building is
ugly if you notice that every new
building is ugly it's ugly Crystal goes
yeah it's all the same glass big Square
ugly building in the 1400s we built
these ornate gorgeous buildings and now
everything's ugly why is that and well
I'll tell you why it is it's because
they don't want you to have any
intrinsic
attachment to a specific place of all
the buildings are beautiful in a
specific town you have intrinsic
attachment to that town you care about
that town you want good things for that
town you'll protect that town you'll
defend that town what what is that
that's a barrier that's a parameter if
everything looks the same all the time
you'll just move who cares oh they've
messed up San Fran who gets on to move
somewhere else let's move somewhere else
saying globalism doesn't matter it's all
the same buildings in Berlin and New
York they all look the same where's all
the beauty going when there's Beauty you
have an attachment to that beauty they
want to remove all your attachments from
everything
even now when they try and psilop you
into let's say the the way the models
all look different than they used to
before right models all look different
Victoria's Secret yeah and I was arguing
this point and someone's saying oh
that's because you have your eurocentric
beauty standards I said no I'm going to
correct you because I know you think you
sound smart using the word eurocentric
I'm going to correct you because you're
a dumbass let me tell you what beauty
standards are beauty standards by
definition for something to be beautiful
has to at least be unique if everything
is beautiful and it's not beautiful if
everything's beautiful then it's
standardized for you to take a model who
looks the way they look without any
effort at all and they look like most
out of shape uninteresting people on the
street you cannot call that beautiful
because it's standardized you can see it
everywhere Beauty means it must have
been difficult to obtain
whether it's a building it's difficult
to make because it's ornate or a woman
who's trained really hard to have a
beautiful figure that is difficult
difficulty and Beauty are linked you
can't have beauty without difficulty you
cannot show me another model and tell me
that my eurocentric beauty standards are
saying she is in hall because that's not
why she isn't hot because she's made no
effort she hasn't tried that's why and
they're doing this with everything
everything is ugly nothing has a
standard nobody has to try for anything
no parameter no Baseline belief of
what's true and what's false
everything's subjective your truth no
there's no truth there's no such thing
as your truth and this is an attack on
every single level they're assaulting us
from everywhere even the buildings they
build are assaulting you so you can't
even just drive through a town and go
wow look how much energy has been put
into this place I love this place I will
not allow them to do it to this place
now it's just like ah we can move there
ah let's move there at all the same
anyways all Starbucks on the corner on a
7-Eleven who cares it's all the same
Wi-Fi why fight for any of it
this is it's all done purposely I'm
telling you there's they call me a
conspiracy theorists call me crazy I
don't understand why an architect would
now decide who hires an architect I'm
gonna build a building let me hire an
architect to come up with the same
sketch of the same [__] building
which is already existing everywhere how
much did I pay him yeah what we're gonna
do is we're gonna build a skyscraper
made of grass it looks like every other
one is that it we did all this 600 years
ago we built Cathedrals and now we build
this crap why everything is on purpose
it's all Asylum it's all asyle
when they put these models on there the
psyop is you don't have to try
you don't have to try it anything don't
try it doesn't matter just don't try
wait for the government we'll give you
some food stamps you'll be okay let's
participation trophy it's slavery it's
slavery when you need to do every single
thing they say to eat that's their end
goal that's what they want it's slavery
they don't want you trying anything even
going to the gym today is an act of
rebellion even being in good physical
condition is an act of rebellion if I
put up a float with me and I'm in good
physical shape there are people who
write underneath it oh you're dumb you
train so they insult you for it like
it's you're a bad person because you
have standards for yourself
that's the level of bug man they want to
get you to of course these people will
give up meat and eat the bugs and live
in the Pod of course they will they have
no standards they have no self-respect
no standards of course they can live in
an ugly building a big ugly Matrix pod
that's all they want is it somebody has
to sell you on that or is it going back
to conditioning well what would it be is
it someone selling you or is it and it
goes back to my original point about the
family I do believe that a reason we
didn't have so many problems before is
because I believe the families had
standards and some some cultures still
do
I have friends who are Chinese my dad I
cannot not get an A that's just their
culture when my dad was still alive and
he was teaching chess my dad would
charge four or 500 an hour for chess
lessons and towards the end of his life
he goes all of my students are Chinese
or Indian nobody else wants to spend
money 500 an hour and teach her kids
chess only the Chinese and Indians will
spend that money to make sure their kid
is that good so that's it they're the
ones who invest the most in their
children they still care on that level
but most families don't wake up and go
ah
I want my children to act a certain way
for the Legacy for the family name as a
whole I'm instilling standards upon them
because of the last name my entire life
I've had standards has been instilled
upon me my entire life your last name's
Tate you can't do that your last name's
Tate you're not allowed to do that your
last name is Tate but hit him back I've
been like that my whole life
and now we've removed all standards from
everybody this is why you get School
shooters these School shooters should be
too embarrassed to even embarrass their
fathers they should wake up and go I
would never do this to my to my family
and I'll also this is definitely going
to get me canceled but I'm gonna say it
because it's true I'll say it by
extension for suicide
I don't care what you do to me I'm
Andrew Tate I cannot kill myself I can't
I'm not allowed it's against it's
against the Creed of my last name I
didn't have ancestors who suffered how
they suffered who went through what they
went through for me to be born to kill
myself that's not why that's not the end
of my story I refuse I absolutely refuse
no matter how bad it gets or what bad
situation I'm in I refuse to do it
because I have too much respect for my
last name I won't do it
and I and I think that a lot of things a
lot of men's mental health a lot of
crisises can actually just come back to
the old adages of Honor
and and you can fix a lot of it your
girl left you you miss her I get it
we've all been heartbroken she's with a
new guy you're upset she doesn't care
you care I get all of it but there has
to be a point where you get to a level
of Pride and you just go that's not who
I am I lost her that's life
you just got to get on with it and the
best way is to have where do you find
the strength when you're in these
difficult situations I always find the
strength from from my last name I'm
Andrew Tate I'm Andrew Tate so I just
have to do I'm in a Romanian jail cell I
wake up there's cockroaches in my bed
they're all over my face what am I gonna
cry
well am I [__] out how am I going to go
and sign a piece of paper and say I'm
guilty I'm gonna sell my brother out is
that what I'm gonna do am I gonna go
[__] it lie and put these and sell the
girls out like they want me to I'm not
going to stand up and say I'm sorry for
for saying go to the gym like a [__] no
I'm gonna take the Cockroaches off my
mouth I'm gonna do some push-ups because
I'm Andrew Tate when [__] really gets
hard honor and courage and bravery and
your last name is all you've ever had
it's all you're gonna have and it used
to be like that in the olden days that's
why no one did this dumb [__] they were
just too embarrassed to even do it and
this is why you're saying how do we fix
the country absolutely all of it comes
down to the fact that especially with
men none of them are bestowed with the
things that the masculine Essence needs
to be a good man you need Pride you need
honor you need a healthy level of ego
you need all of these things we're
taking it all from boys and what are we
giving them instead video games porn
weed and what do you expect of these
people what do you expect of these [__]
versions of men besides trash output
you're going to get garbage of all
across the Spectrum either they're going
to do nothing or do something bad
they're certainly not going to do
anything good when they don't try for
anything in their lives how they're
gonna do something good
scary thing about all of this is that
there still are two teams in the world
and there are there is a side of the
world where they don't accept this crap
how long is America going to compete
globally when you have countries like
China and Russia and these other
countries they don't do this I don't
know if you saw and they did that survey
to kids of what they want to be when
they grow up did you ever see that yeah
it was crazy every American kid wanted
to be a YouTuber every Chinese kid want
to be an engineer or an astronaut who
owns the future who owns the future
we're in so much trouble we're in so
much trouble as a society what are we
arguing over
it's insane and what do they show you on
Tick Tock though absolutely exactly but
this this let's stay on this you asked a
very important question let's go back to
it we had the same amount of guns 1950
per capita Brandy can you look at that
per cap of how many guns we had in 1950
versus today but it's relatively the
same gun laws haven't changed
dramatically from 1950 until today
what's changed from them today we took
out God out of school
Prozac was invented in 1987. the law to
legalize advertising uh drugs big Pharma
in America was 1985. it's only two
countries in the world that can
advertise Us in New Zealand crazy so you
got God you got Prozac you got uh uh
advertising you got the lgbtq movement
that's taking place you got all of that
taking place to where we are today so
when you're talking about guns what has
changed it's not the guns that's changed
Society has changed standards have
changed completely so so how do you how
do you fix that so if that if that is
the biggest problem you're selling
number one here's the problem let me
tell you why this is the problem okay
the people like you're right I'm buying
it give us a solution what's the
solution yeah I think the solution comes
back down to family values and that's a
very difficult question to answer
because it's across the entire Spectrum
right I do feel like it's almost a race
to the bottom for men and women now in
the modern society I don't think women
are being very good women I don't think
men are being very good men and I think
both of that is accelerating against
each other and it's a race to the ball
how do you fix that it's difficult it's
hard and I still think one of the
easiest ways to do that is God I think
if you bring back some degree of
Morality In some degree of standard to
both sexes I think things will start to
get better I can tell you right now they
talk about why does men not want to get
married anymore men don't want to get
married anymore they come up with all
these elaborate reasons the main reason
men don't want to get married anymore is
because their girlfriend was with me for
free so why are they going to marry her
that's that's the bottom line of it why
would you a white dress means Virgin
Mary who a girl from the club who your
friends have been with do you want to
marry her like when you remove all of
the morality from life you just end up
at a scenario where the only possible
logical move is to act without morals
Game Theory right we sit there and we
analyze things logically if you're going
to be if all the women you meet are
immoral How Are You Gonna Act well
you've act morally you get wrecked so
how do you act immorally it's a race to
the bottom we have to fix society as a
whole when it comes down to even the
most basic things most basic things like
female Pro obscurity the most basic
things like men sticking up for the last
name the most basic things like men
having to be too honorable and Too Proud
to be out shape or be poor or not take
care of a woman I'm not just talking
about waiting I'm talking about men any
woman who's with me her life is fixed
that is my job I'm Andrew take I would
be embarrassed to have a girl say I'm
Andrew Tate's girlfriend and have to
work a job unless she wanted to
you can do anything she wants she's my
chick you could have anything you run
the world now you're with the top G
anything you want is mine I'll take care
of you in every single way but you must
take care of me I take care of you
financially and physically you must
protect me spiritually you must do your
job it's a race to the bottom on both
sides and when you have two genders
racing to the bottom and then a child is
born what do we expect from this child
who's raising the child the school the
TV the internet you trust these people
look what they're injecting into them so
another thing that's very interesting
you talk about the 1950s another thing
that was different in the 1950s parents
raised their kids who raises kids
nowadays school school internet twitch
how much time do you spend talking to
your child compared to the programming
they get from The Matrix
you're losing your lose terms of pure
minutes you're
right now they do what they did in
California they're like what most people
don't even know this you have children
15 years old I've seen on YouTube
arguing with their own parents
disagreeing with their own parents the
whole point of having children is to
instill your values in them I want my
sons to be Emory Andrew Tate they must
think and act and be like me and for
someone I've had people say to me what
if they're not if they're not they're
not that's fine but the whole point of
me having them was my lineage that's the
whole point of me suffering to raise
them was my lineage why would I raise
them to be anything other than what I
believe I should be and they should be
that's the whole point of it and I'm
proud of that I'm not going to sit and
apologize for wanting my sons to be
tapes I'm not going to apologize for it
I don't care what the school wants them
to believe they believe what I want them
to believe because they are mine
well that's gone so then we also talk
about what's different between the 1950s
and today these kids are being raised by
people who aren't their parents and
whoever's raising them clearly ain't
teaching them anything good it's
teaching them if you feel I tell you
feel you can't tell men that it's
dangerous you can't tell men to act how
they feel you can't tell men to not have
emotional control you can't tell men to
cry anytime they want because men don't
just cry sad they cry angry
they cry very angry you don't want that
you have to teach them stoices you have
to teach them all of these things and
it's all gone so okay so let's stay on
this this is actually a very interesting
topic we're in from 1950s till today so
you're saying uh if somebody is a tate
if somebody is my wife if somebody is my
son you're going to be doing this I'm
not going to let a teacher XYZ okay
well 85 90 America doesn't have the
money to be able to put them in a public
a private school correct where right now
is June if you go on YouTube or Twitter
and look at pride month everywhere kids
are coming to school parents you know
teachers got these uh Pride stuff going
on all over the place parents are like
look I'd love to put them in a private
school but even some private schools are
doing it right now in Florida there is a
private school
it's known one of the best private
schools out there you know which one I'm
talking about I won't mention it starts
with the letter P people should know
what it is but they all know what I'm
talking about
we have a party at our house okay and
baseball my son you know so he's got a
baseball the players are their parents
I'm talking to their parents so hey meet
Wonder Girls so what school do you go to
oh well you know uh I was going to such
and such school but I'm going to such
and such school oh really tell me why
the dad's like yeah it's just you know
reasons he gets uncomfortable yeah I
said no really tell me why I'm curious
why you not only want to get into it I
said are you uncomfortable because it's
political reasons well yes I said well
let's just say you're safe
save you he says am I fully safe I said
what do I need to tell you if we don't
know you're fully safe you're fully safe
with us because you know my position he
says Fair he says we took him out
because they started asking my daughter
to do XYZ with pride to write on this
and she wrote a letter a paper that was
opposing the opinion and she failed the
class because her opinion didn't match
whatever they were saying on phone now I
said what's going on with that private
school that school's 50 Grand year per
kid the one that's grooming 50 grand 50
Grand a year per kid there's an exodus
from this school to go to other schools
so one some parents don't have the
option Andrew to say you and I are not
worried about I'm not worried about it
but the people I'm leading they're
worried about it absolutely how do you
fix it if you're that person without the
resources you got and that's another
thing that's difficult because I have
two answers to this question I have the
The Arrogant answer not the answer that
I think I know the Arrogant one but yeah
both of them the one I actually believe
is helpful this is where I think things
like we discussed earlier like the clan
comes into come effect right imagine you
had 18 kids from six or seven parents
groups of parents and everyone's living
together the family unit the the energy
and the ethos and the the merits of that
particular Clan is going to be so much
stronger and difficult for the Matrix to
penetrate and break their best friends
are the people they live with the kids
live with the other kids who believe the
same as them the parents all agree when
you're a clan you're far more difficult
to attack an assault so I would say the
first thing I would do if I was a parent
of of normal income I would try and find
other parents who agree with me and try
and find other people who are
ideologically sound and I'd make sure
that our our children are friends and
they spend the most time with each other
and I would try for us all to go on
holidays together and I would also put
in conscious effort to try and deprogram
I don't think many parents say to their
kids what did you learn today
I'd be doing that not to check on the
kid I'd be doing the challenge check on
the school but let me challenge you
what's going on sure let's role play go
ahead ask me the question what did you
learn at school today so today we
learned that you know Dylan Mulvaney had
the courage to stand up for her beliefs
and she's uh she's a hero because she's
out there and she's helping a lot of
other people that have gone through
challenging times be able to stand up
for themselves okay I would say why do
you think they want you to believe that
what do you mean that why do you think
they want you to believe that they've
told you something yeah I don't believe
that's true what they've done is lied to
you why do they want you to believe that
perfect so say you now convince me I'm
your son great I go to school tomorrow
ready I'm in school correct hey Miss
Jones says hey Patrick so tell me so
what did you think about this as this
you have to write this paper well let me
tell you last night I was having a
conversation with my Dad yeah and my dad
told me why do you want me to believe
that yeah then comes the phone call and
then now you're cornered as a parent and
now what do you say to the school say
I'm the school role play correct and
this is and I can't roll this by myself
it's difficult it's difficult and this
is the exact point why you the clan
Union
if I was a parent and my child was going
to public school I'd be extremely
interested in finding other parents
whose kids were going to that public
school yeah you have the PTA meetings
Etc but there has to be a degree of
strength in numbers it's hard you can
say homeschooling that's that's the
cop-out but the other answer the more
arrogant answer to this is actually an
answer I gave after the subway incident
you know in New York with the subway
where they choked the guy who died yeah
I get asked all the time Andrew what
would you have done in that scenario
it's a very difficult scenario I mean we
can argue whether he took them too long
whether he was trying to protect people
there's a bunch of arguments but
it's very unfortunate this goes back to
what I was saying earlier you can no
longer just be the the average man the
average citizen I insulate myself from
so many problems with money I know this
is a terrible thing to say and people
aren't going to like hearing it but it's
true I never have to worry about some
garbage on the subway I never have to
worry about do I stand up and defend
this woman or allow her to get attacked
because they're going to put me in jail
I never have to worry about some fight
on a plane because the ticket was forty
dollars I never have to worry about my
kid go and learn something they don't
want to learn I don't have to worry
about any of this because money protects
me right so when I say this like if I
have a girl and she's saying all you do
is work you need to be a dad too I'm
being a dad by being rich that's me
being a dad that's how I protect you all
I'll work 18 hours a day every single
day that's me being a dad more than
almost anything because that's how I
protect you and everybody else from all
this Insanity it's the only way to do it
because you need to be flexible we're
fully on the same page I'm on the same
page as you I also went and made the
money so I get to pick and choose what
I'm talking about is a message because
the reality is not everybody is going to
go out there and make the 10 a month or
whatever it's just not going to happen
correct the Market's not set up that way
not everybody brings that kind of value
to the market correct to Garner that
kind of pay you know that I know correct
okay how can you and I help the audience
that is sitting there great citizens net
positive yep they take their kids to
church on Sundays they work their butts
out they're doing their best to keep
their marriage together as hard as it is
they're paying the bills for the kids
they're making 80 grand 120 household
income they can't talk like you and I
you're right what do they do you're
right let's give them the solution
you're right so if I were them here's
what I would do I would make sure that
my family had core parameters and core
beliefs that we believed in and I would
fact check everything my child was told
against those core parameters and core
beliefs so let's say one of our core
parameters in core release was hard work
we believed in hard work and dedication
when they came home and told me
something about uh body shaming or the
fact that models can change or say does
that agree with the beliefs and the the
merits that this family has decided we
are going to operate under yes or no I
would have a framework I would have a
gate which I ideas have to penetrate
through every idea has to be fact
checked against a gate a parameters of
set values that was stuck to my last
name on our courage discipline hard work
whatever those parameters are and I
would say to my child every day what do
you learn in school I'd listen to it
let's say does that align with our value
on this and also I'd make this very
clear because this was done to me as a
child I'll make it very clear to my
children they're exceptional I think
every single person is exceptional for
different reasons we talk about normal
children normal family instead of that
doesn't mean they're not an exceptional
individual they can still be an
exceptional person who knows who knows
who they might become sure I'd say
you're an exceptional you don't believe
what everyone else in that school is
told to believe just because it is said
you're an exceptional person and we have
a framework we operate under because
your last name is X and our framework is
this does that align with hard work and
dedication no it doesn't why are they
trying to tell you that because they're
trying to attack the framework which you
need to be successful my father said to
me when I was young you were now my
father had many many quotes and I use
them all the time but one of my
favorites was I allow manipulation to
find out where my enemy wants me to go
and then I use my mind to break the trap
and punish the perpetrators that's exact
that's the exact line I will tell my
child I'll say if you're tempted to
manipulate you we've allowed it I
allowed you to go to school and listen
to this why were they trying to
manipulate you where do they want you to
go they want to take you away from
discipline they want to take you away
from hard work now we're going to use
our minds to break the Trap we now know
what they want my father explained this
saying to me and he said why it was so
important and it's true if you don't
allow them to manipulate you at all you
don't know where they want you to end up
you might get tricked another way you
might take another road to the same
destination you allow the manipulation
tell me what you want me to believe tell
me what you want me to understand allow
it to manipulate me all the way to the
end I see the end goal this is what you
want no
and this is what I would teach my
children explain your time in school is
going to teach you some very important
things that you need to know and they're
also attempting to Psy off you and trick
you and poison your mind and we are
going to discuss daily built within our
family framework within the code of our
last name to see which are true and
which are lies it takes work like
everything else on Earth it takes work
and I know it's hard parents are out
there they're working they haven't got
time the kids are on the Internet it's
difficult but you have to put the work
in because you are almost fighting an
enemy for the minds of your children now
you know what I think you know what I
think is that's great
very good feedback but so I lived in
Iran and in Iran you'd go out there and
you'd say so Hey listen people are
asking about religion don't talk about
it yeah are we Christians I don't know
talk to my mom and dad you don't need to
answer the question right because
there's that fear so parents are
teaching kids to not talk about their
values and principles the elements that
parents fear what the school is going to
say to them and not give the kids the
best Grace because imagine you got a
10th grader or even a senior if you
really say what you believe in that
teacher gives you a c you don't get the
a to get the 4.3 GPA to get the
scholarship because you can't afford it
you have to be like constantly like this
or parents are telling their kids look
whatever I'm telling you don't tell them
I think it's I think it's bigger than
that I think the part of it is I think a
part of it is this is the first time we
had stats and I don't know how long this
was where kids no longer
kids graduating high school are not
valuing a four year College as much as
they did before okay that is a threat to
the establishment because they can't be
a control right number two is there is
an element when I'm watching this video
with these parents yesterday in Glendale
and this is where I grew up this is my
street I grew up Broadway in Verdugo
right next to that the post office I'm
200 yards away from the high school is
where I grew up and I lived on a Doran
for a couple years before I went to
Wilson Junior High School and I'm seeing
these parents upset like how is this
this is common sense leave these kids
alone yeah I think there's got to be an
element of those parents coming together
and a form of a strike I believe yeah to
say if you want the tax-funded money
that's being given to your school
district hey we're not coming we're
going to decide to do schooling together
and we're going to use this place or
that place or this facility in that
facility because they have to feel the
pain they cannot do that to the kids so
my only messaging with what you're
saying right now number one rule is what
go start a part-time income make an
additional three grand a month so you
can send them to the private school that
their teaching right values for okay
that's number one two I can't afford to
do that three this is the other option
that you got yeah and you're right and
Trump said it in his book The Art of the
deal
he said if you're not prepared to walk
away you can't negotiate and that's the
same with absolutely everything if you
haven't if there's never a bottom line
in which you say enough then you can't
negotiate you have no negotiating
position we talk about this when it
comes to children in schools but this is
also very applicable for relationships
I've had girls who say to me you know
while I was watching TV and they were
saying that I don't know XYZ
and I would say listen I take care of
you I love you very much I'm going to
make sure you have everything you've
ever wanted I'm gonna make sure you're
physically safe that's why you're not
going to go walking a home alone drunk
it's not because I'm a misogynist it's
not because I dislike you it's not
because I'm controlling it's not because
I'm manipulative it's because it's for
your safety and your safety two degrees
my responsibility but I saw on the news
XYZ if you believe the news over me then
go find another man
you have to be prepared to walk away
right this is the bottom line of it this
is what I personally believe these are
100 with you these are my values and
this is what I personally believe if
you're and if she says well no I'm not
listening to you and I stay with her
anyway well then it's over isn't it and
then she's gonna do whatever she wants
but not everybody can do that because
the the proposition you're offering so
high that they have to sit there and say
I can't lose this guy completely and
this is where we go back to the original
point about how difficult it is to be
the average man now I it's it's becoming
more and more difficult we're in a
position now where you have a race track
and you have Ferraris and Nissans and
yeah we can discuss how the Nissan might
beat the Ferrari but the truth is it's
hard it's very very hard if I was a man
and I was starting all over again I
would be do I would do the same things I
did I would wake up and say okay this
game is extremely difficult my best
chance is to level up my character to a
point where the game becomes easy
because life does become easy at a
certain point yes now I'm in a very
unique situation but before this
situation I had only three problems in
my life my health which I take care of
my woman who I take care of and money
that was it if I made enough money I had
no other problems if you're broke you
have lots of small problems the the car
doesn't start the school fees are coming
up whatever we need new clothes for the
kids I had one problem to fix if I fix
my one issue everything else is fixed
you get to a point in life where someone
goes oh we've got an issue how much
tell me the number I don't even want to
know the ins and outs to do the transfer
make it go away so yeah as a man I think
you have that imperative to understand
that the video game of Life as a man is
exceptionally difficult and especially
as you get older as you progress with
the levels it gets harder it's getting
harder and harder you need to level up
your character this is what amazes me
when men go I struggle with motivation
how how can you struggle with motivation
in the modern world are you asking to
just lose are you asking to just be
erased from Humanity are you asking to
be invisible how can you be an 18 year
old man and say I don't have the
motivation to train as hard as possible
and get as rich as possible you are born
to lose if you don't have motivation to
18. in the modern world as competitive
as it is all those girls those 18 year
old girls who go to school with are
talking to some 28 year old man with a
yacht somehow and you're sitting there
lonely and you don't have motivation
you must be out your mind the only way
to win this game is to become as
powerful as possible it's difficult and
it's getting harder and harder and this
is why I teach the things I teach to men
you can't just be Joe Schmo and win
anymore that those days are over you
have to be something else the challenge
those young men have though it's
sometimes not even their fault why
single mother raised by a single mother
they've been indoctrinated and they
heard the future is female a million
times next thing you know they're 18
they kind of have this victim mentality
it's almost not even their fault some of
these times oh completely we're all in
our late 30s early 40s we we've grown up
I played football in school he's an
athlete bodybuilder obviously you're a
kickboxing champion we've had coaches
we've had people kick our ass we didn't
grow up with participation trophies
we've had our asses kicked we've gone
through [__] now we are the [__] yep a
lot of these young guys playing video
games addicted to porn they grow up with
a phone in their hand raised by women
they don't have they weren't raised how
we were raised how do you teach those
kids though well that's why they don't
want us so exactly what they don't want
me doing that's why they're trying to
put me in jail because I've managed to
become I I'm not for a second bragging
but I've the the size of the movement
that I created
I turned up in Slovenia I don't have you
ever seen that video with the Bugatti
where everyone's going tall that's the
capital of Slovenia I can't even
pronounce it libuana or something I've
never been number four Slovenia where
even is it like I can barely find it on
a map I know roughly where it is if you
want a guaranteed way to get in touch
with me maybe you have a business idea
maybe you want some fashion tips maybe
you just want to connect you could find
me on minute this is what I was saying
earlier on about how complicated
masculinity is but I broke it down to
those three basic tenants because even a
teenage boy can understand if you get
enough money and enough power and enough
powerful friends and enough sexual
access that you're going to be able to
build yourself to a man of I can cry now
I've qualified to cry when you're an 18
year old boy you can't you shouldn't be
crying you should you should be focused
and you should be an animal you should
be training you should be working hard
and you should be listening you should
be going to coaching I'm now at a level
where I'm allowed to cry I understand
all the different elements of being a
man I understand the tapestry of
masculinity fully I can cry if I decide
to I've qualified for that but before
you get to that point you have to go
through all the hard [__] and the
hardship broken down to the three Basics
and I think that's why they're coming to
attack me so heavily because genuinely
because of what you just said I'm
telling kids things and especially
people often ask me especially Matrix
media they say why did you get so big
because I'm telling the truth I'm
telling the truth which every man knows
it true in his heart because God has
instilled him with a basic degree of
morality of right and wrong I'm saying
things to a 17 year old boy and he's
going this is the he makes sense I get
it everything I was told so far just
didn't quite click but this does and
that's what they're so scared of and I
agree with you you're completely right
and this goes back to once again we were
saying about last names Family Values
the number of times I was told I
couldn't do something because of my last
name I think that was my whole childhood
my whole childhood is well you're a tape
dad I got an A of course you're a Tate
it wasn't even it was just like duh of
course you got an A but what else are
you gonna get B what are you a dummy
that's who I was my whole life I had
standards exacted on me and I've even
heard like psychologists I have a big
problem with psychologists I don't like
them as a whole I'll tell you some of my
scenarios I've I've had conversations
with psychologists there's a couple good
ones but there's a lot of them who I
don't like and their ideas are you
raised children don't put standards on
don't put pressure on them how are they
going to perform without pressure
do you have pressure to perform in your
business because I certainly do but
certainly do pressure makes diamonds you
think I didn't have pressure to perform
when I sat down with the BBC and they
tried to set me up you think I didn't
realize instantly okay War
she's ready well you think I think he
has no pressure you think there's no
pressure when they try and stab you to
death there's no pressure in life you're
gonna raise a child and say to give them
no pressure give them no standards so we
can just be a kid and what's he gonna
mold into
absolutely not really at all life is
pressure especially as a man you need to
have these exacting standards that's how
it is my whole life was a pressure to
perform to my last name that's all it's
always ever been I don't know how
anyone's raised any other way
so yeah it's crazy it's a very difficult
problem to fix I agree with you it's a
very difficult problem to fix but I
think it starts with Baseline things and
this is also why I feel like I have such
a duty to act
I'll give you an example
if I could lie right now for 10 million
dollars and nobody would find out nobody
I still couldn't do it because God would
know and he'd punish me sooner or later
I really truly believe that I would pay
the price of that life I truly believe
it I think when you're if you're a man
and you're growing up and you're saying
how do I act what do I do in this
scenario what would God want you to do
tell the truth you'd be amazed how far
just telling the truth will get you in
any situation I can give you benign
situations that don't even matter your
girlfriend called you oh no and I barely
know her daughter just say yes sorry I
love you I'd love to stay together
well you did this sorry
I'm leaving okay goodbye
next day she's back
it could have gone on for weeks she
could have kept spying she could have
called the girl all this drama just
sometimes in life you just man up and
tell the truth that's why in my current
scenario when I was saying earlier
yeah completely truth shall set you free
it shall set you free when I was saying
earlier the incompetence of my enemies
is scaring me and I don't know exactly
what to do all I can do is just tell the
truth all the time I'm gonna tell the
truth all the time I'm gonna say what I
mean and mean what I say and I'm gonna
tell the truth and that's who I'm gonna
be that's what I think is the best thing
for me to do in the current scenario
but we're not even instilling that in
children anymore we're not even telling
children how important is to not lie
well but but that's that's also part of
what you're talking about I want to show
you the stats because the guy sent it to
me and then we'll put this for the
audience to see as well percentage of
gun ownership from 1972 till today same
thing exactly if you look at the numbers
pretty much the same thing so what's
been the biggest difference is a lot of
these things that we just talked about
by the way that question you asked from
1950 till today
talking about this again I went up and
went back to politics RFK is talking
about this and I think it's a very
important thing to talk about because
it's making people go research and see
for themselves and to ask the question
what really did change we've had this
all the time completely what became
legal why are we adding all this
Pharmaceuticals to you know kids to take
yeah what what else would it be outside
of that so that that was the foundation
which I agree with you household values
principles kids men raising them better
what else would you see as a challenge
from an outside and then I got part two
of the question for you
yeah it's it's anything else where you
say you know XYZ would also by the way I
love the way you say Nissan and status I
just love the way you pronounce those
different words man for a second he said
Nissan I'm like what is Nissan and then
I realize what you're talking about well
I remember when I was young
other people's parents would tell me off
do you remember that did you ever get
that when you were young of course other
people's parents you come up and like
you better not random adults would just
tell me off I was scared of every
grown-up every grown-up had a degree of
authority just random animals who can't
do that anymore there was just a degree
of community that's certainly not really
lost and
asking me how to bring it back is
difficult it's very hard and that's one
of the reasons why I become so religious
recently because I think that God is
definitely part of that and that's also
the reason I want to live in the clan I
live in that's why it is my brother can
tell my kids off no problem if I came
home and Tristan's like I I just scream
at all I'll be like good I trust him in
his judgment good screaming him then
good for children also sometimes you
know what kids need to be yelled at
sometimes why not yell at them what
they're gonna do life's hard life's hard
the way we Pander and baby children
especially is is is insane I was talking
about this the other day I was talking
about how I have a pet peeve and one of
my pet peeves is painkillers and I was
being typical me and I was going over
the top
but I was saying I was arguing not
arguing I was discussing with this guy
this guy said have you got any aspirin I
said there's no aspirin in my house
and he said why I said brother
you are not facing one percent of the
life difficulties I am facing think
about it no government's trying to lock
you up the Matrix isn't after you
they're not trying to frame you nobody
wants you dead when God finally gives
you a tiny headache to give you
something to show your half a man a
little bit of resilience your [__] out
and take an aspirin can you just have a
headache just have a headache and not
only just have a headache have a
headache and don't mention it because I
don't care so don't even talk about it
nobody needs to know just have a
headache I have a headache Twitter yeah
what do you want you want therapy you
want sympathy nobody cares you have a
headache shut up
it kind of goes back into my original
conversation when I was saying I don't
like psychotherapists and all their
garbage because they're constantly I
don't believe in
I've had conversations with therapists a
few times and my biggest detractors and
enemies say you need to talk to a
therapist
the last conversation I had with a
therapist didn't go very well
I said I didn't believe in uh most of
their field and that was garbage
and she said why and I said because
there are some boys who don't drink
alcohol because their dad was an
alcoholic and there are some boys who
are alcoholics because their dad was an
alcoholic you have the same scenario and
different outcomes so I don't believe in
it she said well no it's not an exact
science but we have generalized rules
that we can follow that lead to patterns
of behavior I said but I'm not a
generalized person
I'm an exceptional person so everything
you've learned and everyone you've ever
spoken to and everything in your books
does not apply to me because I am
exceptional and I'm smarter than you and
I've done things you could never do and
I'm a world champion athlete and I'm
Richard you'll ever be so nothing you
know can a possibly apply to my my
mindset so why are we sitting here
talking what was the reaction she just
wrote things down on a piece of paper
probably called me an arrogant piece of
[__] but he said he don't like this guy
complete narcissist
who knows what's going on
yeah there's nothing you've learned in
your book that applies to people it
doesn't apply to me doesn't apply to me
so I don't want to hear it don't care
don't care and and this whole idea this
goes back to the thing about uh
painkillers that's something I didn't
just make up that's from my dad I
remember being at my friend's house and
I remember him saying I need an aspirin
and he had an aspirin I remember just
being a child and coming home and saying
I want to ask but I remember my dad
going for what
you're a kid shut up no you're not
popping pills and I remember my mother
going it's not even ask me no there's
nothing wrong with you your body is is
going to go through the same damage it's
suffering if any at all whether you feel
the pain or not man up get over it it
comes down to the details it's like if
you're a professional fighter and you
get to a certain level your coach once
you've been training for 10 years your
coach is honing you on the details it's
the tiniest details that make you a
predator the tiny things Mayweather does
one percent better than the guy he beats
it's the tiny details so simple things
like denying a child a painkiller when
you know there's nothing wrong with them
I'm not saying to be at surgery you
can't have painkillers I'm saying he
walks in there's nothing actually wrong
with the kids say no it's all the tiny
little things you need to do to instill
paint you need to instill that
resilience inside of them I was in jail
and I could just hear crying and sobbing
from every cell but mine everyone's in
there having a mental breakdown but me
and the most the scariest thing about my
position position and I think it's the
position for most people who end up in
jail in Romania because of how the legal
system works and the extensions you
don't know how long you're in there for
you don't know it could be a year could
be five could be three days that's what
messes with your brain you're like do I
prepare for six months of this do I
prepare for five years of this what's
going on nobody knows everyone's in
there having mental breakdowns but me
why did I not have a mental breakdown
because I've had too much crap happen to
me too many times and never took the
painkiller never took the easy way out
never asked who the therapist never been
a [__] about it this is how life works
there's no way to the top besides the
difficulty and the pain and the trauma I
say I I I I'm really flabbergasted that
there's men out here who still believe
they're going to somehow become
something of importance without it of
course she broke her heart good good
good
good I'm tired of people complaining and
crying about it that's the game that's
the life so yeah it comes down to Tiny
things even down to painkillers smallest
things
my dad used to another thing my dad used
to maybe do
he uses make me drink water I remember
being a kid it would upset me I'll be
sitting there playing chess whatever
you'd say go drink two liters of water
and I'd go and I'd get some water and
I'd start drinking and say I'm not
thirsty I don't want to drink the rest I
need to stand there and make me drink
all two liters now I understand it was
just compliance
two liters of water is not gonna hurt me
it's not gonna hurt me do I really need
it who knows a drunk Elite or why do I
have to drink all too because he said so
that was the household if I was if I
tried to rebel I really don't want to
I'm not thirsty you're gonna drink that
water that's that's it and it's all
these tiny things that instill
discipline in you over a long enough
time frame drink water yes sir bring
that to compliance today though giving
that to compliance today say your dad is
uh around today and you're 12 years old
and you're living in Ohio okay and your
dad is teaching you compliance yep and
your dad says okay so now teacher in
school tells you what to do he's right
he's this he's dad what is the uh angle
you're taking at that time yeah and
that's another thing that's difficult
because back then it was much easier to
say you shouldn't get in trouble at
school right much easier today's kind of
like a badge of honor almost almost
stand up almost and and it is hard but
my loyalty was always to my last name
above anything else this just depends
where your loyalty lies I think that
everyone when we talk about we can link
back into religion and talk about
atheists I don't think there's such
thing as an atheist nowadays I think
everyone has a religion if you're not
religious to God you're religious to
either this woke agenda or you're
religious to a political party or you're
religious to some kind of perversion
everyone's religious to something you
have to decide what is you're most loyal
to above everything you have to put this
thing in hierarchical order and our last
in our last talk I said to I said this a
lot of people hold beliefs and they
don't know where they got them from or
why they hold them they they there's
people walking around who believe things
and they don't know where it came from
or why they so strongly believe it they
don't even have any personal experience
to link it to
you truly believe two plus two is five
why oh because it just is and the news
and the new no no what happened to you
that made you believe nothing's even
happened to you and you believe this
with your complete core you've been
psyopt
I I know where my loyalties lie I've had
them in order I know who who I put who I
put above others I absolutely not really
know and sometimes in the most harsh
situations on Earth there's going to be
scenarios in life which are completely
and utterly they're unexpected and
they're exceptionally rare where you
have to make very difficult choices but
I know my my hierarchy I know I know if
I was in a position a hypothetical where
I had to choose between my brother or my
girl I there wouldn't be a oops what do
I do I know the choice it's never been
the case between the two of you it's
never been the case students yet but if
it happened I know it would be I've had
girls say I I've had girls try and give
me the line I've had girls do it I've
had girls say if you live with your
brother then it's gonna be it's not what
I'm asking what I'm asking is has a girl
ever come in between you guys since you
were kids never never it's impossible
that's because of the value taught down
completely it's absolutely it's
absolutely impossible so the hierarchy
of compliance and respect at that time
last name was first yeah where would it
be today if you're racing kids today
what is number one is it God it is is it
me second then then whom no it is God
it's God first and then it's the last
name in The Legacy in my teachings think
it has to be gold first I think it has
to be gold first because God is the only
thing that can resist this Insanity what
is happening is truly evil this is not
some different worldview no it is evil
because it is dishonest anything that is
dishonest must be evil it is a lie all
of it is a lie it is constructed
deliberately to be a lie it's
deliberately constructed to alter the
minds of people to believe in lies is
evil so it has to be God first because
God is truth and I believe if I have
children who put God first and then put
respect for the last name and the things
I've taught them second it's very hard
to corrupt them how are you going to
truly corrupt these people it's going to
be very difficult and that's what I
always try and do and that's how I was
raised I I was raised in a Christian
family I was actually raised religiously
then I thought I was smart when I became
atheistic
because yeah there's a lot wrong with
the world and obviously I've already
apologized for that and understand I was
completely wrong but respect for my last
name even to this day still there and
and that's why
I say to my girlfriend if we were
walking down the street and 10 men have
approached the machets I just have to
die I can't be Andrew Tate ran away
that's the bottom line if you're living
in this clan right you're living here
your family Tristan's family you're
raising your family Muslim Islam yep
your brother's still Christian yep how's
that going to work well there's one
God's first there's one God there's I
truly believe there's different paths to
God I truly believe that
like I said I'm not a religious scholar
but it says in the Quran people of the
book even even a Muslim man I'm allowed
to marry a Christian woman they are of
the book it's only atheists that the
Quran has a problem with because there's
something morally corrupt with them but
if you're a person of the book a person
of faith
we don't we're not even even says aside
the Quran we're not supposed to convert
you or insult you we're not here to
insult you or correct you there's one
path there's different paths to the one
God I truly believe that and also
another thing I'll say about Clan living
in my experience I think that men quite
often get along in those scenarios if
anyone is hearing the idea of this and
love the idea of this but they feel like
it would be argumentative or to be
problems I think that comes from the
women I think it's when women don't like
each other or the woman's in the man's
ear you're too bad with the guys that I
think the women are more
against it than the men for some reason
unless you have a very strong frame in
the relationship I don't have that
problem but in general the men get along
the men love it I think I think it's
quite firm and quite and quite uh
rigidly installed inside of the basic
psyche of men we like that men feel best
in a gang in a group it's why we charge
at the gunfire when we're with our boys
is when we feel strongest that's why we
go out and drink and party when you're
with your guys there's something inside
you you just feel like on fire I think
men have that a lot of the time it
doesn't seem to work and it breaks down
because women can be unhappy in certain
scenarios but this is why especially in
in some ethnic communities where the
gender roles are more specific and
defined where the man is in charge and
the woman does this they can live all
live together in peace it's much easier
for them like I said I grew up in a town
full of Muslims they'd have 10 families
in one house women cooked cleaned look
after the children looked after their
man the men all worked made a bunch of
money
a bunch of average ass jobs and they're
all millionaires in five to six years
let me ask this other question while
we're on this topic uh that was a good
question by the way Christian Dynamic
and Muslim Dynamic when you're saying
there's a lot of ways to get there you
know there's a religion called Baha'i
it's an element of Christian Muslim
Baha'i is like how Mormonism to
Christianity and by believes there's
eight ways to go to heaven that's the
philosophy of Baha'i my sister husband's
family they're all Baha'i great people
but going back to this okay impact let's
think impact if a person's watching this
content
most of the people that are watching us
a portion is going to be those that are
haters that just want to find like poke
at the argument to find you see I told
you see I told you fine but a lot of
people that are also watching this
they're probably wanting to make impact
they want their life to have meaning
behind it that's who's watching this
show today right okay so I can't be a
president but I want to make impact I'd
be in anybody that's watching this
because Putin says eight years another
another guy comes with a guy with the
briefcase shows up okay cool well if you
were in the states and you're saying
president wouldn't be how to make an
impact but let's say there is a kid
who's 20 years old 18 years old 25 years
old has so much drive it's unbelievable
ambition at the highest level
who do you think has the biggest
influence to make positive change like
real change is it the person with the
money is it the person with the biggest
mic is it the person that goes into
politics what is the best way to have
the biggest impact yeah so I think the
world has always only ever been a battle
for influence
even if you look at the current
Battlefield Ukraine is next door it's
five hours drive away the battle in
Ukraine is not just about tanks and
trenches and grenades it's a battle for
influence who influences the people
within this territory who is in charge
of the thinking the language the mindset
of people within this geographical area
every single battle every single pitch
battle every single argument every
single debate has always been a battle
for influence if you have influence
you're an extremely powerful person all
of us here are some of those powerful
people in the world how many millions of
people listen to us we have massive
influence and I think you can have
influence at the ground level you don't
have to be a famous podcaster or
famously well known to have influence I
would argue that those Romanian grandmas
who gave me my food will remember me for
the rest of their lives I would like to
believe I gave a positive influence and
a positive impact on their lives for the
rest of their life I believe if you go
through life and you're genuinely a good
person you try your best to be good to
people and you're honest and you shake
hands and you don't lie and you're on
time and you work hard and you're good
to everyone who's good to you I think
you'll have a massive influence and I
also believe I truly believe that God is
extremely giving
there's a saying goes around comes
around completely true but I would say
it comes from God God is keeping an eye
on you and he's paying attention to you
and he knows the kind of person you are
and the kind of things you do and I
don't believe if you're actually
genuinely a good person all of the time
that you're not going to get some good
will back to you look at my scenario if
I was being a piece of [__] for years
with all these chicks I'd be in jail
I'll be in jail I could have never seen
this coming but the fact I was nice paid
their taxi home bought them food looked
after them are you okay I know we broke
up I'm sorry I know it hurts I just did
it I was nice about all of it here I am
I'm fine so I could have never seen this
Matrix attack coming it's amazing how
what goes around comes around it's truly
amazing if you're good to people if
you're generous to people if you're
helpful to people you'd be amazed how
much influence you can build up I say
this to people all the time I don't
think if you're a hard-working person
who is honest who shakes hands who tries
to learn who does what they're supposed
to do who has a good heart that you're
truly really not going to be able to get
what you want
I think the universe is absolutely not
really giving when I see somebody who
says they want something and they don't
have it I don't even think they truly
even want it
you could have anything you want in the
world when a guy goes I want a six-pack
then I ain't got one if you want it you
have it you'd like it there's a bunch of
things I'd like that I don't have but I
don't want them everything I've ever
wanted I've got I've never wanted
something and not had it we all know
what we're talking about here there's
things we'd like I'd like to be able to
figure skate not enough to go learn to
figure skate
it's a weird look if you figure out
although that other guy dancing like the
way your dance is doing a pretty good
you've seen this guy you can figure
skate that guy kills the dancer yeah
he's good but your doppelganger but if
you truly want something you're gonna
absolutely not really have it so when it
comes down to influence I think you
started at the base level at the
Grassroots level what if I what if this
guy's got like you know
for example like you know how
um when you were 20 yeah were you this
driven oh absolutely okay so when you're
20 who did you look at and say I can do
it as good as Sin if not better my coach
because I wanted to fight and he used to
he used to beat me badly everyone used
to beat me up when I was young and I
wanted to be the best so I used to go
into the fight okay how about
communication who'd you look at were you
always a good Community I can see you
being a great communicator since you
were 14 years old my pretty I was pretty
good yeah okay who did you look at and
say that guy's good but I think I can
you know do it better that's a good
question
and I think that
you know what I'm asking I know what
you're asking I don't know if there's
one particular person I took nuances
from because when you're a great
communicator you know how to be serious
and you know how to make people sad and
angry and you also know how do people
make people laugh there's different
people who can do lots of different
things was it somebody that was
multifaceted like that I I think it was
a lot of different people and I also
think that the Japan comedy as well or
certainly did but I was also extremely
self-critical I think that's where a lot
of it came comes from I'll watch I'll
watch this podcast back 15 times
I will notice every single time I made a
mistake just then I said I'll watch
twice that was a mistake I will watch
this back 15 times and I'll identify
every single error
I have a email list and I sign up and I
get words of the day I get five or six
new words a day which I try my very best
to memorize it's harder you think to
memorize five words a day but I always
try to make sure I have the most
interesting vernacular I can possibly
have a wide vocabulary is going to be
very specific with my points the reason
I actually did that my I keep talking
about my dad but he taught I'm his son I
have the same name Henry Andrew take the
third he was undertake II my father was
a linguist
the CIA he spoke Russian and German and
Spanish and English
and uh I think I've told this before
back then when they needed somebody
spoke Russian they would take a Native
American teach them Russian nowadays we
have a bunch of russian-speaking allies
you can go to Estonia Latvia Lithuania
they're all NATO and just get a Russian
speaker back then they taught my dad
Russian and he held the Air Force record
for the fastest assimilation of a
foreign language when he died a guy sent
me an email sent me a message saying you
don't know who I am but I worked with
your father in the Air Force and he had
the fastest assimilation he learned
Russian in two weeks crazy and I
remember saying to my dad will you teach
me Russian he said boy you don't even
know English
so what do you mean he goes you don't
even know English and and once he sat me
down with a dictionary I was like you're
right I don't even know English that's
why even I've lived in Romania seven
years people say why don't you speak
Romanian because I don't know English
yet
I need to finish the first job before I
learned the second I don't know English
it's a bunch of words I don't know I
can't speak how he spoke so I don't have
time for a second language yeah also
another thing I found really interesting
Putin speaks English have you ever heard
him speak English no because you want to
speak to put when you speak to him in
his language you speak to me in Russian
and I reply to you in Russian too I
cannot be misunderstood or misconstrued
I don't make a fool of myself you can't
get me on some vernacular trick I speak
my language and I also prefer that also
I speak English that's what I speak if
you want to speak to me you speak to me
in my language so I will win the debate
always who'd you look up to outside of
your dad
I look up to lots of people I'm talking
specifically Young Rich not today I'm
talking 16 20 25 that that age
not today
it's Jim because I always believed in
trying to take the best parts of
individual people and then amalgamate
them and I know you want a name and I
can't think of one off the top of my
head but I would look at people who I
didn't even respect but they'd have one
particular thing about them I thought
that's good it could be somebody didn't
even like but you dressed well I think
you just have to be perspicacious and
look at people and there's something you
can learn from absolutely everybody and
just try and adapt it all I'm not saying
everybody should be clones to me for
everyone's individual right but there
might be some things about me they find
inspiring that they may adapt and take
on board and then they'll find some
things from other people
but learning to speak is something I
very
well I understood from a very young age
how important that would be that's a
superpower okay so let me go back to the
question I was asking where I'm trying
to go with this so I asked the question
I said imagine the 20 year old that's
watching this that's saying no Tate
don't give me the answer for I can
anybody can create you know can't
contribute to society I'm not that guy
talk to me like I'm one in a million
talk to me like I'm one cool so if I'm
willing to give yeah 20 years 30 years
of my life to one way to go up to make
true positive impact in America my
country in the world yep what what
should don't talk to me like everybody
else I understand what should I do okay
so first things first you need to be
worthy of respect and you're gonna be
worthy of respect through having things
which are difficult to acquire so first
things first the basic things you need
to be very focused on trying to make
money because people listen to you when
you have money they just do secondly you
need to be in fantastic physical
condition because when you're in
fantastic physical condition it cannot
be bought it must be earned and people
know that when you're in I mean I don't
know about you
if someone walked in to sell me
something and they were obese I would
not trust them the same as if they're in
fantastic physical shape because I'd say
I don't think you have dedication and
heart I don't think there's something
about you that I just wouldn't trust you
the same so fantastic physical condition
and money is is the first thing the
second thing whatever your ideas are you
need to learn how to communicate them
speaking is a superpower in and of
itself you need to become a fantastic
Communicator you need to be comfortable
in all Realms of communication you need
to be persuasive you need to be
comfortable arguing you'd be good at
debating there's a lot of people out
there in the world who have ideas that
they can't even project into somebody
else's mind how are you gonna how are
you gonna rule the world with that how
are you going to get your ideas out
there make it influence if you can't
make other people understand exactly
what you think that's the first thing
second thing once they understand
exactly what you think you need to make
them agree with what you think these are
two different skills must be practice it
must be learned if you're 20 years old
and you want to change the world you
need to be having endless debates
endless without resorting to name
calling not on Twitter like a dummy in
person and you need to come across in a
way that people agree with you we can go
back quickly and talk about the red pill
the difference between me when I talk to
girls on these panel shows and every
other guy when they talk to girls in
these panel shows is when I'm done all
the girls want me
watch them watch the shows I say the
same thing and by the end the chicks are
in love with me as opposed to saying the
same thing in the chicks to come a
[__]
that's the difference I project my ideas
and I make them agree with my ideas to a
point where they're like
texted me afterwards I'm not saying
anything different is how I'm
communicating it
something so you can catch more flies
with honey
than hurting people sometimes you need
to be good at everything you need to
have a Swiss army knife of tools I know
when to be intimidating or aggressive I
know when to come across as obtuse I
know when to come across as
exceptionally open-minded and easy to
understand I know when to come across as
understanding I know all these things
this all has to be practiced and a lot
of it is yeah communication I would say
if you're going to say to a 20 year old
who's truly exceptional and driven I'd
say you need to become a master
Communicator because once you can do
that you can do anything and that fixes
all the other problems right we talk
about making money if you're a master
Communicator you do fantastic in sales
you'll kill sales you'll absolutely
destroy sales if you're a master
communicator
not many people know that spices sell
windows
you know the old school knock on the
door window sales I did window sales for
two or three years and I'd say this is
one of the hardest jobs you could
possibly do and I would always recommend
a young man if he has some time to waste
to go sell windows and the reason it's
fantastic because I'll tell you why it's
the hardest one to sell because one
nobody wants them
two They Don't Know Who You Are
you are three even
then they go to all your competitors and
then becomes a price point it's a
nightmare it's the hardest sales job if
you're selling a Lambo at least they
want the lambo right nobody wants glass
and plastic they already have Windows so
you gotta find a way to sell them these
windows how do you do that and that's
where all this master communication
comes in and it's so many subtle little
things being a good salesman is not
necessarily being a liar it's not being
a trickster it's just understanding
what's going to make the person believe
and understand what you say if I walked
in and said would you like new windows
and they essentially said no we don't
need new windows our Windows look fine I
would say but what about the security
aspect while looking at their
three-year-old child
and they'd sit there and go ah what do
you mean security aspect and then I talk
about how we had the lock 5000 and their
locks are easy to break as if glasses
and glass is all the same anyway and
you'd end up selling the windows you
have to find the triggers in people
there's another thing people don't
understand about me my message sometimes
I sit here and I say things that piss
people off because that's how you
trigger people to make action I have
often written emails or done videos to
especially to men when I want to help
men to piss them off
you're a loser you're a dumbass Andrew
why you mean because you're not gonna go
to the gym unless I tell you you're a
[__] loser and you are a loser and
I'm not lying to you you are a loser the
emotional trigger you need to get up off
that chair is the fact that you're not
important nobody cares who you are any
girl you're ever in love with I could
take and you're insignificant and when
you die nobody's interested that's your
fault you could have been something else
you did that you failed
that has to be done you have to be a
master communicator and sometimes that
involves also insulting people
it's all a massive tapestry But to
answer your question for the 20 year old
he needs to become a master at
communicating but also to be a master of
communicating to be a master
communicating you also you also need
experiences worth talking about you have
to live a life you need a degree of
wisdom and wisdom doesn't always come
with age it comes with life lived
I had a guy message me
this is a long time ago when I used to
reply to my own emails too big now
but he said I don't have any stories my
life's boring I said bro where do you
live he said Madrid
I said bro ride the train from Madrid to
St Petersburg ride the train from Madrid
to Vladivostok to the Trans-Siberian
Railway cost you like 300 bucks it was
all but what if I get robbed exactly
that's exactly the point what if you get
robbed now you have a story maybe you'll
die maybe you won't but you have a story
don't bring your watch if you've got a
Rolex no no one wants to rub you anyway
don't worry about it you're broken get
on the train
there has to be that degree of risk to
even have a story because when you have
a story then you can communicate the
story
a lot you can't be an empty vessel
either so when you say to you're telling
me how I build this 20 year old into a
super soldier yeah he has to be a master
communicator but he also has to do
things which are risky risk has value
intrinsically linked to it intrinsically
this is why people when you do risky
things people want to hear the story
your coolest stories involve risk
something went wrong this could have
happened I almost this I made it out
without these risks you haven't got it
so I would say 20 year old do what I did
get in the cage
get in the ring knock someone out get
knocked out train hard fighting will
teach you everything you need to know
about life you'll learn everything about
who you truly are you learn if you're a
coward or not you learn everything about
perseverance and hard work and
dedication everything about being
underappreciated you learn everything
about fear you learn all of it you learn
everything about people you win a fight
check your phone lose a fight check your
phone you learn all about people you
learn all about them
learn all about women I learned so much
about women through fighting when I had
a fight coming up and I was I was weight
drained and I had barely eaten in weeks
and I'd lost all this weight and I had a
world title fight and I'm fighting a guy
who might kill me and she's complaining
about the toilet seat I learned all
about women and you learn a lot about
life through these difficult processes
and paths and there used to be for men
like a rite of passage in most societies
you had to go through something to
become a man from a boy to a man but
that thing was always difficult it's
always been difficult now you have to
self-induce it self-inflicted but if
you're gonna be a boy and never do never
bring on that self-inflicted right of
passage how are you gonna never become a
man that's great feedback let me ask a
question about this I love what you said
uh especially number one you're a word
Smith you're a linguist no doubt I mean
I don't know English yet bro yeah we're
still working on here
you know you've got you've got the
kickboxing belts all up over here I
would I would argue I've never seen you
fight but I would argue that your
linguistic skills are better than your
fighting skills I'll let you judge I'll
take that I totally agree with you the
way that you speak to a man is way
different than the way you talk to a
woman yeah you can tell a guy you're a
loser get your fat ass in the gym and a
guy would be receptive to that
so
I can't tell you how many men come up to
me come up to Pat dude
what was entertain like what was taking
like tell me about today tell me a tate
story dude that guy's so cool it's just
a badass my neck is an application which
allows you to take a minute to connect
with influencers from all around the
world my name is Andrew Tate and I'm
available to speak directly to you on
minute I'm no longer interested in just
random chicks I want a woman who I know
would wait for me if I did 10 years
that's what I want that's what I find
interesting that's what I'm in love with
now I can't be in love with a random
chick also once you get to a certain
level of Fame and influence you're no
longer winning the exchange I feel like
a lot of men like going out there and
pulling girls because they feel like
they won haha look at this hot girl I
got
because if I go to the club and get hot
girl oh okay me the thing
who who who who who pulled it off she
did she'll brag or rat or kiss and tell
or ask for handbag like she what did I
win sex who cares it's not interesting
to me I don't want a child with her I
don't want families I don't want future
with her so why do I even want her at
all I'm not I'm really beyond all of
that stuff so now
it's kind of funny in jail I got
thousands of love letters and women
thousands I got thousands of Love
Letters From women in jail Chewie them
all I read every single one yeah I mean
you have time you went through all of
them all of them got it thousands of the
craziest letter you got what's the
craziest letter you got a lot of poems
uh one had drops of blood on it
she did a little cut
uh lots and lots of love letters Lots
just saying I'm the last man they've
been loving me they've watched all my
podcasts and they were with one of them
said she was with her ex-boyfriend he
started watching me then she started
watching me then she wanted me not him
and got rid of him and all this
craziness but I didn't trust any of it
is it real is it an agent is it who's
she is she crazy what if I sleep with
her and she says I did something to her
what if 13 years later she contacts the
BBC
garbage I I would never happen I don't I
don't talk to any new chicks same as I
don't have any new friends I don't talk
to any new chicks that's what I thought
zero so so let me let me ask you the
idea of going through a lot of girls
when you're younger do you think a man
needs to go through that or do you think
that is a form of a weakness that holds
you that you're a slave to it right so
that's a good question and it's a fine
line because there's arguments on both
sides however I think in all scenarios
and life experiences always going to be
valuable no matter what it is you need
to have experience if you're
inexperienced to anything whether it's
hunting figure skating girls you're
going to suffer you pointed at them
you're saying like insinuating sorry I
know we just he told me figure skating
and we made fun of it earlier but I was
technically Patrick oh sorry we're
talking figure skating
you need experience and experience is
exceptionally important also as a man
especially when you're younger you get
heartbroken a bunch of times some some
bigger older richer dudes can take that
chick and you need to get you need to
get used to that pain so so you need to
get through it so I do think it's a
necessary part of being a man but you
don't want to be led by it there has to
become a point where you go you know
what I'm versed enough and also another
thing I would like to say is the reason
you need to sleep with not sleep with
but date lots of women when you're
younger so you have choices which Define
the two yeah which is more important
date or sleep in your eyes I feel like
you don't really I I think that sleeping
with a woman you learn more about them
is a closer relationship so I'd say
probably sleep with x amount not crazy
amounts but I would say that okay let me
give an example if I go to the
supermarket and pick up an apple and
it's the only Apple I've ever eaten
can I really save it to good apple or a
bad apple
it's the only Apple I've ever tasted it
might be sour it might be terrible I
don't know because if I could try 10
apples I can tell the differences
between Apples I say what's a good apple
what's a bad apple I think you need that
degree of experience because sometimes
you'll be with a woman and go yeah she's
great but if you're not experienced
enough you'll realize she really isn't
all that great she actually treats you
like a [__] whereas if you've been
with enough women you can always
reference back to that girl who actually
was really good to you and and you'll
probably mess it up because you're young
and you're dumb we've all done it all of
us have that girl we had when who was
perfect When We Were Young and we all
ruined it because we're stupid but a
person for you yeah but no no not names
I'm not asking for a name but but I have
mine as well yeah but I'm like you know
I feel like when I watch you and you're
going through your your
for example so
I don't know what kind of movies you
like yep but there's movies where it's
redemption or Vengeance like I don't
know if you watch glad you're the 43rd
minute he walks up to the house sees his
wife sees his kids he's like oh my God
yeah I'm gonna tear you apart right and
you watch that over and over again or
taken or Man on Fire or some of these
movies that are just putting that energy
in you right
so girl that breaks your heart and to
produce the energy to say watch who I'm
gonna be in life for the rest of your
life you're going to brag about the fact
that you could have had me right and
then comes to a point where you're like
okay there's not much more I can do to
she's already knows what you missed out
on now what but for me go back to you
I'm curious how bad of a breakup was it
how bad did she break your heart yeah
and I know you're yeah I think lots of
men have gone through heartbreak a lot
of men have and I wouldn't say that I've
gone through any heartbreak which is
particularly worse than any other guy
what I will say is that I think
heartbreak is the most fantastic
motivator on the planet when a lot of
men messaged me and say they're
heartbroken I think that is the most
fantastic mindset to be in to achieve
things because there is that degree of
Revenge and there is that degree of
Vengeance and that can only be achieved
because through being so successful so
monumentally important that she can't
forgive you and also you cannot even
sleep you can't even concentrate like
your whole mind's a mess that's the
perfect time to train I I know what
you're saying I don't think I've been
through a particularly bad heartbreak
but I'm saying that who did she leave
you for did she leave you for somebody
where no I don't think I don't think
I've I've had a particularly bad
heartbreak I only mentioned heartbreak
all the time because I know it's a path
every single young man goes I also think
you're not a type of guy that would ever
give credit to that person if there was
one so I don't see you saying that
because it is a form of a victory over
top G which that's not going to happen
well that's part of it but then let's
let's analyze now right any there's no
girl who I've ever been with in my life
who can now turn on the internet without
seeing my face sure
isn't that beautiful
they have to all lie to their man and
pretend they don't know me I don't I
don't know him because the thing I was
with him for a few years their whole
relationship will probably break down
because then he's getting pissed off and
insecure so that that to a degree is a
victory
um that's kind of fun but no I wouldn't
I didn't have it the reason I say
heartbreak is because
in the modern world I don't think things
were as bad when I was younger I don't I
think women were more pure when I was
younger even in these when I was 20 it's
only 16 short years I think women were
actually a lot purer before only fans
before Instagram the sexual Marketplace
wasn't globalized when I was 20 if there
was a hot girl in the small town she was
the hot girl in the small town now she's
the hot girl in the small town she's
also in Dubai in courcheval and the
whole world's globalized the
competition's globalized Everything's
changed I didn't have a particularly
hard time the reason I say heartbreak is
because 80 of the emails I get from men
are about heartbreak
I think that most men especially young
men in the world today are getting their
hearts broken and when you're saying who
are they leaving for they're leaving for
the millionaire who hits them up on
Instagram it's hard is that what
happened to you that's not what happened
to me no okay but but I'm talking about
the emails I get you're a guy you're in
Nebraska a high school sweetheart she's
a 10 everything's fine she's in court of
all with a millionaire Instagram
I'm trying to Target you purely for one
reason yeah because a big part of my
drive I've had Drive always I was a
dreamer I was the guy that was you know
but at the same time the drive for
Success came after a lot of pain of
course coming right afterwards so that's
why I'm asking you a question so when
that happened to you did you fear risk
of loving somebody was kind of like I'll
get this close from home I got to move
on no no no I gotta move on did that
happen or no no I wouldn't say that
particularly happened what would what
did happen though like I said earlier is
when you have experience with lots of
different apples you know what a good
one and a bad one is so when we said we
all have that girl we messed up when we
were young if I found another girl with
those qualities I certainly wouldn't
mess it up you just need you need
experience to understand what you have
to Value it if you don't have experience
you don't value what you have so the
original question is a really good one
of whether men are are chained and
enslaved by their desires or whether
they need to sleep with lots of women I
think in the modern world you need
experience and you need choices and you
need options but if you live by the
sword you die by the sword if you're
going to be the guy who's also out there
in the club and sleeping with lots of
girls talking to lots of girls there's
gonna be time to lose a girl that you
don't want to lose
you can't be a coward about it you live
by the sword you die by the sword
there's up and down there's rain and
sunshine you have to be that man who's
going to go through it all and then when
you've been through enough of it yeah
like I have like I said if I find a
beautiful girl now who's a 10 and
deletes and doesn't want Instagram
that's worth more to me than a thousand
stupid girls but yeah that's who I want
I got you for my safety
for everything you're clear on what you
want today absolutely because I know
when you when you played you said there
was a phase of my life that I kind of
went through it okay was that after the
Heartbreak
I would say yeah it was after but I
think that was just good I I don't know
if that was deliberately driven by
heartbreak I think I was just younger
and I had less serious motivations and I
was less and I wasn't as famous and I
wasn't as rich and I was less interested
in
so
it's not just my current situation that
makes me say this I would say this to
any man
if your woman wouldn't wait for you if
you went to jail for five years why are
you with her
why if she wouldn't wait I know she's
hot I know she's funny I know she makes
you laugh but if you can't sit in that
jail cell with 100
certainty that she's not out with her
friends them in her ear talking [__]
watching Sex in the City whatever it is
and her ending up with some other guy
why are you even buying her dinner for
what sex
like that loyalty to me is the only
thing left that's valuable when I'm
interested we're in jail
we're sitting there saying we have so
much better than most guys
because most guys in jail imagine you're
a normal person you go to jail who's
feeding your family
who's paying the rent
who's feeding your kids I said Tristan
we're in jail and we're suffering but
everybody we love is good
I'm a man I'm supposed to suffer I'll
sit here with the Cockroaches if that
means all my kids eat everyone I care
about eats my mother's fed my mother has
a house roof over her head everybody has
everything they want only person
suffering is me I'll take that all day
most men who go to jail can't say that
another thing that gave me absolute
peace of mind is the women who love me
are waiting for me imagine you go to
jail and you're completely heads over
heels in love with a woman but you know
deep in your heart that she's out in the
club and she's she's stealable you talk
about we talk about thoughts you can't
get out of your head
in jail it's amazing how when you lose
all access to electronics how thoughts
are Amplified
most of us sitting here you've never
been without a phone or without a laptop
or without computer for 93 days you'll
be amazed how loud you can think be
amazed how Vivid your mind is I learned
that if you had the nagging thought on
your head I loved her she cheated on me
before maybe she cheated again she
hasn't written me in three days and then
plus jail
that's why they're all crying that's why
all the men in there were sobbing their
wives are either [__] someone else or
the bills ain't paid it's not just his
situation it's everything else
so now if you're gonna say to me what do
I respect in a woman I respect the
woman's gonna wait for me I have no
interest in a woman oh she's funny she's
cool she's hot don't care don't care is
she going to wait for me and I also know
because of my experience which one's
wood and which ones wouldn't I'm not
stupid because they'll all say they
would they'll all say don't wait because
they're on the jack but I know which
ones are lying because enough women have
lied to me I've seen it so you do need
that experience but once you have the
experience you start looking for
completely other things quick story to
almost validate your point about
experience I like the direction Pat was
going with this about do you want
relationships or sex with a woman
um
quick anecdote your friend Myron fresh
and fit we just did a big live event yep
three days ago it was myself Myron fresh
was sitting on a panel 20 women yeah
and he goes watch this okay master class
Andrew master class he asked all the
women on the panel
average 25 year old woman
you tell me the amount of sexual
partners she's had what yeah the body
count and these women give a wide range
of oh the 3 10 15 20 one girl said a
hundred numbers were crazy it goes down
the list I saw you okay great ladies
show of hands how many of you want a man
with more sexual experience than
yourself
every single girl put their hand up and
they said yeah I want a man with more
experience than myself and the reason
this came about was because Ben Shapiro
reacted to a video of me questioning
Myron all right when should a man get
married and he basically gave a
checklist on you to make a 100 Grand a
year you need to have slept with 50
women you need to have six to 12 months
of savings a checklist checklist
checklist checklist and Ben Shapiro was
like that's disgusting this is a guy
that married the first person that he
had sex with yeah and it was incredible
to see every woman validate everything
that mine was saying everything that you
were saying about experience oh women
respect experience in fact I saw on a TV
show and this was like 10 years ago and
I have no idea what the show was but it
was a show about it was on channel 4 in
the UK and it was a show about sex and
then at a 85 percent of virgin women
would rather sleep with a man who'd
already had sex than a virgin man wow a
virgin woman doesn't even want a man
with
experience you're respected for your
level of sexual experience and women are
naturally demonized for a level of
sexual experience and even the ones in
the west who pretend that's not true the
ones who are fully psyopt wait till they
see a girl they don't like what's the
first thing they call her she's a hoe
[__] [__] first insult out their mouth
is she's promiscuous so they know deep
in their heart promiscuous AC is bad
because they call each other promiscuous
when they want to insult each other so
yeah you absolutely need that experience
to make sure you don't get reconciled
but now in just in my current dating
life and it's good that this is on this
podcast so you know the girls can still
email me it's nice to read but sorry I
don't trust any of you I don't trust any
of you you I don't trust anybody new I
have no new friends no new girlfriend
no I'm not interested in any of it
because what the things I value now are
not the things I value when I was
younger my life was very very different
but I'm glad I had that experience now
so I can see who who is lying and who
isn't I can tell I can just instantly
tell if they would lie or not so let me
let me let me kind of get to the point
of what I was trying to say I'm I'm kind
of uh
more on your side I don't have a Ben
Shapiro story but I think what happens
is is there's also risk for men to fear
uh because that could happen to me so
therefore I will never risk getting into
a relationship because of XYZ so Chelsea
Handler he brings her up right our
initial reaction was look at her you
know she's doing this she's doing that
so let me look up what her life was like
Mario Aguilar says hey Pat did you know
her life I said I have no idea what her
life was
so she's nine years old her brother at
22 who was her hero her first love her
first you know like her second father
loves him he's going mountain climbing
he says Chelsea can't wait to come back
and see you great goes mountain climbing
Falls dies
she's nine yeah she comes back she says
the most painful time of my life right
so then when she needs her father to be
there for her he's gone he's devastated
they had six kids I believe mom and dad
were still together so they're married
and they were doing okay car salesman
making money and then she says till
today I may be successful and she puts
the act in the book I'm still in a lot
of pain she was being interviewed by
Howard Stern
got emotions talking about this okay
so we can sit there laugh about it but
for men similar thing happens as well
when I was a girl broke my heart dude I
will never ever give this risk to that I
think there's also as influencers we
have to also make sure that men know
look just look at the stuff that you did
wrong completely look at the stuff on
how you reposition yourself in the wrong
way right off the bat being too much of
a this this that now just when you go in
like the way you said I love when you
said what are you doing watching this
show we don't watch this in this house
yeah we watch this now impose and have
be earn the respect to be able to impose
your beliefs in a way where you can
coach and leave you nailed it because
what did I say earlier about this
podcast how many times I'm going to
watch it back 15 times yeah because
people I live in experience and I
analyze the experience and I draw every
lesson from that experience if you're a
man who has a heartbroken a lot of them
are so stupid
that they may revert to the mindset that
you've said they may say I don't have my
heart broken again but they haven't sat
there and said why did this happen you
have to know the why to prevent it from
happening you have to analyze the
scenario and learn from it one thing
I'll say about women that's fantastic
one of the best things women are are one
of the things women are best at is
they're a fantastic mirror women are a
reflection if you have any weakness
inside of you or if you have any
downfalls as a person a woman is going
to show you who they are if you're too
emotional if you're too easy to get
angry she'll teach you that she'll teach
you that you can get angry too fast piss
her off
if your dick's small she'll tell you
she'll tell you exactly what is wrong
with you when she is mad she'll sit
there and say you've got a short leg and
your hair cuts [__]
get a new haircut I hate your ugly
they'll tell you exactly what is wrong
with you when you look at your bad or
your previous relationships with women
that went wrong you can sit there and go
okay this all went wrong what has she
taught me she taught me that I'm
emotionally effectable she taught me
that if she ignores me she gets more
attention than if she's nice to me she
taught me you have to sit there and
analyze all the lessons and you have to
implement them it's the same with
absolutely everything but women are a
fantastic mirror a lot of these guys who
resort to that are men who don't have
the self-reflection to sit and say okay
why did this happen
as a man you have to be accountable for
absolutely everything every single thing
that happens is your fault I didn't go
to jail because of Romania I went to
when I was in jail it was my fault I
even though I don't believe it was just
even though I do not believe it was fair
even though I know I am innocent it is
my fault because I didn't have to become
so influential I did it but it's also
it's also my fault when I'm on the Jet
and and living my perfect life I did
that I did the good I did the bad
you made her leave you you did whether
you like it or not
you are the reason she became so cold
you are the reason she doesn't listen
anymore you are the reason she's so
arrogant all of a sudden you are you may
not have identified why yet but if you
identify why then you get into your next
relationship healed and understanding
what you did wrong and learn from it
that's what you have to do but most
these people don't want the self
accountability I love that and they want
to blame the women you have to blame
yourself I know exactly now how to keep
a woman happy so I ain't got nothing to
worry about I've learned my lessons I
know exactly to keep a woman happy I
know when to set a boundary when to be
nice I know exactly what to do because
I've self-analyzed a lot of these red
pill guys they want to do exactly like
you said just run around and just bang
chicks because they've never looked in
the mirror and go why do these chicks
not want to just love me
why am I a [__] up you're not perfect
gone is perfect nobody is perfect you
need to analyze yourself if you fix
those problems I'll give an example
even when I first start getting rich
I was I never worried about gold diggers
because I can't be gold dug but I was
always a bit like weird about of a woman
wants something expensive that I was
always a bit like not because I'm tight
but just like oh we haven't been
together that long why does she want
such an expensive bag and over time I
learned they don't want the expensive
bag because it's an expensive bag it's
because my life is now so expensive and
so Grand when I'm doing hyper expensive
things if I buy a five million dollar
car I look like a dummy if I won't buy a
500 bag I look I look Frugal and
frugality is a form of fear and it looks
fearful I could say no to a 500 bag when
I had no money to the exact same girl
but when you have a certain amount of
money it's not that they're gold digging
you it's just that to you it's nothing
and there's a degree of gesture to it
and I also learned over time that you
know the best way to get new beautiful
women is for them to see your ex and how
well she was treated they love that [__]
they love it when they see all your
because women will do that women stalk
me when I had Instagram they'd stalk me
and they'd see my the lifestyle my girl
lived and as soon as I was single
they're like hey
they want to turn so I was like you know
I actually get a larger Roi just be Mr
Nice cool it's also helped me in my
current situation I've never been mean
to anybody please call him no he was
nice to me bye there's a lot you learn
but you have to self-reflect and learn
and pay attention to the mirror these
men who are afraid of commitment are not
blaming themselves like they should
because I actually truly believe and
this is never going to be make the
misogynistic supercon the BBC I actually
truly believe that women in their hearts
unless they're completely corrupted by
Society women just want to love and be
loved and feel safe that's what they
want they want a man that they can look
at and they truly know he makes the
decisions and I trust him to make the
decisions and I love him for that and I
respect him for that that's what they
truly want when a woman starts turning
on you it's usually because she doesn't
trust you for some reason she doesn't
trust your judgment and that's not
always cheating it can be other things
doesn't trust your judgment as a whole
right if she starts to doubt your
judgment how can she truly love you
you're the protector you're the provider
so if a woman's gone cold on you you
have to sit there and go okay she
doesn't trust my job feedback she
doesn't trust my judgment what have I
done that made her doubt me did I get my
sixth booster injection like a dummy no
wonder she doesn't want dick because I
keep injecting myself with poison
because I'm an idiot
it's not her fault
it's your fault every single time a
woman leaves you as a man is your fault
always even if a richer more successful
more Alpha man stole her from you it's
still your fault because you need to be
like him it always a hundred percent
your fault these men don't take
accountability it's 100 their fault I
got one last topic unless if you got a
follow-up okay so last topic here
phenomenal way to finish that up because
I think sometimes the messaging from
that Community is yeah it's just
everybody is this versus no you got to
take some account sorry before you go on
yeah but that's that's a fantastic point
because people say to me can you turn a
hoe into a housewife and I say listen I
wouldn't want to but I bet I [__]
could bring a woman alive who's gonna
cheat on me with who
look at the guy in Starbucks
Mr KFC no she's with the top G she's got
all the clout she's with the boss she's
in the five star on the Italian Alps
she's on the Gulf Stream she's in the
Bugatti everyone's jealous of her who
the [__] is she gonna cheat with nobody
there's not a girl alive I couldn't get
loyalty from now would I ever want to do
it probably not I like the idea of
exclusivity but once you get to a
certain level yeah if you're that guy
you're that guy let me ask you a
question there's somebody that's single
right now you think you can turn her to
be an exclusive to you her name is Kim
Kardashian how about you she's she's
watching I wouldn't do that too easy I
wouldn't do it too okay he's not married
now no but you know what this is
actually another but by the way I love
what you just said right now but I
wouldn't I love what you just said right
now we were having a conversation the
other day uh about the the relationship
with men how it's supposed to be the boy
the the man relationship just the fact
like I had a friend of mine
dropped it gorgeous like when I tell you
dropped it I mean drop that gorgeous and
everybody loved her and I I could look
at it and say you're dying yeah her and
her boyfriend broke up three years they
were together I get out all she wants to
do is talk to me we're hanging out hey
how about this how about that I said
listen there's no way you and I could
ever be together no way because you
dated the guy that was my best friend I
like you a lot you're beautiful you're
gonna find somebody it's just not going
to be 100 and she went a different
direction but that that right there is
the values that must be taught 100
because I think the same way we have to
teach the values of what it is to be
running mates men hey man if you're my
circle that's the expectation but it's
the same way that you have to also you
know lead your woman to say if this is
going to be a relationship here's the
standard as well 100 and and and you
know what maybe I'm gonna get a little
bit sentimental in my old age here we go
but I am
let's say I need a girl right
and she's 23 24 and she's been with a
guy for six or seven years and he loves
her with all his heart and she she's
talking to me part of me feels bad I'm
like this is just like shooting fish in
a barrel this isn't even fair this guy's
gonna be a heartbroken man he's going to
be devastated when he realizes she's
with me he's gonna he's gonna it's gonna
hurt him because he's gonna know there
is no
[__] at all no matter what he types in
that text it's done and I actually feel
bad and I'll say to chicks you know what
if you break up with him properly
leave it a while I'm getting to that
point now I'll be like not while you're
still you're still kind of talking to
him though I feel bad it's too easy I
feel bad so when I say I wouldn't do it
to Kanye I actually mean that [__] is
not worth me her I don't even know him
but just like he loved her a lot
I feel bad I just couldn't do it I just
wouldn't do it I can't show on a soft
side tape I just would I just wouldn't
do it but it's also an interesting point
you say about friends that's super
interesting I could leave any of my
girls with my friends for 20 years in a
jail cell and they would never touch her
I know it I know it and I do believe
that birds of a feather flock together
and when I've had a lot of guys email me
as well and they say hey man uh my
friend slept with my girlfriend uh you
know I don't know what to do about it
and I will say that's because you're a
[__]
you're a [__] and I'll tell you why
you're a [__] because you're rolling
with [__] which means you must be one
because I'll tell you what none of my
friends nobody on my team would ever
ever do that to me ever if my me and my
girl split up she is gone she is done
they would never touch her in a million
years because that's the quality of man
I roll with because that's the quality
of man I am you become a better man
you'll get better friends and this [__]
won't happen to you if your own friends
are snaking you for [__] you're
probably the kind of guy who snakes your
own friends for [__] so I blame you
it's your fault you know I saw a clip
the other day you know what Shannon
sharp is Shannon I saw a clip from uh
Shannon sharp the other day he said uh
uh he found the love of his life he she
was married
he paid for her to get a divorce from
him because she knew that was he knew
that was his
that's a such a weird angle I don't know
if you heard what I just said so you're
married oh you're mine I'm gonna pay you
to go divorce your guy to be with me
what do you think is going to happen
later on to you when another opportunity
Rises but again
social media is so open would influence
that the a boy or a man at the wrong
time can see a message like that
thinking that's what it is to be a man
and as a person that's got a lot of
influence some of these things need to
be unpacked let's go to the last message
here
so uh Mel Gibson just recently announced
that he's doing a four-part documentary
on the 32 billion dollar pedophilia
business I don't know if you saw this or
not I did yeah this just came out
yesterday and we talked about BBC
earlier you know and BBC and Phillip
Schofield and ITB and all these guys and
they had another guy back in the days
Jimmy uh Savile you know who there's a
documentary on him that guy's darker
than a lot of these guys and they knew
and they kept them for a long time and
stories have been out there Woody Allen
we talked about Woody Allen we talked
about a lot of different guys on Woody
Allen married
the stepdaughter when she was yeah five
six seven years old it ends up Mary and
hers hey you know he's one of the
greatest such and such of all time
um
and and that whole industry of what it's
doing
some will say well you know it's not
really as real as people think it is
some will say it is some will say well
this whole movement is because of
because of that you know uh you lgbtq
there's that's taking place with kids
and it's a next step of what we're going
to next what are your thoughts with the
topic of pedophilia
yeah okay
first thing I would never kill myself
it's the first thing
right I'm giving you easy questions
that's a soft topic no but it's true but
that's the final line of morality
they're trying to pierce
like I said I have no problem with gay
people and then we talked about lgbtq
and how they're trying to mix it all
together and take people who are on the
extreme end of the spectrum with people
who live fairly normal lives you can be
a gay person this is another thing I
want to make clear you can be a gay
person and live a very normal life you
can also be a gay person to be
degenerate
deciding to get naked in front of
children has nothing to do with your
sexual orientation that's just the fact
that you're a degenerate person it
doesn't matter if you sleep with a man
or a woman the fact that you want to go
and walk around naked in front of kids
is degenerate Behavior regardless of
sexual orientation has nothing to do
with it it's only accepted if you're
homosexual if you're a heterosexual it's
a crime for some reason if it's a
homosexual it's not a crime but it's the
same act and it's degenerate It's the
final line the final line is children
it's the final line of sexual morality
that they're trying to attack they've
attacked every other line It's the final
line they're trying to pierce and
I think a lot of this
pedophilia comes down to
I think a lot of it comes down to
control so yeah what Mel Gibbs is doing
is super interesting it's super
interesting that he's attacking the most
liberal establishment on the planet
super interesting he's hacking Hollywood
which is obviously the heart of the
liberal propaganda machine and he's
saying they're the worst people on Earth
and I sit and say well if you take these
people outside of Hollywood would they
matter this is a really interesting
point you can actually apply this nearly
any job
if you took you away from your sales job
or took me away from my role or you away
from let's say you had a sales job a
specific company
you would still be a good communicator
you'd still know how to speak you'd
still have Charisma you'd still be a man
of status you still know how to walk you
still have a presence you still you
still know how to behave right there are
certain people in certain establishments
where if you strip them of their title
they're nothing if you took Harvey
Weinstein away a Weinstein whatever his
name is away from Hollywood he's just a
fat old ugly dork
that's all he is he's only something
because of Hollywood outside of that
he's nothing these are the people who
end up using their influence in whatever
sphere they're in to do negative things
because outside of it they ain't [__] if
you're a real G if you're a real man if
I was in Hollywood I was a real man I
wouldn't have to use Hollywood to get
girls I'm fine
I think a lot of this stuff is run I
think a lot of these people who are
doing these things are just not very
good or very impressive people
I don't oh yeah you may be a big shot in
Hollywood delete that from your resume
who are you oh you ain't [__] sit down
and talk to these people what have you
even done with your life you ain't [__]
you made it to the top of Hollywood by
what who even knows how you got there
wink wink you go out there through
whatever
so I think that's what a lot of this
stuff is and going back everything we've
been saying so far Andrew how do you
solve pedophilia I think of a man has a
healthy sexual relationship with women
and has options and feels respected by
women and enjoys the company of women
and women like him and admire him and
look up to him he will have no desire to
go down the root of sexual perversion
and Chase children I don't think he ever
would why would he right what my cousin
said was only a joke
but sometimes there's a degree of Truth
in the humor
he's a young good-looking black guy on
the football team he gets girls why why
would he do this dumb [__] where do you
see some fat overweight video game loser
they're the ones on the on the TV doing
it so once again like nearly any problem
on Earth whether it's pedophilia whether
it's school shooting whether it's men's
mental health whether it's women's
mental health whether it's female
promiscuity whether no matter what it is
whether it's crime no matter what it is
how do you fix the problem by building
men of caliber by building men of
capability and status and honor and
dignity and by building men of ability
to be good standing citizens who are
respected by their peers all of it comes
back to improving men all of it every
single problem you can possibly name
even here comes back to building strong
men of capability who are respected
that's all it's the Baseline of humanity
men always has been the Baseline of
humanity and that's why nearly every
problem we can name whether it's
pedophilia whether it's anything else
school shooting whatever all of them are
in a direct negative correlation with
masculinity now it's masculinity
plummets all this garbage is going up
through the roof is that a coincidence
absolutely not really not it's it's you
can literally see it with a graph and
you can see it happening saving the way
men think and operate growing a new
generation of men who understand they
have duty to themselves their last name
and God literally Saves the World
all of it and I'm telling you the reason
is Hollywood garbage happens is because
outside of Hollywood none of them people
are mildly impressive in any regard and
that's why they have to do the
disgusting heinous things they do and
that's why they're going to attack me
and pretend I'm a [__] predator and
that I'm the bad guy and that I'm
dangerous to women when truly people
like Phillip Schofield are the ones who
are doing it but they're part of the
club
and that's what actually upsets me
truthfully I'm a difficult man to affect
and I understand that I'm in the middle
of a war here and I understand that one
way or another with God on my side I
will win but it is extremely frustrating
to have people who commit x-crime
with impunity accuse you of x-crime
that's a very uniquely annoying scenario
when somebody who does something
themselves accuses you of it when you're
innocent not allegedly they've been
caught caught and they accuse you of it
big difference and then they sit there
and go it's a terrible thing to do you
do it all of these liberals and Elites
attacking me do it and I don't and I'm
the one who's sitting in a [__]
dungeon for it
insane what should be to punish them for
that
I think attacking innocence is the most
heinous thing you can possibly do did
you hear what the Santa's announced no
death penalty for that well I think
absolutely they're innocent attacking
innocence is the biggest Act of
cowardice it's cowardice attacking
innocent is the biggest possible Act of
cowardice even you don't shoot an
unarmed man
even in war the Geneva Convention
there's supposed to be a degree of rule
someone can't defend themselves there's
no need to hurt them these people can't
defend themselves
attacking innocence is the most heinous
of all crimes and Children of the
absolutely most innocent thing on the
planet and I'd like to think that I'm
rational enough that not much would
drive me to murder but I know it would
happen if someone hurt my children
should they be castrated I think they
should face an extremely heinous
punishment now the death penalty is
fantastic I also think
from what I've just been through and
there's only three short months I think
a nice long life of solitary confinement
will do just fine
I really truly believe it and I truly
believe that we need to make that clear
to the world but the problem is the
world we're living in the people who are
in charge of the world have no no
obligation or no intention of stopping
what's happening they want to accelerate
what's happening that's what's scary
because they could put punishments in
place would genuinely stop this [__] and
I don't think they are in fact they're
promoting this [__] and trying to say
that you're born that way because when
you're born that way once again you have
no control it's not your fault it's not
your fault you touch that kid you were
born that way not your fault you're fat
you were born that way not your fault
you're a school shooter you were born
that way this is why I have a problem
with psychologist every single time you
ask them anything it's not your fault
it's something else's fault or someone
else's fault and I don't accept that I
accept absolutely not a ruthless
personal accountability absolutely
everything is my fault every action I
undertake is completely my fault if I do
something wrong it is my fault and I
should be punished for it me and that
should be implied on every single other
man on the planet and the second we
start doing that dumb [__] might stop
it's a powerful message we're at the end
of it so if you got anything well this
is gonna be more of a lighthearted
question to end on a lighter note but it
but you're going to ask about who's a
better actor
so I got a question do you do you like
both actors De Niro hates Trump right
yeah
yeah so this is actually a funny
question lighthearted question but it is
about your legacy sure I don't know if
there's anybody in the world when I say
a country
oh I'm going to this country they say
well you must be going to CT yeah if I
told my mom we're not supposed to talk
about this yeah hey Mom I'm going to
Romania are you going to see Andrew Tate
yeah if I told that hey anybody I'm
going to see going to Romania they're
going to say oh you're going to go see
Tate that's how synonymous you are with
Romania yeah irony is that Romania is
the country that locked you up there's
one other person that's associated with
the country if I say the country you
know the name they're not even a real
person that person
is from the country of Kazakhstan yeah
you I say Kazakhstan you think of Borah
Ironically in a twist of fate in 2006
when the movie Borat came out they
actually banned the movie yeah they
didn't want the people of Kazakhstan to
see the movie yeah because it was uh
insulting great insults for the people
of Kazakhstan Ironically in 2020 after
covet it became a global brand
Kazakhstan yeah the the tourism board
um
basically created ads and embraced the
the moniker Kazakhstan very nice as a
way to drive tourism wow to Kazakhstan
so in a twist of fate they banned the
movie
15 years later they're embracing Borah
so my question to you is when you're
innocent yeah and you're Scout free yeah
what will Romania do to make amends for
what's happened to you will it be
Romania what color is your Bugatti yeah
what are they gonna say that's a really
good question because I I I love this
country I chose to live here
I think that they have done themselves a
massive disservice but I don't think
it's Romanians as a whole 99.9 of
Romanians I interact with apologize to
me every Romanian I see says sorry even
the police officers who come and check
my house arrest apologize to me there's
a select few Romanians who have done
irreparable damage to this country and
they're gonna have to deal the
consequences of that if they have a
conscience at all most Romanians
understand exactly what's happening and
if opposed apologized to me and are good
people
I think I did a lot for this country in
terms of Tourism I don't think it was
mentioned much before me yes and
truthfully it is a safe place and it is
a beautiful place and you can carve a
good life here but I think they've
certainly scared away a lot of high net
worth individuals from ever moving here
because they will seize all of their
things and throw you in a jail cell so
we'll have to see how they try and
recover from the mess they've made and
the few people who have done this and
it's a small group are ever going to be
held responsible and if the country of
Romania is mature enough they will
understand that it's a very small group
of people who have made a very big mess
last question
what source of power do you get from
this
this is a this is actually a mud draw
from Power a mudra for power I think
it's I'm not sure which yoga or Hindu or
something it's from it is a mudra from
power but my father used to sit and play
chess like this
is how we played chess so I stole it I
stole it when I would be losing chess
games in chess tournaments when I was a
kid I was like [__] I'm losing I need
power [__] let me do like dad
sometimes it would work sometimes it
wouldn't but um I just adopted it
because it was his hand symbol so I just
copied it and there's a lot of theories
online that you know it's occultices the
cultistat I let the conspiracy theories
run but it's far more simple than that
there's lots of pictures of my dad doing
and I copied it that's all it is respect
so again five hours felt like five
minutes just like last time I can't tell
you how many people last time said glad
you came back you know people wanted to
watch every second of it this was great
and uh we got a couple gifts we want to
give you the audience that's watching
this there's a couple things we want to
do for you we want the world to see this
interview and a lot of you guys will be
part of History five of these hats
future looks bright will be signed by
Tate and on Twitter we will pick uh
anybody that posts the interview there
would hashtag Tate pbd for the interview
when we released this five of you were
going to get these hats sent over to you
for you to pick them up and aside from
that I got a gift for you as well
amazing let's start off with the first
one the first one is a Bible okay okay
now whatever you choose to do with this
whether you give it to uh Tristan or you
keep it this is a special Bible because
it's from 1870. okay this is not a newer
Bible it's 1870. we wanted to give you a
a gift that would have a lot of meaning
behind it we have to go look for this
Brandon worked very hard to find us we
finally found it so this is a gift from
us to you brother I absolutely love
things like this thank you very much and
one of our vice presidents in our
company has uh bozie who is a Muslim
himself but we love this guy respectable
leader his family we were calling Iran
to get a high quality uh Quran with a
lot of meaning behind it the Quran that
his mom passed down to them is the one
he gave to us for us to give to you can
we look for this all over the place so
this is a gift to you as well we know
this is important to you if you open it
up with the presentation in it I hope
you appreciate that
um I think it's right there so this is
something that's been passed from family
to family to family it's incredible we
hope you appreciate that too and then
the last one is a book I read Years Ago
by a guy that's an interesting guy C.S
Lewis it's one of the best books I've
read Mere Christianity if you've never
read it he's an interesting guy Oxford
professor
who went from being an atheist to all of
a sudden believing in God and his
transition to it it's wild if you've
never read it highly recommend you
reading that I think you will enjoy it
this is incredible I'm truly humbled and
uh
yeah if they send me back I have plenty
to read I'll take them
thank you very much when you're reading
to the once again brother really enjoy
this thank you thank you thank you thank
you my neck is an application which
allows you to take a minute to connect
with influencers from all around the
world my name is Andrew Tate and I'm
available to speak directly to you on
minute